ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS FATE
BACKER FORTRESS BRADFORD COME
BY OTHER COURTS HEAVY DALLY DON
TORONTO AIKMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HURTS BERG WEST SO HER
TADO JONES CAM AUGER LAYERED.
FLAVOR THE MOON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MIN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF VOGUE PAM FORTUNE TINO
ROSSI RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG MY CASKEY. WINNER WILL.
THAT IS IN GENERAL A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REALM IN
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENIOR SENATOR
WIENER. AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY
SENATOR BATES. GENERALLY. ONE
MINUTE. YEAH.
MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. MY
APOLOGIES- THIS PRESIDENT
BECAUSE- THE COLORS ARE THE
AUTHOR MARGARET WHEATLEY SAYS
THERE IS NO POWER GREATER THAN-A COMMUNITY DISCOVERING WHAT IT
CARES ABOUT. ASK WHAT IS
POSSIBLE NOT WHAT'S WRONG AND
KEEP ASKING NOTICE WHAT YOU
CARE ABOUT AND ASSUME THAT MANY
OTHERS SHARE YOUR DREAMS.
LOVING AND MERCIFUL GOD YOU'VE
GIVEN US THE COURAGE AND
DETERMINATION TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS THAT MATTER TO
FORGE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL AFFECT MANY PEOPLE IN THE
FUTURE WE CONTINUE TO TRUST IN
THE OUTPOURING OF YOUR SPIRIT.
AS A RELY ON THE GENEROSITY OF
HUMAN GOODNESS OF EACH OTHER WE
MAKE OUR PRAYER IN YOUR NAME
AND I'M. MEMBERS HANDOVER
HEARTS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
PLEDGING ALLEGIANCE TO THE
GREATEST NATION ON EARTH. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
SAMUS. IT IS. MEMBERS IS JUST A
REMINDER PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE THIRTY FIVE AND SENATE
RULE FIFTY SIX DEBATE MAY BE
LIMITED TO FIVE MINUTES FOR THE
AUTHOR OR FOR MANAGER WHICH
INCLUDES OPENING CLOSING
STATEMENTS AND THREE MINUTES
TOTAL FOR SINNERS SEARCH IF
THEY CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN
DEBATE AND WE JUST SHARE THAT
JUST TO TRY TO. KEEP EVERYTHING
MOVING ALONG TODAY. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT WILL BE
DEALING WITH FIRST FOR MOVING
TO. FOLLOW NUMBER FOUR MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE TEAM
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD CONVENE READ REPORTS FROM
COMMITTEE WILL BE JEANERETTE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES ARE THERE ANY AT THIS
TIME. C. NINE. MOVING ON NOW.
MEMBERS REMOVING THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE NOW LOOKING AT SECOND
READING FILE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
900-114-0670. 1-055-155-1621.
SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE
SIXTY SIX THE GREEN WOOD BEAM
OR AT. MINIMUM TO GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE SENATOR LAYER ARE YOU
PREPARED HE IS. THANK YOU. MR
PRESIDENT FINAL ITEM TWENTY
THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
SERRA BARS FOR REAPPOINTMENT
AND DANNY BAKEWELL SENIOR FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE STATE PARKS
AND RECREATION COMMISSION. A
MIS BARTH IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SEMPERVIRENS FUND MR
BAKEWELL IS CHAIR AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. OF THE-
BAKEWELL COMPANY IN THE LOS
ANGELES SENTINEL AND NOW I
WATCH TIMES THESE APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST TWENTY
FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THE APPOINTEES. SENATOR
DORADO I JUST QUICKLY I JUST
WANNA GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT
AND- APPRECIATION TO MISTER BIG
WELL FOR HIS HISTORY OF OUR
COMMUNITY WORK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APARTMENT. IN
NINETEEN NINE THERE'S NO CLOSE
MOUNT SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ACTIONS I
BASE. BACKER I PORCHES RADFORD
I COME BY OTHER HYPERTENSIVE HI
DALLY. GOD I TORONTO I ADMIN
GLAZER ARE YOU CONSOLIDATE I
GROW. HERTZBERG WEST SO. HER
TADO I JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI LABOUR FIVE THE MOON
I ACQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO- CHOKO. PAN
FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW HI RALPH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE STERN
I'M BERG HI WE CASKEY FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NOW. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE THE CALL MEMBERS SHOW
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE DOOR
OPEN SO YOU CAN ADD ON A LITTLE
LATER SO NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO ASSUME THE THIRD
READING. QUESTION THE THIRD
READING. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS FIRST UP IS FALL ITEM.
ONE FIVE FIVE. BY SENATOR
RUSSELL FOR SOON SOON- CINNAMON
MEDINA SHE'S READY MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AND ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. AB
ONE ONE WILL REQUIRE HIGH
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE ETHNIC
STUDIES STARTING IN ACADEMIC
YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. AND REQUIRE STUDENTS TO
TAKE AT LEAST ONE SEMESTER OF
AN EIGHTEEN T. APPROVED UP NEXT
THAT IS COURSE TO GRADUATE
STARTING IN. TWENTY TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THIRTY. CALIFORNIA HAS
ONE OF THE LARGEST AND MOST
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATIONS IN
THE NATION ETHNIC MINORITIES
ACCOUNT FOR OVER 71% OFTHE
STUDENT POPULATION WITH MORE
THAN NINETY LANGUAGES SPOKEN IN
DISTRICT SCHOOLS SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE EXTRAORDINARILY POP
PROUD OF. AS CIVIL UNREST AND
RACIAL TENSIONS HAVE RISEN
ACROSS THE NATION CALIFORNIA'S
PRIDES ITSELF AS BEING A
PROGRESSIVE BEACON. WORKING THE
CHART A MORE EQUITABLE FUTURE
IN ORDER TO BUILD RACIAL
JUSTICE IN THE STATE AND
COUNTRY OUR STUDENTS NEED TO
LEARN A MORE INCLUSIVE HISTORY
OF AMERICA AND THAT HISTORY
INCLUDES A DIVERSE EXPERIENCES
AND PERSPECTIVES. OF
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IT HAS
BEEN MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS
SINCE ETHNIC STUDIES WAS
ESTABLISHED AS AN ACADEMIC
DISCIPLINE HE HAD DECADES OF
SCHOLARSHIP AND ACTIVISM. UP
DESPITE THAT ETHNIC STUDIES HAS
NOT BEEN UNIFORMLY INTEGRATED
INTO K. THROUGH TWELVE
CLASSROOMS. WILL ETHNIC STUDIES
AWAITS STATE WIDE ADOPTION
DOZENS OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING SOME OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST HAVE TAKEN IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO OFFER THESE
IMPORTANT CLASSES. STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND PARENTS HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT ETHNIC
STUDIES PROGRAMS IT'S TIME THAT
OUR STATE JOIN THEM AS WELL IN
MARCH THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION APPROVES THE MODEL
CURRICULUM FOR ETHNIC STUDIES.
THE FIVE DIVERSE CAUCUSES HAVE
WORKED FOR SEVERAL YEARS THEY
STAND TOGETHER AND SUPPORT A B.
ONE ONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DESCRIPTION OF THE VET
CENTER PAT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS I AS CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I TO STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE
OH ONE ONE RECOGNIZE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE AUTHOR SO
THERE HAS BEEN DENIED AND BRING
TOGETHER AND COME TO AN
AGREEMENT AMONG THE FIVE. PERCY
KAKISSIS ETHNIC STUDIES IS
IMPORTANT TO THE EDUCATION OF
OUR YOUTH EXACTLY THAT'S WHEN I
PUT. THANK YOUS CENTER WINNER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT I RISE PERSONALLY BUT
ALSO AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS I
WANNA- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE OR ONE ON ONE I
THANK THE AUTHOR OF MR MEDINA
AS WELL AS THE LATINO BLACK AND
API CARCASSES AFTER WORKING
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
JEWISH CAUCUS REALLY OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS- AND FOR
WORKING VERY VERY HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE PUBLISHING
THE- IMPORTANT SHARED GOAL OF.
OF HAVING I THINK SAUDIS IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND MAKING SURE THAT
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS AT ALL OF
OUR CHILDREN ARE ABLE TO LEARN-
NOT JUST ABOUT- A WHITEWASH
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY- BUT
THE ACTUAL LIVED EXPERIENCES.
OF SO MANY PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHICH HAS
SO FREQUENTLY BEEN SIMPLY
ERASED- FROM- FROM AMERICAN
HISTORY HI SIR THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS
YOU MAY KNOW THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THE I THINK STUDIES
PROPOSED DRAFT CURRICULUM
PROPOSED BY THE ICC HAS SOME
VERY VERY PROBLEMATIC ASPECTS
THAT WERE FRANKLY ANTI SEMITIC.
WE WORKED VERY VERY HARDAND I
THINK I CAN SEE OF THE CENTER
FROM SANTA MONICA IN
PARTICULAR- AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WAS NOT A PART OF THE
CURRICULUM THE CURRICULUM WOULD
NOT BE TEACHING ANTI SEMITISM
OR ANY FORM OF HATE AND THE
FINAL VERSION WAS A DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENT AND SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE ALL RALLIED AROUND- AND
DEFENDED I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INCLUDING- IN THE
LEGISLATION- WHEN I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FROM PASADENA
FOR WORKING. WITH US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAD STRONG
GUARDRAILS SIGNS LEGISLATION
THEY'RE VERY STRONG GUARDRAILS
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT WE'RE
TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TEACH ANTI.
SEMITISM OR ANY OTHER FORM OF
HE- I WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
BACK DOOR WERE PEOPLE CAN. I GO
TO LOCALS THIS. AND TRY TO THE
RIGINAL VERSION- THE DRAFT
VERSION THE REJECTED DRAFTS
VERSION SOMEHOW BACK TOWARD
AND- THIS LEGISLATION WILL
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING-
AND SO I. RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND ASPIRIN I WILL.
CUSE CENTER LAMONT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTY ONE OH
ONE AND IT HAS BEEN UNDOUBTEDLY
INCREDIBLE EFFORT ON FOR
DECADES I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WHILE THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
A BILL HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS- WHEN
I GOT ON TO THE SCHOOL BOARD
TEN YEARS AGO- Z. WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE DO TO
HAVE ETHNIC STUDIES- AT THE
TIME IT WAS ETHNIC STUDIES AS
AN ELECTIVE. AND VERY OFTEN THE
CONVERSATION HAVE A WELL HOW DO
YOU MEASURE ACADEMIC SUCCESS-
WHAT KINDS OF ELEMENTS DO YOU
PUT IN PLACE TO ENSURE- THE
ETHNIC STUDIES IS MEETING BOTH
THE OBJECTIVE IN AN ACADEMIC
WAY AND IN OTHER WAYS AND WHAT
WE FOUND- FOR SANTA BARBARA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
DOES HAVE THIS AS A HIGH SCHOOL
REQUIREMENT IN PLACE- IT IS
THAT THERE WERE MULTIPLE
OBJECTIVES AND SOMETIMES OUR
TRADITIONAL MEANS. TO ASSESS
WE'RE NOT THERE- AND WE HAD TO
FIND WAYS TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITY ALL OF OUR
STUDENT COMMUNITY FELT INCLUDED
IN A HISTORY TOLD IN THE
CLASSROOMS AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS REALLY WHAT IS- IN
FRONT OF US- AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE YOU KNOW THE
AUTHOR IT IS SIMPLY CALLING
FROM RIVERSIDE BUT ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE- TOO MANY TO
NAME WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
MAKING SURE. THAT THIS IS
SHAPED IN A WAY THAT DOES RIGHT
FOR THE STUDENT- BUT ALSO DOES
RIGHT FOR THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT FOLLOW ABOUT WHAT IT WHAT
IT'S LIKE ESPECIALLY TO LIVE IN
AN INCLUSIVE- AND VERY DIVERSE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A SPECIAL
SHOUT OUT AND THANKS TO THE
CHAIRS AND VICE CHAIRS OF ALL
OF OUR CAUCUSES WHO HAVE ALSO
BEEN INVOLVED IN SUPPORTING
THIS SO I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT I'M WITH THE
RECOGNITION THAT THE VOTE TO
DATE HAS BEEN DECADES. IN THE
MAKING FOR THE STATE. THANK YOU
SENATOR I'LL- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WANT TO
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
HAVE BEEN STATED- WE'RE WE'RE
CERTAINLY HOPEFUL THAT THIS
WILL LEAD TO A AN INCLUSIVE
CURRICULUM ONE THAT GIVES
INSPIRATION TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CALIFORNIA%
STUDENTS TO THINK CRITICALLY
ABOUT AMERICAN HISTORY- AND
ALSO TO LEARN DIFFERENT STORIES
NEWS STORIES- STORIES BUT OF
COURSE THEY'RE ONLY KNEW IN THE
CURRICULUM BUT THEY'RE OLD
STORIES OFTEN TIMES THAT HAVE
BEEN UNDER TOLD. ABOUT
STRUGGLES AND CHALLENGES THAT
SO MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
FACED OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SUN
THIS IS A I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OUR STATE. AS WE
AS WE LEARN TO LIVE AND THRIVE
TOGETHER IN A IN A TRULY
PLURALISTIC SOCIETY. AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY. I WANTED JUST A CLOSE
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE SENATOR FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND- ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY FOLKS IN. JEWISH
COMMUNITY ARE MEETING
COMMUNITY- SOME SOUTH ASIAN
COMMUNITIES THAT SECTOR WHERE
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ORIGINAL DRAFT- INCLUSION
ISSUES AND THEN AND IN A COUPLE
CASES SOME SOME OUT RIGHT-
DISCRIMINATORY CONTENT. IN IN
THE IN THE ORIGINAL VERSION
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THIS BILL. CONTAINS A SPECIAL
GUARD RAILS TO PROTECT. AGAINST
DISCRIMINATORY CONTENT. SO THAT
WE REALLY CAN. SURE THIS IS
GOING TO BE A COURSE IT'S GONNA
GONNA CONNECT TO TEACH OUR KIDS
TO. HERE O LIVE IN AND THRIVE
IN A TRULY TRULY PLURALISTIC
SOCIETY THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT GETTING TO KNOW EACH
OTHER STORIES AND CULTURES- AND
THEN TO LIVE AND GROW AND
THRIVE TOGETHER. AND SO. I HAVE
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION AS WAS MENTIONED
WORKED SO HARD TO NOT COME TO A
DRAFT MODEL CURRICULUM. THAT
MET THOSE GOALS- IT'S WHAT
WE'RE CERTAINLY HOPING FOR WITH
THIS COURSE. AND WITH ALL OF
THAT WORK HAVING BEEN DONE AND
ALL THE WORK OF THE ACTIVISTS
OVER SO MANY YEARS- I WILL I
STIR I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MEANT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'M
PROUD TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND I JUST
WANT TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY OWN EXPERIENCE WHEN I
GREW UP HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
THERE WERE NOT A LOT OF ASIAN
AMERICANS AND I WENT TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WITH AND
THERE WERE NO KOREAN AMERICANS
UNTIL MAYBE I WAS IN FIFTH
GRADE- NOBODY REALLY KNEW MUCH
ABOUT. IT THE ASIAN AMERICAN
EXPERIENCE- NOBODY KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT KOREA. AND IT
REALLY WASN'T UNTIL COLLEGE AND
BEYOND. THAT I LEARNED WHY THEY
WERE SPAT POSSIBLY OF ASIAN
AMERICANS IN THIS STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY. ABOUT SOME OF THE ANTI
ASIAN IMMIGRATION STATUTES THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE AND-
PREVENTED ASIAN AMERICANS FROM
IMMIGRATING HERE UNTIL.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE OR LATER.
AND IT'S NOT MY EXPERIENCE
UNFORTUNATELY. IS NOT UNIQUE
AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT IT'S
NOT YOU NEED TODAY IF THERE
ARE. MANY MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE FIRST GENERATION SECOND
GENERATION THIRD GENERATION
AMERICANS. WHO DON'T EXPERIENCE
OUR OWN CULTURE THEY'RE NOT
TAUGHT ABOUT THEIR CULTURES ARE
NOT TAUGHT ABOUT. THE
EXPERIENCES OF PEOPLE LIKE
THEM. NOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
ETHNIC STUDIES DOES AND IT IS-
BYE I THINK WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
A THOUGHTFUL PROCESS AND I WANT
TO CONGRATULATE AND LAW THE
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL. BECAUSE
THEY WENT THROUGH A THOUGHTFUL
PROCESS TO TRY TO INOCULATE
THIS BILL FROM SOME OF THE
CRITICISMS- WHICH WERE SO
MISGUIDED THIS IS NOT AN ANTI
WHITE BILL. IT'S NOT AN ANTI
AMERICAN BILL IT'S A BILL THAT
TRIES TO TEACH A BALANCED
HISTORY OF WHAT AMERICA IS
REALLY ABOUT AND WE KNOW HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION MAKE OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY STRONGER BUT
FOR THAT TO REALLY WORK WE HAVE
TO START TEACHING. A DIVERSE
AND INCLUSIVE CURRICULUM AND SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I. BILL
BECAUSE THIS IS CRITICAL FOR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO- YOU
KNOW COUPLE WHOSE PARENTS OR
GRANDPARENTS COME HERE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES TO LEARN ABOUT
THEIR OWN EXPERIENCES AND
THEY'RE- OFF FOR BEARS CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS COUNTRY.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER. DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THE SITE ON SCENE NINE
SENATOR. OUT SENATOR CAMPBELL
OUR COPIER WHICH- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO ADD MY
VOICE OF THANKS TO THE AUTHOR
OF THIS DISK THESE KINDS OF
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HISTORY AND
ABOUT. THE DETAILS OF HISTORY
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT AND
FRANKLY MOST OF US. I GREW UP
HAVING NO CONTEXT IN WHICH TO
UNDERSTAND OUR OWN IMMIGRATION
EXPERIENCES COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE WE ALL ARE
IMMIGRANTS WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF NATIVE AMERICANS WHO. WHO
CAME HERE WAY BEFORE EVERYBODY
ELSE AND THAT LACK OF
INFORMATION REALLY HURTS US AND
IT IT HURTS US IN WAYS THAT.
THIS BILL CAN HELP TO RESOLVE
SOMEWHERE I REALLY WANNA
RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR LISTENING CAREFULLY TO THE
OPPOSITION THAT HAD SOME REALLY
VALID ISSUES AND FOR TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AND
WORKING. GENTLY TO CREATE THE
BEST BILL POSSIBLE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EYE BUT
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA US. THANK YOU- LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THERE'S BEEN MUCH
IN THE NEWS ABOUT ETHNIC
STUDIES AS IT IS COUPLED WITH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY WHICH IS
REALLY WHAT PARENTS ACROSS THIS
NATION ARE MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT. AND THOSE WHO TEACH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY HAVE-
STATED PUBLICLY THAT ETHNIC
STUDIES AND CRITICAL RACE
THEORY GO HAND IN HAND THAT
THEY GO TOGETHER. AND THAT IS
THE REASON WHY YOU'VE SEEN SO
MANY SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS
ACROSS THE STATE AND THIS
NATION WHERE PARENTS ARE UP IN
ARMS ABOUT THIS TYPE OF
IDEOLOGY BEING TAUGHT TO THEIR
CHILDREN. I THINK THERE ARE
CERTAINLY MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY WHO HAVE THEIR IDEA OF
WHAT IT IS TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES AND THAT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY BENIGN.
THAT WE'RE JUST TEACHING-
CULTURAL HISTORY AND IT'S
SOMETHING TO BE LAUDED BUT IF
YOU DIG DEEPER INTO WHAT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY TEACHERS
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE I THINK HE
WOULD- PERHAPS THINK OTHERWISE.
AS AN EXAMPLE IN CUPERTINO
CALIFORNIA- IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL- LET'S SEE WAS THIRD
GRADERS WERE REQUIRED TO
DECONSTRUCT THEIR RACIAL AND
SEXUAL IDENTITIES. THEN RANK
THEMSELVES ACCORDING TO THEIR
POWER AND PRIVILEGE- IN
MISSOURI TEACHERS IN DIVERSITY
TRAINING. WERE REQUIRED TO
LOCATE THEMSELVES ON THE
OPPRESSION MATRIX IN NEW YORK.
THE SCHOOL PRINCIPAL SENT
PARENTS LITERATURE INCLUDING
TOOLS FOR ACTION AND TOUTING
WHITE TRADERS AND ADVOCATING
FOR FULL WHITE ABOLITION.
PORTLAND OREGON- THEY ARE
TAUGHT TO DEVELOP AND IDENTIFY
THEIR- WHITE IDENTITY AND HOW
THEY HAVE. TAKEN PART IN
OPPRESSING OTHERS THIS IS NOT
WHAT WE SHOULD BE TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN- AND I WILL REMIND YOU
THAT IF I CAN FIND THE QUOTE
HERE- ABRAM CANDY WHO HAS
WRITTEN A BOOK. A RELATING TO
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND IS
REALLY- THE SPOKESMAN FOR THIS
EFFORT HIS WORDS. WERE THE ONLY
REMEDY TO PRESENT TO
DISCRIMINATION IS FUTURE
DISCRIMINATION. I DON'T THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE WANT
TO BE TEACHING OUR CHILDREN ARE
OUR KIDS AREN'T BORN. HATING
OTHER PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THEIR
RACE THEY ARE TIED TO THAT N
THE LAST THING WE NEED IS STATE
SANCTIONED. RACISM BEING TAUGHT
IN OUR SCHOOLS- AGAIN YOU CAN
WE CAN TALK FOR HOURS ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF TEACHING OUR KIDS
ABOUT THEIR HISTORY AND THE
CULTURE AND WHAT FORM OF THIS
GREAT NATION BUT TO TEACH THEM
TO HATE ONE ANOTHER BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE IS ABSOLUTELY
INEXCUSABLE I WOULD. URGE YOUR
NO VOTE. COME OVER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AS A VICE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE OH ONE AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
TRI ETHNIC CAUCUSES FOR- REALLY
LEANING IN. AND HAVING SOME
REAL. UNCOMFORTABLE HONEST
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS BILL.
AND WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH YOU KNOW MANY OF US.
HAVE CULTURAL LEGENDS I CONS
THAT WE WISH HAD BEEN TAUGHT
THROUGH THE MAINSTREAM
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS IF FOR NO
OTHER REASON. THEN. REALLY TO
BE CHANNELED THROUGH ONE. REAL
PIPELINE OF EDUCATION. AND IN
THE COURSE OF ACTUALLY TRYING
TO LEARN THE ABC'S AND ONE TWO
THREES. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO THEY ARE. IN THE CONTEXT.
OF UNITED STATES AMERICAN
HISTORY. AND HOW THAT FEELS
WHEN YOU ARE EITHER ARE RAISED
FROM. MARGINALIZED BY. OR PUT
IT THE INOTES OTHER PARTICULAR
HISTORY BOOK OR LESSEN. AND
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO RECTIFY
THAT. IN THE COURSE OF THIS
SIZE. THE DISCUSSIONS AROUND
EIGHTY ONE OH ONE I ACTUALLY
HAD A CONVERSATION WITH A
COLLEAGUE AND I SAID. I
RECOUNTED THE TIME WHEN- I WAS
IN ISRAEL HAVING DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE PEACE NEGOTIATOR AND
ASKED IF THERE WOULD EVER BE
PEACE IN THE MIDDLE EAST AND
THE PERSON SAID NOW. AS LONG AS-
EITHER SIDE REFUSES TO
RECOGNIZE THE OTHER SIDE'S
TRAUMA. WE WILL NEVER GET TO A
PLACE OF PEACE. AND I THINK
THIS IS WHAT WE TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH EIGHTY ONE OH
ONE. RECOGNIZING THE TRAUMAS OF
ALL OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE
INTEGRAL OR WHOSE STORIES ARE
INTEGRAL TO WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO ALLOW IT TO BE SHARED
TWO YOUNG FOLKS. IN A WAY THAT
IS HONEST. YOU KNOW. THE
REALITY IS THAT IT IS AS
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
BEING TAUGHT AS IT IS TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND WHO IS
TEACHING IT AND HOW THAT WILL
BE TALKED. THIS IS NOT GONNA IN
CULTURE WARS. BUT THIS IS ALSO
NOT ABOUT. IT'S NOT REALLY
ABOUT RACE IT'S ABOUT HISTORY
AND THE FACT THAT FOR SO LONG
SO MANY PARTS OF OUR UNITED
STATES AMERICAN HISTORY HAS
BEEN PUSHED TO THE SIDELINES.
AND TALKING ABOUT RACE CAN BE
DONE. WITHOUT SHAMING PEOPLE.
WITHOUT BEING ACCUSATORY AND
WITHOUT BEING DIVISIVE. AND IF
FOLKS ARE SO AFRAID TO TALK
ABOUT RACE. THEN I WOULD JUST
ASK YOU TO LEAN DEEPER IN
BECAUSE YOU'VE PROBABLY TOUCHED
ON A VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
VULNERABLE POINTS. AND WHO YOU
ARE. THAT NEEDS TO BE FURTHER
DISSECTED. I EIGHTY ONE OH ONE
AND IS ABOUT ASKING FOLKS TO
TAKE THE BLINDERS OFF WE
SHOULDN'T BE WHITEWASHING
HISTORY SO THAT IT'S- BIAR.
THROUGH THE ENTIRE COURSE OF
THIS EXISTENCE OF THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE IT HASN'T BEEN. AND
LEARNING THAT DOESN'T CREATE
DIVISION. HOPEFULLY IT CREATES
OPPORTUNITY FOR REFLECTION. A
NEW WAYS OF TALKING ABOUT FOLKS
AND HISTORIES THAT YOU DON'T
KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT BUT AT
SOME POINT WE HAVE TO STOP
BEING AFRAID. WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW. AND I'M REALLY INTERESTED
IN YOUNG PEOPLE HAVING ALL OF
THE INFORMATION AT THEIR
DISPOSAL. ABOUT HOW THIS
COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ABOUT WHO
HELPED TO MAKE IT GREAT. IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO SPEND ALL
OF OUR TIMES DURING THESE
COMMEMORATIVE DAYS WITH OUR
FLOOR SPEECHES TALKING ABOUT
FOLKS. THEY'RE NOT TAUGHT IN
OUR SCHOOLS. SO I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE OH ONE.
BECAUSE THESE INCREMENTAL STEPS
TOWARDS HONESTY. ARE THE STEPS
THAT WE SHOULD BE TAKING. WITH
SOME MORE FORCEFULNESS AND SOME
MORE CONFIDENCE. SO THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT I'D ASK FOR AN
IDOL FOR EIGHTY ONE OH ONE
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE A
ONE AND I MOSTLY WANT TO THINK-
THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEDINA FOR HIS DOG AND WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. EVER SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE IN THE US SENATE-
BEFORE WAS THE CHAIRPERSON
EDUCATION I SET ON SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND HE'S
ALWAYS BROUGHT THE BILL FORWARD
I HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED IT AND
I'VE ALWAYS SAID THE SAME
THING. THE MORE WE KNOW ABOUT
EACH OTHER THE MORE WE WILL
REALIZE THAT WE ARE MORE ALIKE
THAN WE ARE DIFFERENT. I WANT
TO LEARN ABOUT DIFFERENT
CULTURES I WANT MY CHILDREN TO
LEARN ABOUT DIFFERENT CULTURES
I WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS ALSO WITH. SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES THAT THIS
ISN'T JUST ABOUT GOING FORWARD
THIS IS ALSO ABOUT LEARNING OUR
HISTORY OUR TRUE HISTORY SO
ABOUT HATING ANYONE IT'S NOT
ABOUT HATING WHITE PEOPLE IT'S
ABOUT UNDERSTANDING OUR TRUE
HISTORY. AND WHEN PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT CRITICAL RACE THEORY
WHICH JUST AS AN ASIDE IS NOT
PART OF A B. ONE OH ONE AND IS
NOT PART OF ETHNIC STUDIES THE
DEFINITION OF CRITICAL RACE
THEORY IS A BODY OF LEGAL
SCHOLARSHIP. AND ACADEMIC
MOVEMENT OF US CIVIL RIGHTS
SCHOLARS AND ACTIVISTS WHO SEEK
TO CRITICALLY EXAMINE THE
INTERSECTIONAL INTERSECTION OF
RACE AND US LAW. AND TO
CHALLENGE MAINSTREAM AMERICAN
LIBERAL APPROACHES TO RACIAL
JUSTICE C. R. T. EXAMINE SOCIAL
SOCIAL CULTURAL AND LEGAL
ISSUES PRIMARILY AS A RESULT
RESULT RELATE TO RACE AND
RACISM IN THE US. THE BASIC
TENANTS OF C. R. T. INCLUDE
THAT RACISM AND DESPAIR RACIAL
OUTCOMES ARE THE RESULT OF
COMPLEX CHANGING AND OFTEN
SUBTLE SOCIAL IN INSTITUTIONAL
DYNAMICS RATHER THAN. INTERNAL
INTERNAL INTERNAL INTENTIONAL
EXCUSE ME PREJUDICES IN
INDIVIDUALS SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S A BAD
THING SOMETIMES RACISM IS.
SUBTLE SOMETIMES WE DON'T KNOW
IT I WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M NOT
BEHAVING IN A MANNER THAT WOULD
OFFEND SOMEONE. AND I DO AGREE.
CHILDREN ARE NOT BORN RACIST
THAT'S A 100% CORRECT. BUT
CHILDREN DO LIVE WITH RACIST
PARENTS SOMETIMES IF THEY DON'T
LEARN SOMETHING DIFFERENT IN
SCHOOL THEY WILL LEARN TO BE
RACIST I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AGAIN I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE
MEMBER MEDINA FOR HIS DOG AND
WORK ON THIS AND I HOPE THAT WE
WILL SEE IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK AND GET SIGNED I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WAY SO.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THIS
DEBATE AND- I JUST WANT TO ADD
A LITTLE BIT IN TERMS OF THE-
ISSUE OF SCIENCE BECAUSE THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT EDUCATION. AND
THE WAY WE PERCEIVE SCIENCE AND
YOUTH I'M GLAD THAT. CRITICAL
RACE THEORY WASN'T WRITTEN TO
THE BUILDING OF SOMEBODY RISES
UP AND SAY THIS IS ABOUT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY THERE THEY
DIDN'T READ THE BILL. AND YOU
HAVE TO ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS THAT
AS- ACTUALLY ONE THEORY IN
SCIENCE THERE ARE SEVERAL
OTHERS AND IF. YOU KNOW ABOUT
SCIENCE YOU KNOW THAT SCIENCE
IS ALWAYS ALWAYS WORKS ON
CHALLENGING. OUR OWN
UNDERSTANDING IT'S A CONSTANT
CHALLENGE OF THE WAY WE VIEW OF
THE WORLD AND THE WAY WE'VE
COME TO UNDERSTAND THINGS AND
IF YOU. TAKE A POSITION IN
SCIENCE AT THINGS ARE CERTAIN
WAYS YOU'LL PROBABLY. BE IN B.
THE- WRONG IN TERMS OF HOW HOW
WE WOULD VIEW. SOCIETY IN THE
WORLD. SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE- INCLUDING EDUCATION IN
EVERY ASPECT OF RAISING OUR
CHILDREN PREPARING THEM FROM
THE WORLD WE HAVE TO. RAISE
PEOPLE THAT- ARE ARE PROUD OF
WHO THEY ARE ON THE ONE HAND
AND ON THE OTHER HAND PEOPLE
THAT ARE GROUNDED. IN ROME AND-
IN KNOWING HOW TO INVESTIGATE
THINGS TO THE SCIENTIFIC
PRINCIPLES THAT ALLOW OUR
CURRENT OUR OUR WORLD TO
FLOURISH AND DEVELOP IN THE
LAST TWO HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS.
SO IF WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A
NATION OF PEOPLE WHOSE HEADS
ARE IN THE SAND. IF YOU REALLY
WILL CHALLENGE. THE PROSPERITY
AND THE POSITION OF OUR COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD. IN A IN A IN A
VERY MAJOR. EXTENT SO DON'T BE
AFRAID OF EDUCATION DON'T BE
AFRAID OF UNDERSTANDING OTHER
PEOPLE I GOT A CATHOLIC
EDUCATION GROWING UP AND ONE OF
THE THINGS MY SCHOOL DID MY
CATHOLIC SCHOOL DID WAS TAKE ME
TO LEARN. WE WENT TO A WELCOME
TO MOSCOW WE WENT TO A
SYNAGOGUE WE WENT TO A BUDDHIST
TEMPLE AS PART OF OUR RELIGIOUS
EDUCATION AND IT WAS EXTREMELY.
REVEALING TO ME AND IT WAS JUST
A MOMENT TO UNDERSTAND OTHER
PEOPLE I COME TO RESPECT THEM.
AND THAT WAS A WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE IN MY YOUTH WHY WHY
COULDN'T WE NOT ALLOW THAT TO
EVERYBODY. IN OUR COUNTRY IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT AREAS THAT
INCLUDE. ETHNICITY RELIGION
HISTORY JUSTIN SO MANY PARTS
OF OUR OUR SOCIETY DON'T BE
AFRAID. TO EDUCATE YOUR
CHILDREN. I'M NOT AFRAID TO
EDUCATE MINE AND I HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE SYSTEM WILL
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING TO A VERY COMPLEX
WORLD. TO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE THAT WILL GREATLY ENHANCE
THEIR ABILITIES. TO NOT ONLY
SURVIVE BUT TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP IN A COMPLEX WORLD.
I SUPPORT P. B. ONE A ONE I
THINK WE SHOULD AS A
LEGISLATURE LET'S. MOVE IT
FORWARD AND IMPROVE OUR SCHOOLS
IMPROVE OUR QUALITY OF
EDUCATION AND CONTINUE TO HAVE
CALIFORNIA BE A LEADER IN THE
WORLD. IN ALL THE AREAS THAT
MATTER MOST. Q. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TOO WANT TO THANK
HIM AND MY- CAN YOU
CONGRADULATIONS IF THIS SHOULD
MOVE OFF THE FLOOR BUT MOSTLY
MY THANKS TO THE CARCASSES THAT
PUT IN SOME REALLY HARD WORK
HERE- AGAIN BEING A PARENT OF A
FIRST GRADER MY CHILD IS JUST
SENT HOME EVEN BEFORE- THEY
SHOULD PASS WITH THREE BOOKS A
BOOK ABOUT A MUSLIM CHILDREN A
BOOK ABOUT BLACK FAMILIES A
BOOK ABOUT BROWN OF FAMILIES
THE LATINO NATIVE EXPERIENCE
WHICH IS PRETTY COOL IT'S NOT
JUST TO SAY THAT- STUDENTS OR
THE LEGISLATURES PUSHING
SOMETHING TEACHERS WANT TO BE A
PART OF THE SOLUTION AS WELL TO
ENSURE THAT. IT'S NOT THE
IDEOLOGIES OR SYSTEM OF IDEAS
THAT SOME PEOPLE SHOULD THINK
IT'S LIVED EXPERIENCES OF THE
PEOPLE- THAT HAVE BEEN LIVING
IN THIS THIS COUNTRY IN THIS
STATE FOR SO LONG LIVED
EXPERIENCES IS WHAT WE NEED TO
PUT OUT FIRST I'M WITH THE
FIFTH LARGEST EONOMY- AND WE
NEED TO SEE- OURSELVES IN THESE
BOOKS THE LAST THING I'LL SAY
IS THERE'S BEEN STUDIES OUT
THERE IS MANY PEOPLE KNOW THAT
IT'S A LEAD TO STUDENTS HAVING
HIGHER ATTENDANCE HIGHER
GRADUATION RATES AND HIGHER
INCREASED ENROLLMENT. BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO LEARN ABOUT
THEMSELVES WHITE CHILDREN WANT
TO LEARN ABOUT THE EXPERIENCES
OF OTHERS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
START CHANGING OF THE ROADMAP
AS IT PERTAINS TO A RACIAL
EQUITY AND SOCIAL EQUITY IN
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR THEIR
FRIENDS AND SO FOR THAT I FEEL
SO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE OF ONE AND I WANT TO
THINK ABOUT ARE MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. ON
BEHALF OF THE SET BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU
SOONER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES I ALSO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE OH
ONE AND WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR HI THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT'S BEEN GOING
ON FOR QUITE A WHILE AND I WAS
PRIVILEGED ENOUGH TO SIT ON SO
MANY OTHER CAUCUSES WERE HAVING
THESE DISCUSSIONS. ARE
INTERESTING ENOUGH IF WE
STARTED WITH DIVERSE VIEWS AND
DIFFERENT OPINIONS BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY EVERYONE FELT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND EVERYONE CAME TO
THE TABLE AND AGREED THAT THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE- I
WANT TO BORROW A LINE FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES AND
SHE SAID. HI THIS IS ABOUT
TAKING STEPS INCREMENTAL STEPS
TOWARDS HONESTY AND I AGREED
THIS IS NOT ABOUT CREATING A
TRUTH IT'S ABOUT JUST TELLING
THE TRUTH AND AS A FORMER
TEACHER WHO TAUGHT HISTORY IT
DOES MAKE ME SAD TO SEE THAT SO
MUCH THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ARE
YOU SCORING UP TODAY IS LEFT
OUT OF HISTORY BOOKS AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE
GONNA TEACH HISTORY WE CANNOT
LEAVE FAX OUT OF HISTORY WE
HAVE TO TELL. THE TRUTH
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
THE LIVED EXPERIENCES OF SO
MANY OF OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
FROM YOU KNOW EVERYTHING THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED AND PERHAPS
YOU MAY NOT BE THE BEST OF OUR
HISTORY BUT WITHOUT OUR HISTORY
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE IN THE FUTURE SO WITH
THAT I ALSO URGE YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THE SIGN. ON WE HAVE CENTER
MELINDA'S AGAIN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH I'LL
MAKE THIS BRIEF BUT I WANTED TO
ADD A POINT OF CLARIFICATION
REGARDING- WHAT IS AN ETHNIC
STUDIES AND SPECIFICALLY TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE MENTION WAS
MADE THAT C. R. T. IS NOT
INCLUDED. AND I WILL REMIND YOU
THAT THE MODEL CURRICULUM THAT
WAS APPROVED- SPECIFICALLY
MENTIONS CRITICAL RACE THEORY
IN FACT STATE BOARD PRESIDENT
LINDA DARLING HAMMOND- AT.
PROVIDED A DEFINITION OF
SECURITY- TO BE ADDED SO THIS
SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW THESE
ARE NOT INTERTWINED- IS NOT
TRUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ACTRESS THING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND VERY SENATOR
RAZA WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT- AND I WANTTO THANK
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- I WANT TO THANK THE
CAUCUSES THANKS TO THE AUTHOR
OF FOR ALL OF THE UNITY AROUND
GETTING TO THIS POINT. THIS IS
ONLY MY THIRD YEAR HERE BUT I
KNOW THAT MANY FORESTS HAVE YOU
KNOW REALLY STRUGGLE TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD AND FINALLY GET TO
THIS POINT. A COUPLE YEARS AGO
A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN THE MOVIE
HIDDEN FIGURES CAME OUT I TOOK
MY TWO GRANDDAUGHTERS AND I WAS
BOTH EXCITED AND PROUD- AND AT
THE SAME TIME EMBARRASSED THAT
I HAD NOT LEARNED THAT
PARTICULAR STORY AND HISTORY IN
MY LIFE BUT I WAS GLAD TO SEE
MY TWO GRANDDAUGHTERS. LEARNING
THAT WE DON'T NEED YOU SHOULD
NOT WAIT FOR A MOVIE TO TELL A
STORY IT SHOULD BE PART AND
PARCEL OF WHAT ARE OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR YOUTH- EXPERIENCE AND
LEARN IN SCHOOL- AND THIS WAS A
SOMETHING THAT. MANY PEOPLE
WORKED VERY HARD ON AND MOST
RECENTLY THE CAUCUSES CAME
TOGETHER UNDER A UNIFIED AND
I'M- VERY- PROUD OF THE WORK OF
THE CAUCUSES AS WELL SO WITH
THAT THE PRESIDENT REGION I
WILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AV ONE OH ONE. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. HI ADKINS. FIVE
BABIES. NO BACKER. HI FORTUS.
BRADFORD I KERR BY OTHER.
HYPERTENSIVE HI DOLLY NO DODD I
THEY'RE AWESOME I A COMMON
BLAZER ARE YOU CONSOLIDATE FIVE
GROVE NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HYPER TIDO. I JONES NO KAMMERER
I LAYERED I. LEIVA. FIVE THE
MON ALL RIGHT MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH KNOW
PAM. I FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT
I RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE STERN
NUMBER HI BY CAL SKI. I WINNER
I WILL. WELCOME NOW. AUGUST
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES NUMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM FIFTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR COOLLY
PRESENTED BY SENATOR I MEAN
SOME OF THEM INCLUDE PRESENTED
BY SENATOR CORTESE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT CENTER CURTIS- THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES ARE
ALWAYS RESENT E. . FIVE THIRTY
NINE WHICH ALLOWS THE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT BOARD TO ESTABLISH
PRUDENT RESPONSIBLE POLICIES TO
PROCURE CONTRACTS WITH EXTERNAL
INVESTMENT MANAGERS AND
ADVISORS. MAYBE FIVE THIRTY
NINE WOULD REQUIRE NEW
CONTRACTING PROCESS TO ENGAGE
WITH THE BEST MANAGERS AND
ADVISORS TO BE ESTABLISHED BY A
BOARD THAT INCLUDES LEADERS
FROM OVERSIGHT AGENCIES WOULD
BE COMPELLED BY FIDUCIARY DUTY
TO CHOOSE THE BEST PERFORMERS
THAT WILL PRODUCE GREATEST
RETURNS AT THE LOWEST COST.
THIS BILL WAS HAVE HAD HAS HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT. IN NINETEEN
NINE MANAGER. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS
I BASE HI BECKER I PORGES
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY. I DON I
TORONTO FIVE EGGMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE. I HURTS
BURKE I WAS SO HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
HI LISA I THE MON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A TELEVOTE I CAN. HI
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT I RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN I'M BERG HI
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL
I. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NON
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM SIXTY TWO. AV EIGHT TO
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR ON
BERGMAN'S SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. I SIMPLY FELT AT EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE BY SSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVIN AND ACT RELATING TO
INFORMATION PRIVACY SOON
REMEMBER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASE
PRESENT A. B. EIGHT TO FIVE-
MANY OF YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
SUBMIT FOR EXAMPLE GENETIC-
DATA FOR PURPOSES OF ANALYSIS
OF. WHETHER IT BE HEALTH ISSUES
OR YOUR ANCESTRY THAT THAT
GENETIC DATA IS EXTREMELY
VALUABLE AND HAS SOME OF THE
MOST PERSONAL INFORMATION WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT SIMPLY
REQUIRES WHEN THERE'S BEEN A
BREACH OF THE SYSTEM WHERE THAT
DATA IS STORED CAPTOR
DISSEMINATED. THAT THE PERSON
WHO SUBMITTED THE DATA BE
NOTIFIED OF URGENT I VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. SCENE ON MOUNT
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FILE I'M SIXTY TWO. ALAN I
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I BAIT.
BECKER I PORCHES RADFORD I COME
BY ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY. DOT
I TORONTO I EGGMAN LASER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG
I WISH SO HI HER TADO. HI JONES.
CAN LONGER I GLARED. HI LLEVA
FIVE THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. FIVE MILLION HI
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT YOUR VOTE
HI PAM I POURED INTO YOU KNOW.
HI RALPH I REVIEW I SCANNER. HI
STERN NUMBER HI KELSEY I WINNER.
I WILL. MARCH THIRTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES BELL MEMBERS
REMOVE ON THE FALL I'M SIXTY
THREE MEASURE BY ASSEMBLYMAN
JONES SAWYER PRESENTED BY
SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR ROSE ARE
YOU. OPOSSUM FILE THE PASSWORD
FILE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL GRANT RECONSIDERATION ON
FALL ITEM SIXTY TWO. AND I'LL
BE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO. SEVEN
ZERO THIRTY SEVEN ZERO THE
WHOLE WORLD AND- ZURCHER YOU
CAN CALL THE ROLL AGAIN ON ITEM
FILE I'M SIXTY TWO. ALAN. FIVE
ARCHULETA I ADKINS I BASE.
BACKER I FORTUS BRADFORD I HAVE
A ARE YOU PROTESTING HI DOLLY.
DOT HI THERE ASA I EXAMINE
GLAZER EYE CONSOLIDATES I DROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LAVER I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN FIVE NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. A TELEPHONE. CAN I
FORTUNE TINO I RALPH HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER
TIME I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I
WILL. I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS. BATES GORGEOUS
DALLY. EGGMAN GROVE. JONES
NIELSEN A SHOW BOTH. STERN WELL.
HIGHS THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE. MEASURE PASSES THANK
YOU. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
FALL I'M SIXTY THREE- NO WE'RE
GONNA PASS ON FILE. IS THAT
SENATOR RAZA. HAVE SOMEONE HAS
SOME FUN. THE RESOLUTION OKAY.
OKAY. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THE REQUEST OF THE OP ED PLEASE
MOVE A. B. EIGHT FIVE EIGHT TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. THIS WOMAN.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM. SIXTY SIX. FIVE A
SEVENTEEN PRESENTED BY DECEMBER
SENATOR GONZALEZ MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG AN ACT
RELATING TO PEDESTRIANS SENATOR
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AT
TWELVE THIRTY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM THAT SEEKS
TO DECRIMINALIZE SAFE STREET
CROSSING AND REMOVE UNNECESSARY
FINES THESE LAWS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND THEY ARE
JUST THE ENFORCED TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY DATA
SHOWS THATBLACK CALIFORNIANS
WERE UP TO FOUR POINT THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY. THAN WHITE
CALIFORNIANS TO BE STOPPED FOR
JAYWALKING LOWER INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS ALSO FACE
INEQUITY IN STREET DESIGNS AS
NEIGHBORHOOD LACKS SIDEWALKS OR
HAVE LARGER DISTANCES BETWEEN
CROSSWALKS AB TWELVE THIRTY
DOES NOT A BLANKET BAN ON JAY
WALKING IT DOES NOT PERMIT
UNSAFE CREEK CROSSING WITH AN
IMMEDIATE HAZARD IS PRESENT AND
IN WHICH CASE LAW. ENFORCEMENT
CAN STILL CITE INDIVIDUALS THE
BILL ALSO CONTAINS A SEVEN YEAR
SUNSET AND INCLUDES A REPORTING
PROVISION TO ENSURE THAT THE
POLICY IS SAFE AND IMPROVES
EQUITY I THANK YOU MEMBERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
ANY FOR THE- AND DEBATE ON THIS
I. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. NINETY NINE MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FALL I'M SIXTY SIX. ALAN I
ARCHULETA ATKINS. BASED NO
BACKER. I PORCHES BRADFORD I
HAVE I GOTTA. CORTESE I DALLIED.
NO DODD. I TORONTO I EGGMAN
LASER I CONSOLIDATE I GROSS NO
HERTZBERG. WEST SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MOON. I
ACQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A- NO PAM
FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW. I. ROSS.
RUBIO SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI. I
WINNER I WILL NOW M. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA ATKINS. FOR JUST.
CABRERO EGGMAN HERTZBERG MAN.
RALPH RUBIO STERN. PRICE TWENTY
TWO MILLS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES. IS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FALL AND SIXTY NINE CENTS
DRAWS ARE YOU THERE. EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY BY SYSTEM AND
GIBSON. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON'S AN
ACT RELATING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY POLICIES SENATOR ALSO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I RISE
TO PRESENT AT FOUR NINETY WHICH
SEEKS TO RESTRICT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING
RESTRAINTS THAT CAUSE
POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA. NATIONAL
US FIX YET IS A DEADLY
CONDITION THAT CAN OCCUR WHEN A
PERSON IS RESTRAINED AND CANNOT
BREATHE. THIS IS A FOLLOW UP OF
WHICH- TO AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
OF US SIGNED INTO LAW
RESTRICTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM USING CHUCKLES. WELL MANY
OF US WITNESSED THE UNTIMELY
DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD. ANGELO
KEEN TO A NAVY NAVY VETERAN
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO
LOST HIS LIFE BECAUSE OF
SIMILAR RESTRAINTS. HIS FAMILY.
THE FOUNDER KENDALL COLLINS
ROBERT COLLINS AND THEIR
DAUGHTER HAVE BEEN TIRELESSLY
ADVOCATING TO MAKE SURE NO
OTHER FAMILY HAS TO WITNESS
WHAT THEY DID THE NIGHT ANGELA
DIED. TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
WILL NOT HINDER LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM UTILIZING RESTRAINTS THEY
MIGHT NEED TO USE AND DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS ALL TOGETHER. THE
AUTHOR AMENDED THIS BILL IN
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS REFLECTED IN THE
LAW TO AVOID ANY
MISINTERPRETATION. EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY IS A POLICY THATIS
NEEDED NOW TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE
IN CURRENT USE OF FORCE
POLICIES ARE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR I. VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER THIS OF ON THE SIDE OF.
HEARING AND SEEING ON MOUNT
SECTOR PLEASE REVIEW OUR- SIR
BACK OF THANK YOU I JUST WANNA
SAY HAVING MET WITH THE FAMILY-
I JUST STRONGLY BACK UP MORE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I APPRECIATE THE OFFER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND FOR
THE PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON FILE I'M
SIXTY NINE. TURNING SEEING ON
MOUNT SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER HI
FORGES BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
HI CORTESE HI DOLLY. NO DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I DROVE. NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TROUBLED. NO PAN
HI FOURTEEN TINA I. ROSS HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI STERN I'M
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI. HI WINNER
I WILL NOW ACTOR PLEASE CALL
OUT FOR MEMBERS FORTUS ADMIN
HER TADO NO MELINDA'S STERN.
MARCH TWENTY EIGHT MILLS EIGHT
THE MEASURE PASSES NOT MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FALL ITEMS
SANITY A MEASURE BY SOON FLOOR
ARE PRESENTED BY THE TOOL BOX
ENTER TROUBLE YOU SHOULD
PREPARE SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLORA AN ACT RELATING TO
CONTRACTORS. IN ORDER TO A BOAT.
MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT FAILED
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY THREE
AND A HALF OF FAMILY MEMBER.
LAURA AT TEN TWENTY THREE WOULD
ENACT THE PENALTY OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY AGAINST A
PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTOR WHO
FAILED TO SUBMIT. AN ELECTRONIC
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS. ELECTRONIC
CERTIFIED PAYROLL IS A TOOL
USED BY THE STATE TO ENSURE
THAT CONTRACTORS ON PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS ARE PAYING THEIR
WORKERS THE PREVAILING WAGE
THEY ARE ENTITLED TO. THAT
MEETING THESE RECORDS IS
ALREADY A REQUIREMENT FOR THESE
CONTRACTS IN EIGHTY TEN TWENTY
THREE WOULD SIMPLY PROVIDE AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO ENSURE
THAT CONTRACTORS ARE ABIDING BY
THE LAW. THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HEARING CHAIN ON
POPSUGAR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ARM SEVEN. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE.
BACKER. FIVE PORCHES BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI PROTESTING HI
DOLLY I DON. HI THERE I SEND HI
A COMMON GLAZER AIKENS OLIVE I
GROWTH I HURTS BURKE I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR. HI
THE MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.
IN MEN HI I. NEWMAN HI NIELSEN
NO A TROUBLED I CAN HI PERSON
TINA. HI ROB I RUBIO HI SKINNER
I STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI.
I WINNER I WILL I. M. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS.
BATES NO. PORGES ADMIN
MELINDA'S NO STERN. FIVE THIRTY
THREE MILLS FOR THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FALL ITEM SEVENTY ONE-
MEASURE BY HAS SOMEONE BERMAN
PRESENTED BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERM
BERMAN AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
POLLUTION SENATOR GONZALES
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BERMAN AND
GONZALES TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX WHICH WILL PHASE IN.
THEIR EMISSION STANDARDS FOR
SMALL OFF ROAD ENGINES LIKE
LEAF BLOWERS AND LAWN MOWERS
CURRENTLY SMALL GAS POWERED
ENGINES ARE STORES OF THEIR
CALL OUR MAJOR SOURCE OF
POLLUTION IN FACT EMISSIONS
FROM SMALL ENGINES ACTUALLY
SURPASSED THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
MISSIONS FROM ALL PASSENGER
CARS IN CALIFORNIA JUST THIS
YEAR- AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
WOULD PHASE IN A ZERO EMISSION
STANDARD FOR SALES OF NEW SMALL
ENGINES BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WITH THE DELAYED PHASE AND- BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT FOR SMALL
PORTABLE GENERATORS. THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS ALREADY
BEGUN THE RULE MAKING PROCESS
ON THIS ISSUE IN THE BILL IS IN
LINE WITH THEIR PROPOSAL FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
STANDARD. AT THIS BILL DOES NOT
AFFECT THE USE OF EXISTING
SMALL ENGINES AND HAS IMPORTANT
EXEMPTIONS FOR FARM EQUIPMENT
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE ENTITIES
FURTHERMORE I TWO INCH INSURED
JUST TRANSITION THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS HAVE SECURED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
TO CREATE A DEDICATED INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FOR SMALL LANDSCAPING
BUSINESSES. TO TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION EQUIPMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVACY.
THANK YOU FOR THIS. OF THE IT
ON THIS O. SENATOR DALLAS.
THANK YOU ADAM. FOR THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I DON'T
SOLVE THIS BILL AND- LEE WAS EQ
AND- I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE THIS
WE'RE GONNA REGULATE. A LAWN
MOWER WEEDEATER A CHAIN SAW A
GENERATOR. AND I KNOW IT'S
PHASED IN OVER TIME IN THOSE OF
US WHO ARE WANT TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
PROTECT OUR LAND FROM FIRE AND-
HEY WHAT WE'LL GO BY SIMON ME
THEY'LL LAST AND THEN THE NEXT
GENERATION WON'T HAPPEN. AND
IT'S JUST AMAZING TO ME THAT WE
PASS LEGISLATION LIKE THIS THAT
REGULATES FREEDOM OF PEOPLE TO
USE SOMETHING OTHER THAN A
BATTERY. WHEN THE POWER'S OUT
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO POT HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO CHARGE YOUR
BATTERY. SO THAT YOU CAN.
SUPPOSEDLY KEEP YOUR
REFRIGERATOR ON. WHAT HAPPENED
PUBLIC POWER SAFETY SHUT OFFS
ALMOST EVERY YEAR NOW. AND
WE'RE CONVERTING EVERYTHING TO
POWER BECAUSE FOR SOME REASON
THIS LEGISLATURE HATES. FUEL
WHICH IS VERY SUSTAINABLE IT'S
EASY TO ACCESS AND WHEN THE
POWER IS OFF YOU CAN STILL USE
IT YOU CAN STILL RUN A
GENERATOR TO KEEP YOUR FEES ARE
GOING TO KEEP YOUR MEDICAL
DEVICES GOING BUT WHEN YOUR
BATTERY IS DEAD AND THERE'S NO
POWER ON YOU HAVE. NOTHING. AND
ON TOP OF THAT. WE TALK ABOUT
SAVING THE ENVIRONMENT THIS IS
THIS IS A JOKE ABOUT SAVING THE
ENVIRONMENT YOU WANT TO SAVE
THE ENVIRONMENT TAKE THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HELP SOMEBODY STAY IN
THE WEEDING LAWN MOWING
BUSINESS. AND SPEND IT ON THE
FIRST THAT'S BURNING THE HECK
DOWN AS WE SPEAK RIGHT THIS
MINUTE EMITTING MORE CARBON
THAN ALL THE BILLS YOU'VE EVER
DONE IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
TOGETHER. I'M I'M SORRY I'M
YELLING. I'M A LITTLE BIT.
FRUSTRATED AT THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE COMMON SENSE IN THIS
PLACE. THAT WE CAN BURN ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE REGULATE.
COMBUSTIBLE ENGINES COME ON
REALLY THIS IS AS GOOD AS WE
CAN DO AND THEN LAST NIGHT. IN
THE BUDGET HEARING. WE'RE NOT
EVEN GONNA SPEND MONEY ON
PROJECTS THAT ARE SHOVEL READY
SEEKER READY PROJECTS TO MAKE
OUR FIRES KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES
MORE FIRE SAFE. MEMBERS AT SOME
POINT THE PUBLIC IS GONNA WAKE
UP AND REALIZE THAT ALL THE
MONEY WE SPEND ON BATTERIES
SOLAR PANELS. REGULATING
COMBUSTION ENGINE ISN'T GOING
TO CHANGE THE ENVIRONMENT. THIS
BILL IS GOING TO DO NOTHING TO
SAVE THIS PLANET OTHER THAN
REGULATES OUR BODY TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND YOU'RE
GOING TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT VOTING
FOR THIS BILL. AND IT'S NOT
GONNA CHANGE THE OUTCOME IF YOU
WANT TO CHANGE. CALIFORNIA AND
YOU WANT TO SAVE OUR WATERSHEDS
OUR WILDLIFE. OUR CARBON SEEK
FOREST IS THE PLACE WERE WE
SEQUESTER CARBON IF IT'S STILL
ALIVE. FOR ALL THOSE REASONS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE KILL THIS BILL AND DO
SOMETHING THAT REALLY MAKES
CALIFORNIA RIGHT BY DOING
SOMETHING THAT WOULD STOP. THE
MASSIVE. THE SPEWING OF CARBON
WHICH IS FOREST FIRE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN. AND THANK YOU- IS
PRESENT MEMBERS- THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCE BOARD IS ALREADY
WORKING ON RULE MAKING AROUND
THIS AREA AND- AND THESE
REGULATIONS COVER A BROAD RANGE
OF TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDING
PORTABLE GENERATORS LAWN AND
GARDEN EQUIPMENT CHAINSAWS
PUMPS. AND OTHER DEVICES MY
UNDIES WITH THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THE SPECIFIC SUB CATEGORY OF
PORTABLE GENERATORS DURING P.
S. P. S. EVENTS THE DISASTERS
AND OTHER POWER INTERRUPTIONS
MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE
COME TO RELY ON PORTABLE
GENERATORS TO POWER MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT REFRIGERATORS AIR
CONDITIONING OTHER ESSENTIAL
POWER NEEDS DURING THESE
INTERNMENT CHALLENGES WHICH
HAVE BECOME ALL TOO. FREQUENT
IN RECENT DAYS REGULATION IT
WILL HAMPER ACCESS TO THIS
EQUIPMENT- IS A SIGNIFICANT
TURN FOR NOT ONLY THESE
CONSTITUENTS- BUT FIRMER FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO TRY TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS IN CRISIS THE
AMENDMENTS IN PREPARATION
COMMITTEE. REQUIRED A. R. B. TO
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL FACTORS
DURING THIS RULEMAKING
INCLUDING THE AVAILABILITY OF
ZERO EMISSIONS GENERATORS AND
COURT HAS TO CONSIDER THE
OPERATIONAL SIDE OF THESE
GENERATORS THE POWER NEEDS OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS THE ABILITY
FOR ZERO EMISSION PORTAL
GENERATES. TAXING MEET THOSE
NEEDS IN THE NEAR TERM AT AN
AFFORDABLE PRICE. WITHOUT THESE
ISSUES ADDRESSED THE CARD
SHOULD PROBABLY PAUSE ANY
EFFORT THAT WILL LIMIT THIS
SPECIFIC CATEGORY- PORTABLE
GENERATORS FOR CALIFORNIANS
DURING PS PS EVENTS AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES OUR CONSTITUENTS
NEED TO HAVE ACCESS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVERS NOTED TO
GENERATORS AND OTHER EMERGENCY
RESPONSE EQUIPMENT AND I WOULD
URGE THE AIRPORT TO BE MINDFUL
OF THESE NEEDS- BUT FOR THE
MOMENT BUT THIS BILL GOES IS
TOO BROAD- AND I WILL HAVE TO
STAY OFF IT THANK. YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN. YEAH SOME
ISSUES AROUND RACE THAT I THINK
DESERVE- SOME RESPONSE AND
THERE IS A LONG PHASE IN ON THE
GENERATORS WITH THIS BILL- YEAH
THERE ARE ZERO EMISSION
GENERATORS THAT ACTUALLY ARE
AVAILABLE NOW THAT CAN PROVIDE
ADEQUATE BACKUP POWER DURING A
POWER OUTAGE- EVERYONE CAN
CONTINUE USING THE GENERATOR
THE OWNED WERE THEY ALREADY OWN
OR THOSE OF THE PURCHASED
BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT BUT
THEN I WANTED REALLY EMPHASIZE
THE POINT THAT'S BEEN MADE BY
THE SENATOR. FROM ORANGE COUNTY
WHICH IS THAT MEANS REMEMBERS
THEY WERE TAKEN IN THIS HOUSE
THAT- WE'RE CARB. HOW IS GOING
BE RQUIRED TO DETERMINE ZERO
EMISSION GENERATOR AVAILABILITY.
AND IF WE'RE STILL HAVING PS PS
EVENTS AFTER TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT CAR ABOUT THE DISCRETION
TO WAIVE EMISSIONS RULES IN AN
EMERGENCY SO. HE DOES. THE IDEA
THAT- THE THIS IS GONNA TAKE
AWAY THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE THAT AND THERE'S NOT
WITHOUT ANY ALTERNATIVE IS JUST
NOT TUE- THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THEY'RE THEY'RE
LOOKING IN REAL TIME THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TECHNOLOGY- BUT
LET'S LET'S FACE FACTS FOLKS
THE TRUTH IS. WE'VE GOT TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM THESE
ENGINES TO MEET OUR OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE CLEAN AIR ACT
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY EXCEEDING
FEDERAL STATE STANDARDS FOR
OZONE AND PARTICULATE MATTER IN
THE SOUTH COAST AIR BASIN IN
THE BAY AREA AND SAMPLE SOME OF
KEENE VALLEY SACRAMENTO- THE-
THE- THE STAGE ON FIRE. RIGHT I
MEAN THE P. S. P. S. ISSUES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ARE
BECAUSE OF. OUR INABILITY TO
SOLVE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES- THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN IN THIS HOUSE
REALLY DO MAKE THIS BILL-
SENSIBLE AND WORKABLE- AND I
AND I ALSO JUST SHOULD MENTION
THAT YOU KNOW FARMING
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT HAVE AN
EXEMPTION- FIRE AND POLICE HAVE
AN EXEMPTION TO THE BILL. I
COULD MEAN USER FORSTER FAR
CLEANING SUCH AS- LARGE CHAIN
SAWS ARE ALSO EXEMPT. AND IN
INDIA THE DAY THERE'S BUILT IN
FLEXIBILITY INTO THIS BILL WITH
REGARDS TO THE ROLE. OF YOU-
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO SUPPOSED TO
BE ABLE TO TRACK THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN
THIS SPACE IN REAL TIME BUT THE
FACT IS UNLESS WE PUT PRESSURE.
ON INDUSTRY THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO TAKE THE STEPS NECESSARY TO
GET. THESE BETTER LOWER
EMISSIONS ZERO EMISSIONS
GENERATORS ON TO THE MARKET AND
WIDELY AVAILABLE FOR FOLKS- AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE MANY REASONS
WHY I. URGE THAT I VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR BREAUX.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RESPECT THE RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AND I LINE MY
COMMENTS- WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIEBER- AND THEN I ALSO
WANNA LINES IN THE COMMENTS FOR
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER HE SAID
YOU KNOW THIS IS A LONG PHASE
IN FOR GENERATORS A LONG PHASE
IN FOR LAWN MOWERS- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX AND SB THIRTY
TWO PASS. MEMBER PEOPLE MAKING
FLOOR SPEECHES ABOUT THE COMING
AFTER YOUR LAWN MOWERS
GARDENERS WON'T HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO YOU KNOW ON ONE BILL THESE
GAS LAWN MOWERS GAS MEDIATORS
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. AND WE
WERE PRACTICALLY LAUGHED OUT OF
THE ROOM AND HERE WE ARE JUST A
DECADE LATER COMING AFTER LAWN
MOWERS AND WEED EATERS. AND I
THINK ABOUT HOW THIS WILL
AFFECT- YOU KNOW ENTREPRENEURS
AND START THEIR OWN ONE MORE
BUSINESS I THINK ABOUT A
NONPROFIT THAT IN BAKERSFIELD
HAS TAKEN THIS MEN'S RECOVERY
HOME AND- THEY ACTUALLY STARTED
A LAWN WHERE BUSINESS LOT OF
THINGS WERE DONATED I THINK
ABOUT RANCH PROPERTIES THAT
HAVE. LARGE YARDS THAT HAVE YOU
KNOW RIDING MOWERS. AND I ALSO
THINK ABOUT- HOW MANY LAWN
MOWERS ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CIVIC
THERE'S FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
DIVIDED BY TWO SO TWENTY
MILLION PEOPLE AS A COUPLE PER
SE A HOUSEHOLD- LET'S JUST SAY
THERE'S TWENTY MILLION LAWN
MOWERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ELIMINATING ALL
THOSE LAWN MOWERS EVEN IF THERE
WERE THAT MANY WOULD NOT IN ANY
WAY SHAPE OR FORM ELIMINATE
CARBON EMISSIONS THAT COME FROM
ONE FIRE. AT THE CREEK FIRE
THAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR
DEVASTATING HUNTINGTON LAKE IN
THE SHAVER LAKE AREA- I GREW UP
THERE. AND MY MOM GREW UP AT
THEIR- END AND- YOU SMELL THE
WALK TO THE LAKE AND WE HAD
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOREST
MANAGEMENT MITIGATION AND ALL
THOSE THINGS AND SEE VARIOUS
BILLS. FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME
AND YOU SMELL THE WALK TO THE
LAKE BUT NOW YOU CAN'T YOU
COULDN'T EVEN WALK TO THE LATE
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO MUCH.
UNDERBRUSH IN SO MANY FAN SMALL
TREES- THEY'RE NOT THERE
ANYMORE IT ALMOST LOOKS LIKE
THAT DR SEUSS BOOK NOW THE
LORAX WHERE ALL THE TREES ARE
GONE IN THAT BEAUTIFUL WOODED
MOUNTAIN AREA. SO ONE FIRE- TO
STOP THAT. TO STOP ONE FIRE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
MITIGATE A LOT OF THE CARBON
EMISSIONS THAT WE HAVE- LOOK AT
CARBON CAPTURING NEW TECHNOLOGY
TO DO CARBON CAPTURE. AND THEN
THERE'S A BILL THAT WAS
FLOATING AROUND ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE. TO ELIMINATE ANY NEW
TECHNOLOGY FOR CARBON CAPTURE
BECAUSE THAT WOULD ALLOW WHAT
THEY CALL THE- OIL INDUSTRY TO
BE ABLE TO OPERATE LONGER
BECAUSE THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE. CARBON EMISSIONS. I
MEAN SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DO IN THIS BUILDING JUST DON'T
MAKE ANY SENSE AT ALL. AND
WHILE THE AWHILE THAT WE'RE
BANNING LAWN MOWERS AND WE'RE
GONNA START AFFECTING PEOPLE'S
LIVES THAT MAKE A LIVING.
MOWING LAWNS AND TAKING CARE OF
OUR- HOMES AND BUSINESSES AND
MEDIUMS AND ALL THAT PLACE. THE
D. W. R. THE C. D. THE SKEWS ME
THIS P. D. W. R. ANNOUNCED
THURSDAY THAT THEY'LL BE
EXPANDING NATURAL GAS POWER BY
ADDING POWER PLANTS. DO THE
ENERGY SUPPLY CONCERNS. THEY'LL
HAVE FIVE NEW GAS POWERED POWER
PLANTS THAT WE OUTLAWED
BASICALLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT THEY REALIZE
THAT WE CAN'T DO THIS WE CAN'T
ACHIEVE 1100% RENEWABLE ENERGY
BY THAT DATE. THAT IS SET BY
THIS LEGISLATURE NO MATTER WHO
YOU BANNER WHO YOU PUT OUT OF
BUSINESS OR- YOU REGULATE. WE%
HAVE TO HAVE NATURAL GAS POWER
AND OIL AND GAS. INDUSTRY RIGHT
NOW WE'RE IMPORTING IT INSTEAD
OF PRODUCING IT HERE. BUT THIS
SPECIFIC BILL OUTLAWS AND HURTS
SMALL BUSINESSES IT HURTS
INDIVIDUALS WOULD HAVE TO GO
OUT AND BUY A NEW ELECTRIC LAWN
MORE. ON THE PORTABLE EQUIPMENT
THE GENERATORS WE HAVE THOSE P.
S. P. S. SHUT OFFS LIKE TO HAVE
TO BE. A LOT OF ELDERLY- IT'S A
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY UP IN THE
BEAR VALLEY SPRINGS AREA. IN MY
DISTRICT THEY SURVIVED THE
WINTERS. AND WHEN THEY WERE OUT
OF POWER FOR FOUR FIVE AND SIX
DAYS BECAUSE THEY HAVE THOSE
PORTABLE GENERATORS. WELL THOSE
PORTABLE GENERATORS OPERATE ON
GASOLINE AND IF ALL OF YOUR
POWER IS OUT. IT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE HOW YOU WOULD PLUG IN
YOUR PORTABLE GENERATOR BATTERY
OPERATED. TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR- MEDICAL DEVICES WORKED
YOUR BREEDING EQUIPMENT WORKED
AT NIGHT. AND IT'S JUST CRAZY
TO THINK THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD. AND YOU
KNOW WHEN IT MOVES FORWARD I'M
SURE WOULD BE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. BUT THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CHANGE ISSUE IF YOU REALLY WANT
TO TACKLE CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
TACKLE THE FIRE. ISSUES AND YOU
LISTEN TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BIEBER WHO'S LIVING THROUGH
THIS DISASTER. RIGHT NOW IN
HOUSE FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS.
AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE IT'S ABOUT PROBLEM
SOLVING. N. F. FORCE MITIGATION
AND MANAGEMENT IS ONE OF THE
BEST THINGS. AND YOU KNOW I
TALKED TO MY CATTLE RANCHERS
THAT CAN'T GRAZE CATTLE IN EAT
DOWN THE GRASS- IN THE FOREST
ANYMORE BECAUSE- THAT WAS. YOU
KNOW STEPPING ON BIRD- NESTOR
WHATEVER. THAT WHAT THE ISSUE
WAS A FEW YEARS AGO AND ALL OF
THAT IS CREATED CREATED THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IN. I
THINK WE JUST NEED TO GET
ENGAGED AND START- DEALING WITH
THIS PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE- IN A
REALISTIC MANNER. AGAIN I THINK
THAT DOING PASSING THIS BILL
WILL HARM. A LOT OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS- AND IT WILL
COST- A REGULATORY PROCESS WILL
COST A LOT OF MONEY FOR THESE.
INDIVIDUALS AND IT WILL DO NEXT
TO NOTHING TO CHANGE THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE NOW.
THANK YOU SENATOR HURTS HER.
THE FINNISH PRESIDENT TO GET BY
I AM HAPPY ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN IN THE SOUTH OF
SUSPECTED GENERATORS BECAUSE
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUES- REEK WITH COMMON
SENSE IF YOU HAVE THE POWER
SHUT OFFS OR OTHER THINGS
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A SOURCE IN
THE INTERIM TO GENERATE POWER.
IN THE SECOND THING AND I KNOW
IT'S NOT ALWAYS POLITICALLY
CORRECT BUT I THINK IT'S TRUE
WHAT I REMEMBER IS CHAIR OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE OF
THIS HOUSE SOME YEARS AGO MY
FIRST COMMITTEE WAS ABOUT THAN
IN THE FORCE. AND ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF FIRES AND CLIMATE
CHANGE IN ON GREENHOUSE GASES
IT IS TRUE THAT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT WE MADE SO MANY
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS BUT WE
HAVE TO PRIORITIZE THE FIRES WE
LOOKING AT THE TIME IT TAKES IN
TERMS OF WHEN THE FIRE SEASON
STARTS WHEN ZIDANE'S REIGN ALL
OF THOSE FACTORS INFORM BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. TO ME ARTS
IMPORTANT AS WE STAND HERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS INCLUDED
IN THE DISCUSSION AND I MAKE
THESE COMMENTS TODAY I'M GONNA
VOTE FOR THIS MEASURE BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THERE'S ANY FOLKS SOME CARB
LISTENING TO THIS I JOINED WITH
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE
OF SAID THE SAME KIND OF
COMMENT PLEASE AS YOU IMPLEMENT
REGULATIONS UNDERSTAND AND
LISTEN TO. THE LEGISLATURE AND
WHAT THE COMMENTS ARE MAKING
AND WHAT GUIDANCE ARE GIVING.
YOU AS YOU MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR LAMAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AT THIRTEEN FORTY SIX AND I'VE
I'VE HEARD OF IT I THINK AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION BUT YOU
KNOW FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AS
SOMEONE WHO IS- YOU KNOW COMES
FROM A FAMILY WHERE WE HAVE
MULTIPLE MULTIPLE GARDENERS IN
OUR FAMILY AND LANDSCAPING
BUSINESSES- IN THE EXTENDED
FAMILY- I ALSO KNOW THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD I HAD THE
CHANCE TO VISIT- HELLO HI WHO
DID THIS ON THIS ON THEIR OWN
THE THEY STARTED TRANSITIONING-
FROM. SOME OF THESE OLD OLDER
TECHNOLOGIES TO NEWER
TECHNOLOGIES BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO I THINK
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WHAT CONTRIBUTES TO
IT- TO PUT THAT A LAWN MOWER
OR- A LEAF BLOWER IS- IN IN THE
SAME CATEGORY AS A FIRE I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR WE NEED TO DO
WORK ON BOTH I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE- THAT ARE YOU KNOW
WILDFIRES- CONTRIBUTE MORE
EMISSIONS INTO THE AIR DID ANY
OF THESE DO IT BUT IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT AS A LEGISLATURE- WE
DON'T TRY TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THE EVERYDAY THINGS THAT HELP-
OUR ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS-
TACKLE. SOME OF THESE BIGGER
ISSUES AND THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT- THIS IS NEEDED- I KNOW
THAT I THAT I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD
NEED TO TRANSITION- BUT I ALSO
KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT- AMONG.
ALL OF THE YOU KNOW THINGS THAT
WILL BREAK- THEIR LANDSCAPING
BUSINESS THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS THE DIRECTION THAT
CALIFORNIA IS GOING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING AND- AND
SO I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN COMMIT
TO DOING BOTH THE LITTLE THINGS
THAT WORK EVERY DAY BUT ALSO
THE BIGGER ISSUES- THERE
SOMETIMES FEEL MUCH MORE
COMPLEX AND HARDER TO DO AND
SO- WITH A LOT OF RESPECT- TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER WHO I
AGREE WITH WE HAVE GOT TO DO
MORE- AS IT RELATES. TO
WILDFIRES SO THANK YOU. SENATOR
VOTE. HELP CENTER BEDROOM
ACROSS IS A NINE FIVE THANK YOU
ARE THIS BILL MIGHT BE
SUPPORTABLE IF THERE IS A
PROVISION IN IT AND THAT
ANYTHING THAT CARB CAME UP WITH
IN TERMS OF THE REGULATIONS
CAME BACK TO THIS BODY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT AND OUT
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED HERE WHEN WE HAVE OUR
ELECTRIC GRID ALREADY OVER
BURDENED DURING ALL OF THE-
DEMAND ON IT WE'RE ADDING THAT
MANY MORE TOO IT IS
INCONCEIVABLE TO ME THAT WE
WOULD ADD. IN JUST A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME THIS NEW BURDEN
OF- ELECTRICITY ON THAT KOREA
TO FOR A QUICK MENTAL VITAL
VITAL TO SAVING LIVES AND WE'RE
GIVING THAT TO KERR HOW MANY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE WHO
ALL COMMENTED HERE THIS MORNING
REGARDINGCAR DO THIS CAR DO
THAT OF KARBALA ONLY DO THIS OR
THAT THEY'RE NOT ELECTED BODY
THEY HAVE INCREDIBLE POWER I
SIT ON OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY AND OFTEN I BRING UP
THE THAT VERY THING THAT CARBON
IS NOT ELECTED BODY WE GIVE
THEM THE RESPONSIBILITY TO DRAW.
TO BRING IT BACK HERE TO SEE IF
IT REALLY MATTERS THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED IN THOSE
COMMITTEES FOR UNTIL THERE'S
SOME. UNKNOWNS THAT COULD BE
ADDED TO THIS THE WE ADDRESS
BOTH OF THE ISSUES DOWN THIS
BILL SHOULD NOT BE SUPPORTED
TODAY IT WILL BE A HORRIBLE
HORRIBLE BURDEN ON THE PRESENT
AND THE FUTURE WHEN WE CAN'T
HAVE THIS AN ALTERNATE A GAS
POWERED EQUIPMENT THAT HELP OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND HEALTH ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
BLACKOUTS MANY TIMES AND ALL
FOUR WEEKS AND IN IN FRANCE AND
THE OTHER PART OF THE COUNTRY
FOR MONTHS IT WOULD APPEAR SO
PLEASE VOTE NO IT'S NOT
SUPPORTABLE TODAY. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THE OTHER
MEMBER SEEN NINE SENATOR
GONZALES WHICH ARE TOO CLOSE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
ROBUST DEBATE AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON
ALL SIDES BUT I WANT TO REMIND
US SMALL- ENGINES OFF ROAD
ENGINES EMIT AN AVERAGE OF
SIXTEEN POINT EIGHT TONS PER
DAY. OF NITROGEN OXIDE AND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE TONS PER
DAY OF WHAT IS CALLED REACTIVE
ORGANIC GASES IF THE STATE DOES
NOT TAKE ACTION EMISSION LEVELS
FROM SMALL ENGINES ARE EXPECTED
TO INCREASE BY TWENTY THIRTY
ONE IN FACT THEY'LL BE MORE
THAN TWICE THOSE FROM PASSENGER
CARS- THAT'S JUST A REMINDER IN
TERMS OF THE CARB AND
DISCUSSION ABSOLUTELY I THINK
THE AUTHOR HAS DONE A GREAT
JOB- AS MENTIONED IN
SUPPLEMENTING THIS IS A
SUPPLEMENT TO WHAT CARDS
ALREADY REGULATING FOR TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. AT TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT PHASE IN THE LATE PHASE
IN AND AS IT PERTAINS TO
GENERATORS THIS BILL ACTUALLY
ONLY APPLIES TO THE SMALLEST OF
GENERATORS UNDER TWENTY FIVE
HORSE POWERS- WHICH ARE MOSTLY-
USED FOR HOME BACKUP POWER OF
COURSE AND AS A RUNNING AS OF A
REFRIGERATOR OR FOR CAMPING SO
IT ONLY APPLIES THERE AND IT
DOES NOT APPLY TO STATIONARY
GENERATE LARGE STATIONARY
GENERATORS AND DIESEL
GENERATORS. WHICH AGAIN IS NOT
SUBJECT TO THIS BILL JUST TO
PROVIDE MORE CLARIFICATION
THERE I KNOW HE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU ESPECIALLY AS THERE IS A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
APPROPRIATION THAT WILL GET
INTO THE WEEDS OF THIS POLICY
WITH SO WITH THAT I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I'VE-
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FALL I'M
SEVENTY ONE. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. I HATE NO BACKER. HI
PORCHES BRADFORD. BY ADAM.
CORTESE HI DOLLY NO DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN BLAZER
ARE YOU CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH.
NO HERZBERG I WAS SO. HER TADO
NO JONES NOPE CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI FLAVOR I THE MON I
REQUIRE. MELENDEZ NO MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH NO PAN. HI PORTS AND TINA
I BROUGHT. RUBIO SKINNER. FIVE
STERNE AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WINNER I WILL KNOW. I'M
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. PORGES BRADFORD I HAVE
I EVER. DOT EGGMAN WEST SO.
MCGUIRE I NEWMAN. ROTH RUBIO
STERN AMBERG. HIGHS TWENTY ONE
MILLS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON THE
FALL ITEM SEVENTY FOUR A
MEASURE BY ASEMBLYMAN HOLDEN
CENTER COM AUGER SHE'S RUNNING
RUNNING RUNNING MADAM SECRETARY
TICKET TIME EMPLOYEES RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FIVE I'M
REMEMBER HOLDING AN ACTION
RELATING TO HUMAN RESOURCES
TURNER COME OVER WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS. EIGHTY ONE OH FIVE
IDENTIFIES AND REFORMS
PROCESSES THAT HINDER. UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
THE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM. THE
GENESIS OF THIS BILL AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF A SERIES OF
LETTERS. WRITTEN AND PUBLISHED
IN THE SACRAMENTO BEE LAST YEAR
ON BEHALF OF. AFRICAN AMERICAN
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN THE CIVIL
SERVICE SYSTEM. EIGHTY ONE OH
FIVE CALLS FOR DIVERSITY ON ALL
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS I
HAVE VOLUNTEERS. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT THE
STATE PERSONNEL BOARD TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES DIVERSITY AND BEST
PRACTICES IN EACH ASPECT OF THE
DESIGN ANNOUNCEMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION OF EXAMINATIONS.
EIGHTY ONE OH FIVE PROVIDES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES MAY DEVELOP MODEL
UPWARD MOBILITY GOALS TO
INCLUDE RACE GENDER LGBTQ
VETERAN STATUS OR PHYSICAL OR
MENTAL DISABILITY AS FACTORS.
TO THE EXTENT PERMISSIBLE UNDER
STATE AND FEDERAL EQUAL
PROTECTION LAWS FINALLY A. B.
ONE OH FIVE CALLS FOR STATE
AGENCIES TO COLLECT AND REPORT
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA USING MORE
NUANCED CATEGORIES. OF
CALIFORNIANS OF AFRICAN DESCENT
SIMILAR TO THE DATA COLLECTED
FOR CALIFORNIANS OF ASIAN
DESCENT. THIS DATA IS CRITICAL
TO ACCURATELY REPORTING WHO
AMONG CALIFORNIANS OF AFRICAN
DESCENT EXPERIENCE BARRIERS TO
UPWARD MOBILITY ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL GIVES A REPARATION
TASK FORCE MORE ACCURATE DATA
TO UTILIZE IN ITS DELIBERATIONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FALL
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR. ANY OTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSIONS HERE AND
SEEN ON MOUNT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND FALL I'M
SEVENTY FOUR. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I BASE NO BACKER I
PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE A HI
CORTESE I DALLY. NO DODD I
TORONTO I AIKMAN BLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LABOR HI THE MON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TRUCK OKAY NO PAM.
HI FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT.
FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG I LIKE ASKING. I WINNER
I WILL KNOW. ZURCHER PLEASE
CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS. PORGES
EGGMAN STERN. ALL EYES TWENTY
NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE GONNA PASS
ON FALL ART I'M SEVENTY SIX
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE SOONER A
GRAND. ALL RIGHT. OKAY WE'RE
MOVING AGAIN WE'RE NOT PASSING
ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX
SENATOR LEVEL PRESENT- AV
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDICAL INFORMATION
CENTER LEVEL THANK YOU MR FOR
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION WHICH
STRENGTHENS PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS
MEMBERS BECAUSE OF THE COURT
FORMAL CARE ACT MANY YOUNG
ADULTS OR STAYING ON THEIR
PARENTS HEALTH CARE PLANS UNTIL
AGE TWENTY SIX. ADDITIONALLY
MANY PEOPLE ON THEIR PARTNER ON
THE PARTNER'S HEALTH PLANS AS A
RESULT MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
THE PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER FOR
THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE THE
PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER IS THE
PERSON WHO RECEIVES THE
COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT SERVICES
RENDERED AND AN EXPLANATION OF
BENEFITS. IN SOME INSTANCES THE
PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER MAY
RECEIVE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TYPE OF CARE PROVIDED THAT THE
PATIENT DOES NOT WANT REVEALED
TO THE PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER IN
SOME CASES IT CAN EVEN BE
DANGEROUS FOR THE PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT SERVICES
ANOTHER PATIENT ON THEIR PLAN
HAS RECEIVED. FOR EXAMPLE A
TRANS YOUTH MAY NOT WANT THEIR
PARENTS TO KNOW THAT THEY ARE
ACCESSING GENDER AFFIRMING
SERVICES A WOMAN WHO IS
ACCESSING REPRODUCTIVE CARE OR
CARE RELATED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE MAY NOT WANT HER
PERFECT PARTNER TO KNOW THAT
SHE IS ACCESSING THAT CARE.
THIS BILL UPDATES EXISTING
PATIENT PRIVACY LAWS TO DO A
FEW THINGS FIRST IT
AUTOMATICALLY ENSURES THAT THE
COMMUNICATIONS FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANY REGARDING
SENSITIVE CITY SERVICES. AS
DEFINED ARE CONFIDENTIAL AND
NOT SENT TO THE PRIMARY POLICY
HOLDER SECOND IT EXPANDS
EXISTING DEFINITION OF
SENSITIVE SENSITIVE SERVICES TO
INCLUDE GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
EXTENDING AUTOMATIC
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR THESE
SERVICES THIRD IT ENSURES THAT
PATIENTS WHO ARE NOT RECEIVING
SENSITIVE SERVICES HAVE A
PATHWAY TO REQUEST CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS FROM THEIR
HEALTH PLAN. AND LASTLY IT
INSURES THAT PATIENTS ARE AT
DID ABOUT THE CALL. RIGHTS BY
REQUIRING PLANTS TO PROVIDE
NOTICE. I WANT TO BE CLEAR WE
HAVE HEARD FROM OPPOSITION SOME
FALSEHOODS THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE EXISTING MEDICAL CONSENT
LAWS NOR. DOES IT CHANGE THE
AGE OF CONSENT FOR ANY SERVICE
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO NEED.
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS CAN
RECEIVE IT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FALL
ITEM SEVENTY SIX ANY ADDITIONAL
DESCRIPTION INTEGRATE CENTER
TOLD ALL. MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE WITH CONCERNS
ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR SPECIALLY AS A
PARENT. WOULD YOU BE
ENCOURAGING PARENTS AND
FAMILIES TO BE INVOLVED WITH
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES NOT
REMOVING THEM FROM IT. IF
NEEDED. GIVE PARENTS THE TOOLS
AND SUPPORT THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO REALLY HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. AS THEY SEEK MEDICAL
PROCEDURES THIS BILL IN AN
EFFORT TO FURTHER HIDE
INFORMATION FROM PARENTS AND
PARTNERS IN CARE GIVERS WOULD
PUT POLICY HOLDERS IN THE
IMPOSSIBLE POSITION OF BEING
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
BILLS. HE DID NOT IN HER CANNOT
VERIFY AS BEING LEGITIMATE.
ADDITIONALLY IT FURTHER LIMITS
PARENTS ABILITIES TO PROTECT
THEIR CHILDREN BY REMOVING THEM
FROM SENSITIVE CONVERSATION AS
EARLY AS TWELVE YEARS OLD. AND
I NEED TO ADD THAT IN OTHER YOU
KNOW I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
SITTING IN PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
PUBLIC SECTOR YOU OFTEN HEAR
HOW. MANY OF OUR YOUTH UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX DO NOT
HAVE THE CAPACITY SHOULD NOT BE
LIABLE FOR DECISIONS. THAT THEY
MAKE IN THEIR LIFE DURING THAT
JOURNEY AND YET AT THIS TIME WE
ARE LEAVING THEM ALONE TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND DO. A PROCEDURE
PROCEDURES OR MEDICAL
TREATMENTS WITHOUT THE GUIDANCE
OF AN ADULT IN THEIR PERSONAL
LIVES SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. RENEWABLE
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSIONOR DEBATE. ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR GIRL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TOO I RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR- IN LINE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS- THAT JUST
PREVIOUSLY SPOKE AND THIS BILL
IS A DIRECT ATTACK ON ON
PARENTS RIGHTS. IT UNDERMINES
PARENTS RIGHTS IN THE GUIDE-
IN. IN THEIR RIGHT TO GUIDE AND
CONTROL- HEALTH CARE FOR THEIR
MINOR CHILDREN AS TWELVE YEARS
OLD I MEAN TWELVE YEARS OLD
YOU'RE IN FIFTH GRADE. YOU
SHOULDN'T BE THINKING ABOUT
GOING OFF OF CAMPUS AND-
GETTING AN ABORTION AND TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT- OR HAVING A
MEDICAL PROCEDURE ANY MEDICAL
PROCEDURE- WITHOUT YOUR PARENTS
KNOWLEDGE AND CONSULTATION. THE
BILL ENCOURAGES. CHILDREN TO
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES ALONE TO
HIDE IT FROM THEIR PARENTS- I
THINK THAT CREATES A DIVISION
BETWEEN PARENTS. AND CHILDREN-
I THINK THE STATE INTERFERING
IN RAISING CHILDREN- THESE DAYS
IS JUST CONTINUALLY OVER
REACHING I KNOW IT ALWAYS SEEMS
LIKE IT'S AROUND THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION- SEIZURES- REGARDING
SEX- SEXUAL TRANSITIONS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. THAT'S WHAT
THE- THE LANGUAGE HAS BEEN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT NOT ONLY PARENTS ARE
BEING REMOVED FOR HAVING THEIR
SAY IN THEIR OWN CHILDREN'S
LIVES BUT THIS BILL GOES
FURTHER TO REQUIRE. SOME
TERRORISTS TO PAY FOR THOSE AND
DISCLOSED PROCEDURES ARE BASED
ON THEIR MEDICAL INSURANCE. AND
NONE OF US WOULD WANT TO PAY
FOR A BILL THAT WE HAD NO
INFORMATION ON THE BILITY. TO
ADDRESS- WHAT HAPPENED I THINK
THE MONEY IS JUST A SECONDARY
THING I THINK THE ISSUE IS
BETWEEN THE PARENT AND THE
CHILD. AND HAVING A PARENT A
CHILD AS YOUNG AS TWELVE YEARS
OLD- THAT'S THE IN THE FOURTH
GRADE BEGINNING A FIFTH GRADE A
TWELVE YEAR OLD CHILD MAKING
MEDICAL DECISIONS. ABOUT THEIR-
ABOUT MEDICAL ISSUES RIGHT
COULD YOU IMAGINE AS A PARENT
MOST OF US ARE PARENTS IN HERE
SOME OF US ARE NOT. COULD YOU
IMAGINE IF YOU SEND YOUR KID
OFF TO SCHOOL AND- AND YOU
DIDN'T KNOW THAT AS A TEACHER
OR A SCHOOL NURSE TO COME TO A
CLINIC TO HAVE A MEDICAL
PROCEDURE. AND UNDER ANESTHESIA
OR UNDER GENERAL ANESTHESIA OR
WHATEVER SOMETHING HAPPENED AND
THAT CHILD LOST ITS LIFE. I
MEAN YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
SOME OF THESE PROCEDURES THAT
ARE GOING ON AND TO HAVE. THIS
BILL COME FORWARD AND HAVE THE
INSURANCE COMPANY PAY FOR IT-
WITHOUT THE PARENTS KNOWLEDGE.
OF ANYWAY. YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
LOOK AT. WE SHOULD WHAT TEXAS
DID TRULY WE SHOULD REALLY LOOK
AT WHAT TEXAS DID TO PROTECT
THE LIFE OF THE UNBORN WE
SHOULD ALSO LOOK AT OTHER
STATES THAT ARE LOOKING AT
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD PROTECT.
NOT ONLY THE ON BOARD BUT THE
INDIVIDUALS- KIDS RIGHTS. THEIR
KIDS THEIR KIDS HAVING THE
ABILITY DISCUSS THESE THINGS
WITH PARENTS. THERE ARE KIDS-
THE GOVERNMENT OF THE HOSPITAL
NONPROFITS. THEY'RE NOT THEM
THERE ARE KIDS AND I WOULD ASK
OF RESPECTFULLY FOR A NO VOTE.
IN MAKING THESE DECISIONS- MAKE
BE THE PARENTS AND THE FAMILIES
DECISIONS. AND NOT JUST THE
CHILD STANDING ALONE AT TWELVE
YEARS OLD. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NINE CENTER LEVEL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO HELP
MY- COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
WHEN SHE'S TALKING ABOUT TWELVE
YEAR OLD THAT'S CURRENT LAW
RIGHT NOW THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE CURRENT LAW SO IF YOU DO
NOT LIKE THAT THEN YOU SHOULD
INTRODUCE A BILL ENTRENCHING
SALAH. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE WHICH I SAID IN MY
INITIAL REMARKS DOES NOT CHANGE
EXISTING MEDICAL CONSENT LAWS
NOR DOES IT CHANGE THE AGE OF
CONSENT FOR ANY SERVICE LET ME
REPEAT MYSELF ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
NEED CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS. CAN RECEIVE IT
WE CAN TALK ABOUT TEXAS ANOTHER
DAY PASSED HER NO VOTE. HI NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE
MOMENTUM THIRD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX
TH ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE NO BACKER ALL
RIGHT FORTUS BRADFORD HI BY
ADAM HI CORTEZ HE I. DALI NO
DODD. I TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER
FIVE CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE.
NO HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HI HER
TADO FIVE JONES NO CAMCORDER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I FOR THE MOST.
HI WIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TRY. NO
PAM HI PERSON TINA I. ROSS FIVE
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I STERN I'M
BERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. I'M SECTOR
POLICE CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS.
PORCHES EGGMAN STERN WELL NO.
MARCH TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK FROM
MESSAGES FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. MADAM
PRESIDENT I DRUG I AM DIRECTED
TO INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND
ON THIS DAY PASSED AS AMENDED
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY TWO.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCURRENCE THAT AMENDMENTS TO
PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILL ORDERED TWO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE.
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. SENATOR PAN
ARE YOU PREPARED. HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY MARY. SENATE BILL
SEVEN FORTY TWO BY SENATOR PAN
AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF-CITRIX MEDIA. CENTER PLANT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATOR
SESAME SEVEN FORTY TWO IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. SINCE WE LAST
VOTED ON THIS BILL HERE ON THIS
FLORIDA NUMBER OF CODE REPORT
THAT'S IN CALIFORNIA'S RIDGES
INTO OVER SIXTY SIX THOUSAND.
IN FACT THE MORE INFECTIOUS
DELTA VARIANT HAS MADE
INCREASING OUR VACCINATION
RATES EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO
CONTROLLING THIS PANDEMIC.
STILL THAT HASN'T STOPPED
SPREADING HOWEVER THE
EXTREMISTS CONTINUE TO ESCALATE
THEIR ATTACKS ON VACCINATION
SITES. ARE SHOWING THAT VACCINE
CLINICS IN COMMUNITIES WITH
THIS- WITH THE TERMINATING
HARASSING EVEN ASSAULTING
PEOPLE- PATIENTS AND EALTH
CARE WORKERS TRYING TO SHUT
CLINICS DOWN. FACT AT LEAST TWO
OCCASIONS HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO
SCREAM AS IF YOU'RE DRIVEN TO
CARS INTO VACCINATION SITES AND
TRY TO STRIKE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. HOWEVER WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO WORK ON SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO TENDERLY CRAFTED SO
WE CAN HAVE ACCESS TO VACCINES
PROTECT PATIENT PRIVACY SAFETY
FOR PATIENTS HEALTHCARE WORKERS
AND FREEDOM SPEECH. FAMILY MAN
IT'S NEAR THE DISTANCE TO WHAT
WE KNOW AIRBORNE ERRORS AND
ERRORS ALL DISEASES CAN BE
SPREAD AS DECLARATIONS AND
FINDINGS. MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES ENSURED THE BILLS
CONTENT NEUTRAL AND CLARIFIED
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
SUPERSEDE EXISTING REGULATIONS
AROUND LAWFUL UNION PICKETING
ESPECIALLY. ASPIRIN I VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU ANY FOR
THIS IN DEBATE SENATOR NELSON.
PROSELYTISM REC CENTER ARGENEAU
VOTE HOW FAR ARE WE GOING TO
GOAL IN SOCIETY TO STIFLE FREE
SPEECH AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT. FOR CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS CONSTITUENCIES HAVE
A DIFFERENCE SO WHAT DO THEY
WANT TO DO ALL. THAT SOMEBODY
HAVE THEIR SAY NO NO WE'RE
GONNA. REALLY MAKE IT
DIFFICULT. THAT'S ALL THIS IS
ABOUT IT'S CENTER AND I
REGIONAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
GIRL. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
HATES FREE SPEECH UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION WHAT DO YOU LIKE
THE SPEECH OR NOT IT'S FREE
SPEECH- PROTESTERS OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW OVER ELEVEN OH TWO IN
THE FEAR THAT THAT WAS GOING TO
BE A VACCINE MANDATE- THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DO THAT WHEN
PEOPLE CAME OUT LAST SUMMER AND
BLACK LIVES MATTER AND THEY DID
PROTEST AND- YOU KNOW TORE DOWN
STATUES YOU KNOW I DISAGREE
WITH THAT BUT- YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THEY SHOULD BUILD A
DAMAGED PROPERTY BUT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO BE OUT THERE. YOU
KNOW PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO
HAVE A GRIEVANCE AGAINST THEIR
GOVERNMENT THEIR GOVERNMENT
JUST BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
THIS SPEECH DOESN'T MEAN THAT
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY YOU
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO BAN THE
SPEECH- YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
VACCINE INFORMATION THE OTHER
DAY MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MENTIONED ALL THIS.
FALL STUFF THAT HE SAYS COMES
OFF OF FOX NEWS. AND THE RIGHT
WING AND IT WAS MENTIONED.
EARLIER BY ANOTHER COLLEAGUE
THAT YOU KNOW WITH WITH THE
RIGHT PUTS FORWARD AT THE
EXTREME RIGHT. IF YOU LOOK AT.
AND THE STUFF SURROUNDING
VACCINES A LOT OF THE
MISINFORMATION COMES FROM CNN
MSNBC THE ADMINISTRATION. US
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT CONSISTENT
RIGHT. FOR INSTANCE. LAST YEAR
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS NON
VACCINATED WORKING IN HOSPITALS
AND COVERT NINETEEN. ALL THE
WAY THROUGH NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY. THEY WERE HEROES MADE
YARD SIGNS ALL OVER BILLBOARDS
WERE PUT AT. HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ARE HEROES THIS EAR
THEY'RE EVIL AND THEY'RE AWFUL
BECAUSE THEY REFUSED TO GET
VACCINATED SOME OF THEM DO. SO
I THINK WE JUST HAVE TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH OUR MESSAGING
CONSISTENCY IS FOLLOWING THE
CONSTITUTION. THIS IS FREEDOM
OF SPEECH. AND JUST LIKE I SAID
THOSE PROTESTERS OUTSIDE OF THE
ONES THAT WERE HERE LAST SUMMER
OR THE WORSHIP EVENT. FOR
PROTESTING NOT ALLOWING TO BE
YOU KNOW ABLE TO WORSHIP IN
CHURCHES. AND THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH SO IF
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DRIVE THEIR
CARS INTO. CLINICS THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WRITE TO CAUSE HARM TO
ANOTHER PERSON. AND YOU KNOW IN
SOME TYPE OF VIOLENT PROTESTS.
BUT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
STAND UP. WHETHER IT'S
REGARDING THIS SITUATION OR THE
SITUATION THAT WE HAD THE OTHER
DAY THAT. TALKS ABOUT AND YOU
KNOW ABORTION CLINICS. YOU
KNOW. THE PEOPLE WHO PRAY FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING ITO
THOSE SITUATIONS. AND ASK THEM
TO KEEP THAT BABY THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE THERE IT'S A PUBLIC
SIDEWALK. THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO BE THERE TO PROTECT PROTEST.
HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT MANDATORY
VACCINES IN ABOUT MANDATED
VACCINES AND ABOUT VACCINES IN
GENERAL. AND I THINK THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE ALL THIS GOING ON
IF THERE WAS SOME TYPE OF
CONSISTENCY COMING OUT OF BOTH
ADMINISTRATIONS. PREVIOUS THIS
ONE. AND THE ONE THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY ASKS
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR MAN I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
PERMISSION ASKED. WILL THE-
PRESENTER TAKE A QUESTION- HI
HAS THERE BEEN ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL ANALYSIS AS LEAD
COUNSEL WAITIN ON WHETHER THIS
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. HI YES THIS IS BEEN
EVALUATED BY LEGAL COUNSEL AND-
THIS- BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT- THIS SEEMS
CONSISTENT JUST UPON READING
THIS WITH- THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT ARE IN PLACE FOR POLLING
PLACES AND- AGAIN JUST YOU KNOW
GOING BACK TO FIRST YEAR OF LAW
SCHOOL. ON THE FIRST AMENDMENT
CERTAINLY PROTECTS OUR RIGHT TO
FREE SPEECH BUT THERE ARE
LIMITS THE FIRST AMENDMENT YOU
CAN'T YELL FIRE IN A CROWDED
THEATER. YOU CAN'T INJURE
PEOPLE AND I BELIEVE THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. PASSING PEOPLE
PHYSICALLY INTIMIDATING THEM
PREVENTING THEM FROM GETTING
VACCINES- I THINK FALLS OUTSIDE
THE BOUNDS OF SPEECH IN INTO
THE- ACTIVITY OF UNPROTECTED-
ACTIVITIES THAT THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO HARASS INTIMIDATE-
WITH THREAT OF VIOLENCE- PEOPLE
FROM. DOING A PERMITTED
ACTIVITY- AND I WOULD JUST-
MAYBE TAKE ISSUE WITH ONE
COMMENT MADE. WITH FROM MY CAR
BUT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD. I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S ILLEGAL AND I DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S PROTECTED FREE
SPEECH TO TEAR DOWN STATUES SO
WHETHER THAT'S BLACK LIVES
MATTER. WITH THAT THE
PROTESTERS OUTSIDE IF THEY WERE
TO TEAR DOWN A STATUE- THAT
CROSSES THE LINE AND
DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY AND I
BELIEVE THAT THAT SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED- SO AGAIN. I STAND
FOR MOST OF THE PRINCIPLE THAT
WE SHOULD PROTECT FREE SPEECH-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT- WHEN SPEECH.
GIVES WAY TO VIOLENT ACTION OF
THE THREAT OF VIOLENT ACTION
BUT IT NO LONGER IS PROTECTED
BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IF NOT SENATOR PANIC YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LET'S BE CLEAR SB
SEVEN FOUR TWO DOES NOT PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM PROTESTING ARE
SPEAKING OUT IT PREVENTS THEM
FROM HARASSING. AND THREATENING
PATIENTS TAKING AWAY THEIR
PRIVACY AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
WHO ARE DELIVERING VACCINES ARE
STRICTLY ASPEN I DON'T THINK
YOU MEANT SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM TWO TWO
SEVEN. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER I
FORGES BRADFORD I HAVE A BETTER
LIFE FOR TESTING HI DOLLY NO
DODD. HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE.
NO HERTZBERG FIVE WESA. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LABOUR HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO A CHOKE NO
PAM I FOURTEEN TINA. I. ROSS I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN BERGER
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL
NOW. I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. FORTUS
EGGMAN HER TADO. STERN VICE
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE IN THE NEXT TEN MINUTES
ARE CONCURRED ON. TWENTY EIGHT.
MARCH TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT
THE MINUTES ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS- THIS WILL BE OUR FINAL
MAJOR BEFORE TAKING LUNCH WE'RE
GOING TO ASK MEMBERS TO GRAB
THEIR LUNCH AND TAKE IT BACK TO
YOUR OFFICE BUT BEFORE THEN
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ANNOUNCEMENTS
AS IT RELATES TO COMMITTEES WE
HAVE BOTH HEALTH AND LABOR DO
WE HAVE THE NONSENSE BY THE
RESPECTIVE CHAIRS SENATOR
CORTESE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THE SENATE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
WILL MEET. UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
HEALTH COMMITTEE- DURING THIS A
SHORT RECESS SO HEALTH
COMMITTEES GOING FIRST FIFTEEN
MINUTES LATER. LABOUR WILL
COMPETE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
THAT IS IN- ROOM FOR TWO OR
THREE. SO WE'RE HAVING FORTY
TWO OH TWO WE'RE HAVING BOTH.
HEALTH AND LABOR MEETING AND
FORTY TWO OH TWO IS THERE A-
NOT SOMEBODY HEALTH COMMITTEE
MISINTERPRET THREE YES THIS IS
A SECONDHAND HEALTH WILL BE IN
LEAVES ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
OF THE HEARING UP ON THE RECESS
OF THE SPORTS SECTION. BECAUSE
MY MISTAKE IT'S FORTY TWO OH
THREE YOU'RE CORRECT DR PANTS
SO WE'LL BE MEETING- DURING
THIS RECESS. MEMBERS WERE GONNA
ASK MEMBERS RETURNED PROMPTLY
AT ONE THIRTY WE'RE GONNA ASK
YOU TO TAKE YOUR- LUNCH TO YOUR
OFFICE AND IF- UPON YOUR RETURN
AT ONE THIRTY YOU'RE STILL
HUNGRY I WE I SHOULD GRAB SOME
LADIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
WELCOME BACK FROM OUR RECESS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM THIRTY. SP
TWO SENATOR BRADFORD. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. CENTRE BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AS FEATURE
DO BETTER KNOWN AS THE KENNETH
ROSS JUNIOR PLEASE TO
CERTIFICATION ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL IS JOINT
AUTHORED BY MYSELF AND OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS
AND IT'S A PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. I
WANT TO THANK ALL THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED THEMSELVES IN
THIS DISCUSSION OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF TO BRING US TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. THIS BILL
DOES TOO SIMPLE THINGS THE BILL
MAKES CHANGES TO STRENGTHEN THE
THOMAS PAINE ACT CIVIL RIGHTS
BY CLARIFYING THROUGH THE MOST
EGREGIOUS IMMUNITIES CALMLY
ASSERTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
NOT APPLICABLE TO CLAIM- TO
CLAIMS BROUGHT UNDER THE BAN
ACT. IT THEN ALSO CREATES A
STATEWIDE PROCESS TO REVOKE THE
CERTIFICATION. OF AN OFFICER
AFTER. MEETING CRIMES OR
TERMINATION FROM EMPLOYMENT TO
THE MISCONDUCT AGAIN WE'RE
ASKING OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO FOLLOW. OVER TWO
HUNDRED DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS
TO HAVE A FAIR AND TRANSPARENT
WAY OF DECERTIFYING BAD
OPERATORS. MANY CHANGES IS BILL
HAVE BEEN MADE SINCE YOU LAST
HEARD IN THE SENATE. AND NOW
REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE BY
POST. COMMISSION TO DECERTIFY
ANY OFFICER IT ALLOWS FOR THE
SUSPENSION RATHER THAN THE
MEDIA- DECIRTE ALTOGETHER-
LEAVES OUT OPTION IS AS AN
OPTION IT REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT OF HAVING TWO
VICTIMS FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
ABUSE OR THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
ON THE ADVISORY BOARD BUT
ALLOWS A GOVERNOR TO GIVE GREAT
CONSIDERATION TO THAT- ALL
BOARD MEMBERS ARE REQUIRED TO
TAKE FORTY HOURS OF TRAINING.
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT PRACTICES
AND STANDARDS- THE LICENSE FEE
HAS BEEN WAIVED FOR THOSE
OFFICERS PROVIDED BOARD CAN NO
LONGER IT INITIATE AN
INVESTIGATION THEY CAN ONLY I
RECOMMEND TO THE COMMISSION.
AND SO ON I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THERE IS CURRENTLY A
TECHNICAL ERROR BY THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL REGARDING
ONE OF THE MEMBERS TO THE BILL
AND IT'S BEING ADDRESSED IN
ANOTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THAT MIMIC CLARIFIES THAT
EXISTING LAW REGARDING ISSUES.
R. PRECLUSION APPLIES TO THE
BILL. REGARDING ISSUE
PRECLUSION IMPLIES THE BILL WAS
PLACED IN THE WRONG SECTION BUT
IT WILL BE CORRECTED IN A
DIFFERENT BILL IN THE COMING
DAYS. AGAIN MEMBERS. THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF EFFORT HERE TO
GET US TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY I
THINK WE HAVE A GOOD BILL THAT
WE AS CALIFORNIANS CAN BE PROUD
OF. LAW ENFORCEMENT STILL
REMAINS A POLLS BUT MANY OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE MADE THAT WE MADE
ADDRESS MANY THERE'S CONCERNS
ABOUT- CREATING A SYSTEM THAT
WOULD ONLY PRESERVE THE STATUS
QUO WE'VE CLEARLY NOW THAT
WE'VE SEEN A HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS OF THE POLICE POLICING
THEMSELVES AND IT DOESN'T WORK-
THIS BILL DOESN'T MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO DECERTIFY
OFFICERS NOR WILL IT. CALLS
OFFICERS TO BE CERTIFIED FOR
MINOR MINOR OFFENSES AGAIN THIS
IS A PRO. A LAW ENFORCEMENT
MEASURE IT PROTECTS THE
MAJORITY OF MEN AND WOMEN WHO
DO THEIR JOB IN A RESPONSIBLE
AND HONORABLE WAY ON THE DAILY
BASIS THAT BASIS IT ONLY
ADDRESSES THOSE BAD ACTORS. LET
ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE- TWO
WEEKS AGO I WAS CONTACTED BY
THE MAYOR OF TORRENTS IN MY
DISTRICT. THE LET ME KNOW THAT-
THEY HAD TO LET GO OF THIRTEEN
OFFICERS IN THEIR CITY- IT
CREATED. A REAL ABUSES RACISM
AND A LOT OF HORRIBLE
PRACTICES. OF THOSE THIRTEEN
THAT HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ-
BEEN ON SUSPENSION INTO WERE
FIRED. TWO OF ARE YOU BEING
RETIRED. DO YOU HAVE ALREADY
BEEN REHIRED. SO IF THEY HAD.
BRACES AND ABUSE OF POWER
PRACTICES IN TORRANCE. WHY DO
YOU THINK THEY WOULD NOT
CONTINUE IN ANOTHER COMMUNITY
THIS BILL JUST STOPS THAT TYPE
OF BEHAVIOR IT STOPS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS FROM CONTINUING
OFF. AS MY MOTHER SAYS A
LEOPARD CAN'T CHANGE HER
STRIPES ARE THEIR SPOTS. AND
THESE OFFICERS WILL NOT CHANGE
SO THE CERTIFICATION IS THE
ONLY WAY TO RID. OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CREATE. A LEVEL
OF TRUST. S. B. A S. B. TO
CREATE THE STRONGER C.
CERTIFICATION SYSTEM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WHAT MORE DO PROCESS
FOR OFFICERS WITH CIVILIAN
REPRESENTATION AND INPUT. THIS
BILL STOPS THE PROCESS. THAT IS
EFFECTIVE IN READING
DEPARTMENTS OF BAD OFFICERS
PROTECTING OFFICERS WHO DO
THEIR JOB WELL. AND ALL THE
WHILE BEING WORKABLE FOR POST
THE POST COMMISSION. THE TIME
IS NOW TO CREATE A FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT THE CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA- ANYWAY.
OUR COMMUNITIES MUST HAVE FAITH
AND ALL THE OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE HELD TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARD IT WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
CAFIERO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- WINTERIZED TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL I DID NOT
SUPPORT IT WHEN IT CAME TO THE
SENATE FLOOR- NUMBER OF MONTHS
AGO AND THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
ISSUES THAT I WAS EALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT AND- AND I WELL
I JUST WANT TO STAND UP AND SAY
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR BECAUSE
HE WORKED THIS HARD. HE
LISTENED AND TOOK CARE AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED AND THE ISSUES
THAT I WAS MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT- FIRST OF ALL HE HE- HE
TOOK CARE OF THE ISSUES WITH
THE BANE ACT THAT I HAD
CONCERN- FOR IN IN THE- BILL
ORIGINALLY. AND SECOND OF ALL-
THE HE MADE SOME STRUCTURAL
CHANGES TO THE RELATIONSHIP OF
THE COMMISSION AND- THE- THE
COMMISSION. THE- THE BOARD THAT
HAS BEEN BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
THIS BILL AND THE ROLE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. IN DISCIPLINING AND
BEING RESPONSIBLE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL FURTHER- THE HIGHER AND
FIRING UP THEIR POLICE OFFICERS
AND- WHAT DID THE CHANGES DO IS
IT. ELIMINATES THE POSSIBILITY
OF DOUBLE JEOPARDY NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER TWO MOST IMPORTANTLY
IS IT. MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WHO ARE THE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
SUPERVISES THE HIGHER. ON A D.
THAT POLICE OFFICERS THE- THAT
WORKIN THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY
HAVE A PROCESS TO GO THROUGH
INTO THAT PROCESS IS RESPECTED
AND IS PART OF THE- OF THE
COMMISSION- OVERSIGHT AS WELL
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND- AND I ASK THAT YOU.
SUPPORT SB TWO. THANK YOU
CENTER COVERDELL CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE- IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND I THINK THAT DOES
OUR- CALLING FROM SALINAS JUST
POINTED OUT THE BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED IN GOING THROUGH A LOT
OF CHANGES SINCE WE SAW IT ON
OUR FLOOR. AND AS THE AUTHOR
POINTED OUT THE BILL HAS ANYONE
CAN SEE FROM THE FLOOR ANALYSIS
STILL HAS A GOOD DEAL OF
OPPOSITION FROM OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITY. AND
I WANT TO SPEAK TO THAT- THE
VAST VAST MAJORITY. OF OUR
OFFICERS AND THE OFFICERS IN
THE DIFFERENT ASSOCIATIONS
REPRESENTED AND THAT OPPOSITION
LIST WILL NEVER BE AFFECTED BY
THIS BILL. AND THE VAST VAST
MAJORITY OF OUR PEACE OFFICERS
IN OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS KNOW THAT THEY ARE
NOT ABOUT THE WALL THE LAW. AND
THEY ACT ACCORDINGLY THEY ACT
WITH INTEGRITY THEY ACT
APPROPRIATELY. AND IT- I
COMPLETELY APPRECIATE THAT. ANY
CHANGE THAT WOULD-
INTENTIONALLY AFFECT THE STATUS
OF A COLLEAGUE CAN CAN CAUSE AN
ASSOCIATION TO BE IN OPPOSITION
BUT I THINK IN FACT THIS BILL
WILL GREATLY HELP OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BECAUSE
IT'LL GIVE US THE TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
OFFICERS AND VERY FEW THAT FEEL
THEY ARE ABOVE THE LAW AND THAT
ACT IN SUCH A WAY THAT DISPLAYS
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE REGARD
FOR THE LAW. THAT THEY WOULD
NOT CONTINUE IN SUCH SERVICE
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT NOW WHEN WE HAVE SOME
PORTIONS OF OUR COMMUNITIES
MISTRUSTING ONE OF COURSE ME WE
REALLY NEED OUR COMMUNITIES TO
TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS EVERYONE'S
TRUST TO DO THEIR JOB TO
PROPERLY INVESTIGATE A CRIME
THAT IS COMMITTED YOU. SEE WHAT
HAPPENS AND THEN OF COURSE TO
HELP YOU WISH TO BRING A CASE
AGAINST SOMEONE SO TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE WE NEED THAT
TRUST AND WE NEED TO HAVE
OFFICERS THAT APPRECIATE THAT
TRUST AND AS I SAID THE VAST
MAJORITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO SERVE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE
THAT. SO WHILE I. KNOW THAT
THEY ARE NOT WOULD- PREFER THAT
WE DO NOT PASS THIS LAW I THINK
THAT THIS BILL WILL BE A GREAT
ASSET TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND FOR THAT I
STAND IN SUPPORT NOW ASK THAT
YOU ALSO BOWTIE. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
HIGH BELIEVE THAT MOST OF US
WOULD- PERSONALLY SUPPORT A
POLICY OF DECERTIFICATION FOR
PROBLEM POLICE OFFICERS.
HOWEVER THIS BILL- IT WAS
APPROVED IN THE ASSEMBLY OR
IMPROVED ACTUALLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY IT STILL HAS
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS THAT
JUSTIFY A NO VOTE. THE
DEFINITION OF SERIOUSNESS
CONTACT IS VAGUELY DESCRIBEDIN
WOULD BE LEFT UP TO
INTERPRETATION OF POST
COMMISSION THE POST COMMISSION
VICE REPORT. WHICH IS AN
UNELECTED BODY OF APPOINTEES
THE POST ADVISORY BOARD ITSELF
IS PROBLEMATIC SINCE TWO PUBLIC
MEMBERS ARE ENCOURAGED
ENCOURAGED TO BE VICTIMS OF
POLICE MISCONDUCT MAKING A
MOCKERY OF THE IDEA. THAT ANY
POLICE OFFICER WOULD GET A FAIR
TRIAL OR A FAIR HEARING. I'M
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT STRIPPING
AWAY STATUTORY PROTECTIONS SUCH
AS POLICE OFFICERS BILL OF
RIGHTS. MEMBERS WHEN THIS BILL
WAS PRESENTED TO THE FULL
ASSEMBLY THE FLOOR JACKIE SAID
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT BILL. I
WOULD SAY- IT'S A BAD BILL AND
THAT WHEN WE MAKE IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT TO BECOME POLICE
OFFICERS IN THE STATE- THIS
BILL IS EXACTLY WHAT THAT WOULD
DO. SPT WEAKENS THE PROCESS FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT INPUTS THEIR
CAREER INTO THE HANDS OF A
BIASED UNACCOUNTABLE BOARD-
THIS UNACCOUNTABLE BOARD IS NOT
ON THE STREET AT NIGHT WHEN
OFFICERS HAVE TO MAKE A SPLIT
SECOND DECISION IT'S ALL EASY
FOR US TO YOU MONDAY MORNING
ACCORDING QUARTERBACKING AND
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED- THAT POLICE
OFFICERS MADE A SPLIT DOES
SECOND DECISION ON NOT KNOWING
WHAT THEY KNEW THE FOLLOWING
MORNING AND PEOPLE CAN ALWAYS
SAY- I WOULD HAVE DONE- THIS
WOULD HAVE DONE BETTER OR MAKE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST OFFICERS
BUT AT THAT VERY MOMENT RUNNING
DOWN AN ALLEY CHASING SOMEBODY
THAT HAS SOMETHING IN THEIR
HAND IDENTIFIED AS A FIREARM OR
A WEAPON. AND IT'S A STICKER
IT'S WHATEVER IT IS WHATEVER
THE STORY ENDS UP BEING AT THAT
VERY MOMENT POLICE OFFICERS
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S SUCH A
BROAD DEFINITION IN THIS BILL.
AND I KNOW A LOT OF THE
SURROUNDS- THE GEORGE FLOYD- IT
INCIDENT WHERE WE- ALL OF US
WATCHED IN HORROR. AS DEREK
CHAUVIN- BRUTALLY MURDERED BY
AN INDIVIDUAL A HUMAN RIGHTS A
HUMAN WITH RIGHTS. AND HE WAS A
BAD POLICE OFFICER. BUT THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WORKS. ERIC
CHAUVIN IS NOW SERVING OVER
TWENTY TWO YEARS IN PRISON. SO
THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE WORKS AND WHEN SOMETHING.
THAT IS ATROCIOUS IS WHAT
HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD. GETS
PUT IN AT IT GETS THAT GOES
THROUGH THE SYSTEM THEN
OFFICERS- ARE SERVING IN PRISON
JUST LIKE IT'S PROVEN THAT.
THEIR CHILDREN AS- I THINK TO
LABEL ALL OF OUR MEN AND WOMEN
IN BLUE THAT PROTECT US AND
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE. OF
LIKE AN OFFICER LIKE THEIR
CHILDREN IS UNACCEPTABLE AND
NOT RIGHT. THE PEOPLE IN BLUE
THAT SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
DESERVE A DEEPER RESPECT. AND I
WOULD ASK YOU FOR IT A NO VOTE.
THE CENTER GROUP CENTER HER
TADO. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I KNOW THAT WHEN THIS
MEASURE WAS FIRST BROUGHT TO
THE SENATE FLOOR I DID NOT
SUPPORTED I HAVE. I HAD
CONCERNS AT THE MOMENT. AND TO
BE HONEST THERE'S STILL A
LITTLE BIT OF CONCERNED AND A
LITTLE BIT OF FEAR AND ANOTHER
IS A LITTLE BIT THERE'S A LOT
OF FEAR- ESPECIALLY AMONGST OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY- COMMUNITY.
REGARDING THIS AND MANY OTHER
BILLS BUT- I THINK THAT THE
SPILL IS. WORKING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO PROVIDE. JUSTICE
NOT JUST FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
BUT ALSO FOR ALL THE GOOD
OFFICES AND ALL THE- PAUL'S
WORK THAT THEY DO IN THE
COMMUNITY AND- I'M NOT THE
BIGGEST FAN OF THE WAY THE
COMMISSIONERS ARE SET UP BUT- I
HOPE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IMPROVEMENTS. AND I
HAVE FULL FAITH THAT THIS IS
GOING TO WORK FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THESE REASONS I
WILL BE INSTRUCTS THE PARDONING
COURAGE ALL OF YOU TO SUPPORT
IT AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
HER TITLE MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
COM LONGER.
MADAM CHAIR I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO- YOU
KNOW THIS BILL HAS. GONE
THROUGH- A METAMORPHOSIS QUITE
FRANKLY- SINCE IT LEFT THIS
FLOOR- AND TRAVELED ON TO THE
ASSEMBLY- AND IT IS BACK- AND-
IT IT. ARE THERE ARE SO MANY OF
THE CONCERNS AND SUGGESTIONS ON
THAT THE AUTHOR HEARD- FROM SO
MANY OF HIS COLLEAGUES ON THIS
BILL. AND I THINK AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER A FEW THINGS. THAT THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE DOES NOT
HAVE THE FINAL SAY. THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS FOLKS SHOULD
NOT BE AFRAID OF AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. IF YOU WANT TO BE
COMPLETELY HONEST YOU KNOW THAT
OFTEN TIMES FOLKS DON'T ALWAYS
TAKE THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF AN
ADVISORY COUNCIL. BUT THEY LIKE
TO HAVE THAT ENTITY THERE. GIVE
SOME ADDITIONAL PERSPECTIVE.
THIS BILL STILL WILL ALLOW FOR
THE DECERTIFICATION OF BAD
APPLES AND WHAT WE KNOW FOR
SURE IS THAT BAD APPLES. PUT
EVERYONE'S LIFE IN DANGER.
INCLUDING THE LIVES OF THEIR
PARTNERS AND THEIR COLLEAGUES.
AND THEIR FELLOW OFFICERS ON
THE FORCE AND THE LAST THING I
JUST WANT TO REMIND US IS THAT.
IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER HOW
YOU LABEL YOURSELF IF YOU'RE AN
ACTIVIST IF YOU'RE AN ACADEMIC
IF YOU'RE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT IF
YOUR PRACTITIONER. YOU CAN COME
TO THE TABLE WITH ALL OF THOSE
LABELS. WHAT'S AT STAKE IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN. ALL OF THOSE
FOLKS COME AND LISTEN TO CASES.
AND DIG INTO THE INVESTIGATION.
AND I HOPE THAT WE ARE NOT
STILL CONTINUING TO BE AFRAID
OF THOSE LABELS AND SUGGEST
THAT IF YOU'RE AN ACTIVIST YOU
CAN'T BE PRO PUBLIC SAFETY THAT
IF YOU'RE A PRACTITIONER YOU
CAN'T BE AGAINST LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT IF YOU'RE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER YOU
CAN'T BE AGAINST. CITIZENS WHO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT POLICE
MISCONDUCT. WE SHOULDN'T LET
LABELS MOTIVATE OUR FEARS ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE HOPING THIS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE CAN ADD.
WHICH AT THE END OF THE DAY ARE
JUST DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES.
AND WE ALL KNOW THIS BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS IT'S AMAZING. HOW
MANY SIMILARITIES WE HAVE WHEN
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ISSUES.
WHY WOULD WE THINK THAT THAT
WOULDN'T HAPPEN IN THIS CASE
WITH THIS BILL. I ONCE AGAIN
JUST HAVE TO ASK US TO LEAN
INTO THE FAITH THAT WE ALL HAVE.
IN PEOPLE WHO WOULD COME TO THE
SPACE WANTING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING WANTING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR LAW EFORCEMENT
WANTING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
FOR CITIZENS AND ULTIMATELY
WANTING TO BE PART OF SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE BENEFICIAL FOR
THIS STATE. THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT ARE INCREDIBLY
ASPIRATIONAL AND I SUBMIT TO
YOU THAT THEY ARE ALL THINGS
THAT ARE ALSO NOW IN THIS BILL.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO.
THANK YOU SENATOR COM AUGER
SITTER DRAWS SO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO-
VERY SIMPLY SAY THANK YOU I'M A
CO AUTHOR THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR STICKING
WITH THIS THANK YOU FOR WORKING
ON THIS- TAKING AMENDMENTS
MEETING WITH PEOPLE AND
PURSUING WHAT IS FAIR AND AN
HONEST WAY OF ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES- SO. SIMPLE AS THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
DRAWS SO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. FINGERBOARD IS. WE
DISCUSS THIS ISSUE IT AT GREAT
LENGTH IN JUDICIARY. AND I
MAYBE I CAN POSE A QUESTION
THROUGH THE CHAIR TO THE ALTAR
SET A RECORD FOR YOU TO
QUESTION. PLEASE PROCEED MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
EARLIER ITERATION OF THIS BILL.
AT THE COMMISSION I WOULD
ADVISE THAT THE POSTER TO
CATION BOARD BUT THAT WOULD BE
A BIT OF AN THIS MISNOMER THAT.
THIS ADVISORY BOARD RENDERS A
DECISION AND THEN ONLY HOST
WITH OVERWHELMINGLY DISAPPROVE
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD BE FORCED
TO FOLLOW AND EXECUTE THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE
COMMISSION IS THAT IS THAT AN
ACCURATE VERY VERY IN AFTER THE
GAME PLEASE I'LL FORWARD IS
JUST THAT AN ADVISORY BOARD
POLL STILLHAS FINAL SAY ON
WHETHER OFFICER SHOULD BE
SUSPENDED. OR DECERTIFY. BUT I
THINK I WANT TO HONE IN ON THAT
POINT IF I MAY. THROUGH THE
CHAIRS. MY UNDERSTANDING SO IT
IS IT AN INCORRECT
UNDERSTANDING. THAT THIS
ADVISORY BOARD ISSUES A
RECOMMENDATION. AND THEN THE
POST CERTIFICATION BOARD CAN
AGREE DISAGREE OR DISREGARD.
THAT IS CORRECT ARE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE THE RECOMMENDATION
SO YOU KNOW PRESUMPTION OR AN
INCREASED BURDEN OF PROOF USED
BY THE POST BOARD TO OVERRULE.
THE DIRECTION OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD ADVISORY BOARD AGAIN IT'S
JUST THAT ADVISORY THE POST IS
NOT HAVE TO ACT ON ANYTHING
THAT DIVIDES REPORTS SUGGEST.
FORGIVE ME ONCE ONE LAST TIME.
IS THE BURDEN OF PROOF
DIFFERENT. MEANING THIS POST
HAVE TO OVER RULE. OR RENDER A
DECISION THAT THE ADVISORY
BOARD'S DECISION WAS WRONGLY
MADE IN ORDER FOR THEM. TO TO
REACH A DIFFERENT CONCLUSION
AGAIN THE ADVISORY BOARD IS NOT
REACHING A CONCLUSION EIGHT
FIVE FIVE REPORTERS ONLY MAKING
A SUGGESTION. THANK YOU THINK
CENTRE BOARD JUST MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
BRADFORD PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS WHO SPOKE IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS MEASURE THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE A FOLKS. WE'VE
LIVED IN THIS COUNTRY FAR TOO
LONG AND WE ALL KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE NEED OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THIS BILL IS JUST
THAT A PATROL LAW ENFORCEMENT
BILL BUT IT'S TO PROTECT THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WE ALL KNOW
PERSONALLY I HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO ARE POLICE OFFICERS
AND THEY'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I HAVE CHILDHOOD
FRIEND WHO SPENT THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. ON LAPD AND THEY'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THEM TO READ
THE BAD APPLES THAT WE KNOW
EXIST BAD APPLES THAT WE KNOW
EXIST IN EVERY PROFESSION.
REGARDS TO THE WALK OF LIFE
THAT WE LIVE IN WHERE WE LIVE
THERE ARE BAD PEOPLE. AND JUST
BECAUSE YOU PUT ON A UNIFORM
AND A BADGE DOESN'T. ABSOLVE
YOU OR MAKE YOU IMMUNE TO BEING
A BAD PERSON AND THAT'S THE
REALITY THAT WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY. THAT THERE ARE
OVER TWO HUNDRED PROFESSIONS
PROFESSIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT YOU CAN LOSE YOUR LICENSE
OR BE DECERTIFIED. BECAUSE OF
BAD OR ILLEGAL ACTS WE'RE JUST
ADDING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO THAT
CATEGORY OF BEING ABLE TO JOIN
THE FORTY SIX OTHER STATES WHO
FEEL. JUDGED AND AFTER. A
THOROUGH REVIEW OF ACTIONS.
POLLINI INVESTIGATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEONE
SHOULD BE DECERTIFIED WE HAVE
FAR TOO MANY EXAMPLES HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THIS NATION THEY CLEARLY
WARRANTS THIS MEASURE TO BE
PASSED INTO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD WHO TALKED ABOUT
SPLIT SECTION SECOND. DECISIONS
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT MAKE IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY ALWAYS GET IT
RIGHT WHEN THEY'RE WHITE
COMMUNITIES BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO BLACK AND BROWN ON ARMED
PEOPLE WITH CELL PHONES IN
THEIR HANDS THEY WIND UP DEAD.
BUT WHEN THEY FACE AND FACE
ANGRY WHITE MOBS THEY ALL GO
HOME SAFE SO THIS IS NOT ABOUT
TRAINING THIS IS ABOUT SOME
BIASES THAT CLEARLY EXISTS
BIASES THAT CLEARLY EXISTED IN
THOSE. THIRTEEN OFFICERS IN
TORRENTS OR WALKED OFF THE
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE OF RACES
HORRIBLE TREATMENT TO CITIZENS
THESE INDIVIDUALS DO NOT
DESERVE. A UNIFORM THEY DON'T
DESERVE THE BACK AND THEY DON'T
DESERVE OUR TRUST AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ESTABLISH
TRUST IN THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
WE ALL WANT. A SAFE COMMUNITY
WE ALL WANT GOOD COPS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THIS ALLOWS
US TO BE. A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMFORTABLE AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE A FIGURE IT IS
SEVEN STEPS THAT HAVE TO BE
MET. BEFORE OFFICER AGAIN CAN
BE THE CERTIFIED OR HAVE THEIR
CERTIFICATE SUSPENDED. AND IT
IS FAIR AS YOU CAN EVER WISH IT
TO BE THE CONTINUE TO THINK
JUST BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN A
VICTIM OF POLICE BRUTALITY. OR
OR SOME KIND OF JUSTICE THAT
YOU CAN'T BE FEARED THAT YOU
CAN'T BE UNBIASED. TRUST US
JUST LIKE YOU **** THE TRUST
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT- AGAIN MOST
PEOPLE DO NOT HATE COPS THEY
FEAR COPS THE PIER COP BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF TRUST. THIS BILL
HELPS US ESTABLISH THAT TRUST
THAT'S LONG OVERDUE. AND THE
SCENE ONE APPLE CAN SPOIL THE
WHOLE BUNCH WILL AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ONE OUT THE BAD
APPLES CAN SPOIL THE WHOLE
BUNCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLAH HI
ARCHULETA. AT KINS I FACE NO
BACKER HI FORGES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE  HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY.
DOT FIVE TORONTO I EDMUND
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE FIVE
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
THE MON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S
NO MEN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
TROUBLED NO PAM. I WAS IN
DENIAL HI RON HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL. NOW.
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA DALLY NO. EGGMAN
STERN. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS NOW
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL BE
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
TAKING UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AT THIS TIME. ENCINO AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL. 576-168-2623.
FIFTY NINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE THREE NINETY
ONE SIX TWENTY EIGHT SIX FIFTY
THREE SEVEN FORTY NINE SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT FIFTEEN
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT NINE
TWENTY SEVEN NINE TWENTY EIGHT
TEN OH THREE TEN THIRTY SIX
ELEVEN TEN ELEVEN ELEVEN ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE FORTY THREE
TWELVE SIXTY ONE TWELVE NINETY
FOUR THIRTEEN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND THIRTEEN
NINETY. THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FALL ITEM TWO HUNDRED.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BATES FIVE BECKER HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ V. I. DALLY I DONT. HI
TORONTO I EXAMINE USER I.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE I HURTS
BURKE I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
HI LLEVA HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN. I WOULD SHOW THE. HI
PAM I FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN
I'M BERG RIGHT HI CASKEY FIVE
WINNER. I WILL LOOK. HI. SHARE
ALL EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO ON FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED
OZ THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
BALANCE OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR ALLEN BY ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY MEMBER REAVIS SOONER
ALLEN IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT ELEVEN BY A FAMILY
MEMBER LOSE THREE OF US AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
CENTER OUR- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT PERHAPS THE ONLY.
METHOD OF METRO BOARD OF
DIRECTORS RECENTLY GOT THE
TWENTY FEET BY TWENTY EIGHT
INITIATIVE INITIATIVE SEEKS TO
ACCELERATE. A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS TO MEET THE
TRANSPORTATION DEMANDS OF THE
LOS ANGELES TWENTY TWENTY
OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC GAMES.
TO ENSURE EFFICIENCY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION THESE PROJECTS
REALLY MATTER WAS AUTHORIZED TO
UTILIZE DESIGN BUILD AS A
METHOD OF PROCUREMENT.
UTILIZING DESIGN BUILD CAN
REDUCE THE OVERALL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROJECT AN
EXPEDITED PROJECT DELIVERY.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE LA- METRO
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MUST APPROVE
BY A TWO THIRDS VOTE. EACH TIME
LA METRO DEEMS IT APPROPRIATE
TO USE DESIGN BUILD FOR PROJECT
CONSTRUCTION THIS REQUIREMENT
WHICH NO OTHER TRANSIT AGENCY
THE STATE MUST ABIDE BY.
INHIBITS LA METRO'S ABILITY TO
STAY ON TRACK FOR DELIVERING
KEY INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
A TIMELY EFFICIENT MANNER THIS
IS SUPPORTED BY BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
FALL ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT. C.
NINE MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
YOU KNOW THROW CALL ON THIS
MEASURE. HEARING SEEN ON AUGUST
THIRTY EIGHT. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO. FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY NINE. SPY CENTER TODD-
ON BEHALF OF. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE SHE'S READY MAN'S
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SIXTY BY FAMILY
MEMBERS DOWN AN ACTIVE RELATING
TO GUARDIANSHIP. SENATOR TIED
UP THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AB
TWO SIXTY ESTABLISHES A PROCESS
TO TRIBUTES FOR NEGLECTED HER
CHILDREN ARE NOT IMPROPERLY
DIVERTED INTO PROBATE
GUARDIANSHIPS IN LIEU OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES IN THE LEGISLATURE
LET LEGISLATURE I ASK FOR. AND
I VOTE. THE RAIN ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS I
DON'T. HEARING SEEING NONE MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS.
FIVE EIGHTHS HI PARKER. HI FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD. I HAVE A I
PROTESTING HI DOLLY. DOT FIVE
DRAW SO I ADMIN LASER ARE YOU
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE. I
PURCHASED BERG I WAS SO HI HER
TADO FIVE JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LABOUR HI THE MOON
HI MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON I- TELEVOTE HI
PAM I FOURTEEN TINA. I ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I'M
BURKE HI HI MY CASTING I
CLEANER I WILL. I I'M SECTOR
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS
DALLY. EGGMAN STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY CENTER TITLE
STILL UP THE BACK THIS IS ITEM
AT A. B. EIGHT TO NINE BITES
THE CINNAMON LIVER LEVIN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER CHILDREN
CENTER TODDLE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT BACK WITH A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINE WHICH SUPPORTS
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE BY ENSURING THEY RECEIVE
THE IMMIGRATION RELIEF AND
REPRESENTATION THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO UNDER THE LAW. AND
IT ELIMINATES IT THIS BILL
ELIMINATES THE SUNSET ALLOWING
OUT OF STATE NONPROFITS TO ACT
AS GUARDIANS OF THE MINORS IN
CONNECTION WITH SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT JUVENILE STATUS.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION AND IT
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOAT. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. HEARING SEEN ON MOUNT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN RIGHT HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE. BACKER FIVE FIVE
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM HYPERTENSIVE HI DOLLY.
GOD HI THERE ALSO HI. BLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I DROVE. HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
PLAY A- I THE MOMENT I WIRE. I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF VOGUE HI
PAM I FOURTEEN TINA. I ROTH I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG I LIKE CASKEY I WINNER I
WELL I. PICTURED PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. BATES I
VALLEY. EGGMAN MELINDA'S STERN.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FALL I DON'T
EIGHTY ONE. THAT SPY CENTER- I
SIMPLY MEMBER BENNETT AND BEING
PRESENTED BY SENATOR LEMONT
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BENNETT AN ACT RELATING TO OIL
AND GAS WELLS. CIRCLE MON
FLOORS OR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA HAS OVER
FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR IDLE WELLS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN. PAID TO IDLE FEES AND
ARE NOT IN THE IDLE MANAGEMENT
PLAN RESULTING IN OVER SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION- TO THE STATE
OVER 20% OF THESE IDOLS ARE IN
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTY. EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY SIX
WOULD PROVIDE A PROACTIVE TOOL
FOR CAL JAM SO THAT THEY CAN
IMPROVE FORSMAN EFFORTS AGAINST
NON COMPLIANT WELL OPERATORS.
AFTER RECEIVING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM CAL JAM THE
AUTHOR AMENDED THE BILL OFF THE
SUSPENSE FAIL TO EXPAND CALKINS
EXISTING TAX PLAN AT THE READY
INSTEAD OF PROVIDING THEM WITH
NEW PROPERTY LENA THIRTY THIS
BILL SIMPLY SEEKS TO PROVIDE
THE STATE WITH ANOTHER
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM AGAINST
BAD ACTORS SO THAT WE CAN
PREVENT ORPHAN WELLS AND- HAVE
A WAY TO RECUPERATE COST. IF
ALL WELL IF A WELL IS OUR
FRIEND RECENT FOR AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND
ADDRESS CAPTURING ISSUES THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. HERE IN ENCINO MA'AM
SO PLEAS THE ROLL ON. ME TO
WANT. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BASE. BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DOG. I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN GLASER
ALRIGHT CONSOLIDATES I DROVE.
HERZ BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN WALKER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON. I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO THE TROUBLE
HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO I RALPH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
HI HI MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. NO ZURCHER PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. EIGHT NO
PORGES. EGGMAN GROVE NO
MELINDA'S NO STERN. PRICE
THIRTY NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES NON MEMBERS LET'S MOVE
ON TO FALL ITEM EIGHTY TWO
SENATOR GONZALES PREPARED IT'S
FALLEN AB THREE OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND ACTS
RELATED TO RELATING TO
CONTAMINATED SITES CENTERED IN
THE HOUSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AT THREE OH FOUR ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
WHICH WILL PROVIDE STATE
OVERSIGHT AND SET REQUIREMENTS
FOR LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS. WHO
OVERSEE THE CLEANUP OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES- THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND E. T. S.
C. HAVE EXTENSIVE PROCEDURES
THE METHOD HERE TOO WHEN
CONDUCTING OR OVERSEEING A
HAZARDOUS WASTE CLEANUP THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS DO NOT
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE SAME
STANDARDS FOR AB THREE OH FOUR
SETS REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS TO
OVERSEE THE CLEANUP OF THE KID
CONTAMINATED SITES HAVE THE
NECESSARY EXPERTISE KNOWLEDGE
AND RESOURCES TO CARRY OUT
REMEDIATION RESPONSIBILITIES
THE BILL WILL ENSURE THAT EACH
SIDE IS CLEANED UP IN A MANNER
THAT IS TRANSPARENT AND
PROTECTIVE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT.MAYBE THREE OR
FOUR HAS NO OPPOSITION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANY FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF THE-
CURRENCY NINE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WITH ALAN.
I ARCHULETA I ADKINS HI BABES I
BECKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A I PROTESTING HI DALLY.
DOT FIVE TORONTO I EKMAN GLASER
ALRIGHT CONSOLIDATES HI GROSS.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HYPER TADA
HI JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I PLAY BASS HI THE MON
HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN. THE TROUBLE
I TEN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA HI
ROTH I RUBIO I SCANNER. FIVE
STERN I'M BURKE HI LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER I WILL. I. ZURCHER
POLICE CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS.
PORCHES I DALLY NO. ADMIN GROVE.
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN I STERN.
MELINDA'S NOW. GROVE NO. MARCH
THIRTY FIVE MILLS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
PREPARED- SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORIO AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING THE URGE
FOR. THINGS PRESENT THE ARRAY
OF POLICY CHANGES IN LAWS
DEALING WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS SOMEWHAT COMPLEX AND
DIFFICULT ONE OF THOSE HAS TO
DO WITH THE AFFORDABILITY SET
ASIDES AND DURATION OF THOSE
SET ASIDES. AND TO HELP CORRECT
THOSE AND TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THIS
MEASURE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CORREO- ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO REQUIRE AN AFFORDABILITY
PERIOD LONGER THAN FIFTY FIVE
YEARS. UNIZIK QUALIFY FOR
DENSITY BONUS ASPIRIN I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. TURN SEEN ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FIRE TO EIGHTY THREE. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE.
BACKER I FORGES NO BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM I PROTESTING HI
DOLLY. DOT I THE RUSSELL HI
EGGMAN LASER AIKENS OLIVES I
GROW NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI
HER TADO I JONES. NOPE CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOR I THE
MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO
TROUBLE NO PAM. I FOURTEEN TINA
I. ROSS FIVE RUBIO ALL RIGHTS
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL KNOW.
IN COURT PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. BATES NO DALLY NO.
EGGMAN STERN. I H. TWENTY NINE
MILLS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RE ASSEMBLY
BILL FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATED TO TRAFFIC SAFETY.
SYNERGEN DOLLARS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AT FORTY THREE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AB FORTY THREE MAKES
MODEST CHANGES TO THE WAY OUR
SPEED LIMITS ARE SET BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
ZERO TRAFFIC FATALITIES TASK
FORCE HEADED BY CAL STAR.
INCOMPLETE COMPRISED OF CITIES
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESEARCHERS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ALONE OVER THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR
LIVES IN TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS
INCLUDING THE DEATHS OF OVER A
THOUSAND PEDESTRIANS SPEEDING
IS A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO THESE
TRAP TRAGIC FATALITIES WITH 31%
OF ALL TRAFFIC FATALITIES
INVOLVING SPEEDING. RESEARCH
FROM THE UC INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES SHOWS
THAT I'M FIVE MILE PER HOUR
REDUCTION IN SPEED LIMITS
RESULTS IN AN 82515% REDUCTION
IN INJURIES FOR ALL ROAD USERS
AND ABOUT 8290% FEWER
PEDESTRIAN FATALITIES. AB FORTY
THREE WILL ALSO ALLOW CITIES TO
MAINTAIN EXISTING SPEED LIMITS
COMBATING SPEED CREEP THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK CAN I
VOTE THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. HERE IN SAINT. LOUIS
AFTER OKAY SENATOR WHY COFFEE.
US PRESIDENT I'M I HAD A
QUESTION THERE WAS A CONCERN
ABOUT SOME AMBIGUITY IN THE
LANGUAGE IN THE IN THE TEXT
THAT MIGHT ALLOW A LOCAL
DISTRICT TO REDUCE THE SPEED
LIMIT BY FOURTEEN MILES PER
HOUR IF THEY SO CHOOSE I WOULD
WONDER IF I HAVE A QUESTION
THAT THE FLOOR. MANAGERS CAN-
GONZALES WOULD YOU TAKE YOUR
QUESTION YES. THE CHAIR GO
AHEAD. OUR COST CENTER ARE
CLOSELY I THERE'S SOME CONCERN
THAT SOME LANGUAGE IN THE THAT
THE BILL CREATED AMBIGUITY WERE
RATHER TENDING IT REDUCING THE
SPEED LIMIT BY FIVE MILES PER
HOUR THAT SAID JURISDICTIONS
COULD ACTUALLY DROP BY FOURTEEN
MILES PER HOUR AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT WAS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR. THROUGH THE- THROUGH
THE CHECK OUT THROUGH YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU- AND
I APPRECIATE THAT FOR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE. IT LOOKS LIKE- THE
OPPOSITION SAFER STREETS LA
CLAIMS THAT IT IS AMBIGUOUS AND
WOULD ALLOW- SPEEDS SPEED
LIMITS TO BE REDUCED BY FORTY
MILES PER HOUR. BUT FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND HERE AND WHAT SHE
WRITES IS THE ORGANIZATION THAT
IS RAISING THE ISSUE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED TO
LOWERING SPEED LIMITS AND IS
RAISING AN ISSUE WHERE NONE
EXISTS. YEP IS OFTEN SHARED
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
OPPOSITION WITH LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL WHICH GAVE AN
UNOFFICIAL OPINION THAT THE
AMENDMENT ACTUALLY ADDED. IN
THE CUTIE BY IMPLYINGTHAT BOTH
CALTRANS AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES
CAN LOWER SPEED LIMITS PROVIDED
FOR IN THIS BILL WHEN IS THE
ONLY GRANTS THAT POWER TO LOCAL
AUTHORITIES SO I THINK IT'S
JUST THE WAY IT HAD BEEN.
WRITTEN AND WHO EXACTLY I WOULD
BE APPLYING IT TOWARD. AS
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION SO THERE'S THE
RECORD IS CLEAR ON WHAT WHAT
THE INTENT IS OUR REGION IPHONE
ALSO. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HERE IN J. NINE
SENATOR CONSULTING WHICH OUGHT
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM. EIGHTY FIVE. ALAN
I ARCHULETA. ATKINS I FACE. HI
BECKER I PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE I HAVE- I PROTESTING I
DOLLY. NO DOG HI TORONTO I
EGGMAN GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
HIGH GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I WAS
SO. HER TADO HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER. LAYERED I LABOR HI THE
MOON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM I PERSON TINO. HI
ROSS I RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI. I
WINNER I WILL. HI SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS
ARCHULETA I. EGGMAN WESSEL. CAN
LONGER. MELINDA'S STERN. PRICE
THIRTY FIVE MILLS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON THE FOOT FOLLOWING
HIM EIGHTY SIX SENATOR BORDERS
EACH OTHER YES HE'S READY. OKAY
SENATOR JONES LET'S CHECK IT
OUT ALL RIGHT. HE'S READY MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AN ACT
RELATING TO CONSUMER WARRANTIES.
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE ON BEHALF OF A
SINGLE MEMBER FLOOR TO PRESENT
A B. TWELVE TWENTY ONE THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW CONSUMERS
CONSUMER WARRANTIES TO COVER A
CLASS OF PRODUCTS AS WELL AS
EXPLICITLY ALLOW THESE
CONTRACTS TO BE OFFERED MONTH
TO MONTH. FOR CONTINUED UNTIL
CANCELED SUBJECT TO DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS THE OTHER IS
TAKING AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE
GREATER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AS
WELL AS EXCLUDE VEHICLE SERVICE%
CONTRACTS FROM THESE PROVISIONS
A. B. TWELVE TWENTY ONE HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I APPRECIATE YOUR I
HAVE A- THIS. THE STAFF. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS I DON'T ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE SIGN. I DON'T. SEE NONE
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ON THIS ITEM. C.
NINE HOURS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
REMOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN. CENTER HER TADO
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
JOB TRAINING SEARCH OUT OF THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. A. B. TWELVE AND A-
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE PROMOTES
OR AN ONLINE TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES BY DOING TWO
THINGS FIRST IT ADDS THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO
THE INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS.
SECOND IT PROHIBITS RELEVANT
AGENCIES FROM DISCOURAGING EARN
AND LEARN OPPORTUNITIES. THESE
CHANGES ARE BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED IN THE
REPORT PREPARED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND STAKEHOLDERS. AND REQUESTED
BY THE LEGISLATURE A TIME WHEN
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED. THIS BILL
OULD HELP BRIDGE THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I WILL. THANK YOU ANY.
VADER DISCUSSION ON THIS I
DON'T IN ADDITION- DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION HERE AND SEEN ON.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
NATURAL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION WHICH WOULD USE IN
THE UNITED THROW CALL ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN. HEARING CENA
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT MILLS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. BELL
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY NINE GONZALO SHE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY ME
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CORREO AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
POLLUTION. SINNER ONZALEZ
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARDIO TO
PRESENT AB NINE SEVEN NINETY
FOUR THE CLIMATE JOBS IN EQUITY
ACT THE MEASURE WILL REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO MEET IMPORTANT
LABOR STANDARDS IN ORDER TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE CLEAN
VEHICLE INCENTIVE DOLLARS.
SEVEN CENTS TO DOLLARS TO
TRANSITION DIRTY DIESEL
VEHICLES TO LOW AND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THAT HAVE
BEEN A POWERFUL TOOL AND
ADVANCING OUR MISSION AND
VICIOUS CLIMATE GOALS HOWEVER
THE STATE DOLLARS SHOULD NOT GO
TO SUPPORT COMPANIES THAT USE
EXPLICATED BUSINESS PRACTICES
SUCH AS MISS CLASSIFYING
WORKERS AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. TO AVOID PROVIDING
THOSE WORKERS WITH THE BENEFITS
AND PROTECTIONS THAT THEY
DESERVE CURRENTLY APPROXIMATELY
65% OF PORT TRUCK DRIVERS IN
THE U. S. ARE MISCLASSIFIED
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FIVE WOULD
STIPULATE THAT THOSE PORT
TRUCKING COMPANIES A
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR CLEAN VEHICLE
INCENTIVE FUNDS WE MUST STOP
THIS IN ADVANCE THE BLUE GREEN
ALLIANCE TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUTURE WE HAVE. AS IN THE STATE
IS CLEANER AND MORE EQUITABLE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN BY
BOAT. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE AND SAYING ON MOUNT
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FOLLOWING A MEETING ON. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS FIVE
EIGHTHS NO BACKER. HI FOR JUST
NO BRADFORD I COME BY OTHER
HIGH COURTS HAS HE I DALLY NO
DODD. I TORONTO I A COMMON
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WENT SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO KAMMERER I LAYERED
HI LABOUR I THE MON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A TRUCK BOTH. NO PAN
I FORTINO I BROUGHT. HI RUBIO
I'D SKINNER I STERN NUMBER FIVE
BY CAL SKI I WINNER I WELL NOW.
ZURCHER PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. EGGMAN STERN HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT ME EYES TWENTY
NINE MILLS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS THEN WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE ITEMS. AS
AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERWAS SO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
WILL MODERNIZE AND IMPROVE
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA LIFELINE
PROGRAM. THE LIFELINE PROGRAM
PROVIDES FREE OR DISCOUNTED
PHONE SERVICE TO ABOUT ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ONLY ABOUT 40% OF ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLDS WERE ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM IN RECENT YEARS IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM CUSTOMERS MUST SELF
CERTIFY ON AN ANNUAL BASIS TO
CONSERVE FIRM THEY ARE STILL
ELIGIBLE. BABY SEVENTY FOUR
SIMPLY DIRECTS THE CPC TO ADOPT
UPDATES RULES WITHIN THEIR
EXISTING LIFELINE PROCEEDING TO
REVAMP THE OUTDATED RE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS BY
ALLOWING RENEWAL OVER THE PHONE
OR ONLINE THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
DIRECT THE CPC TO ADOPT CHANGES
WITH THE GOAL OF INCREASING
RENEWABLE RATES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
IT. CURRENCY NINE MEN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FALLING
NINETY. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I EIGHT FIVE BACKER I
FORTUS. BRADFORD I COVER YELLOW
I C. I. DALI I DONT. HI TORONTO
I A GUNMAN GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE.
HIGH GROWTH. I HURTS BERG I
LISTEN I HER TADO I JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA I THE
MOON HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S I
MEAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I GO TO
A VOTE. HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO I
ROTH I REVIEW I SKINNER. I TURN
ON BURKE. ALL RIGHT HI QUITE
HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL HI.
ZURCHER PLEASE CALL THE APPS TO
MEMBER. FORTUS EGGMAN STERN.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SINNERS NINETY ONE I'M
SORRYSENATOR SKINNER YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF SEVEN INCH TRUE. YEAH.
SEARCH OUT- OKAY MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE RIP. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD AN ACT RELATING TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. SENATOR FLOOR
GEORGE. THANK YOU- THAT I'M MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AT THIRTY
NINE CODIFIES THE CALIFORNIA
CHINA CLIMATE INSTITUTE TO
ACCELERATE CLIMATE ACTION
THROUGH COOPERATIVE EFFORTS
BETWEEN TWO LARGE ECONOMIC
POWERS CALIFORNIA CHINA
INSTITUTE COLLABORATES WITH
LEADING ACADEMIC AND
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES IN CHINA
AIRLINES CALIFORNIA TO ADVANCE
POLICY RESEARCH S. B. THIRTY
NINE ALLOWS CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE WAY TO
REVERSE THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
WITH THAT I'D ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I SAW THIS
BILL ACTUALLY TWICE I SAW NI Q.
AND IN- NOW ONE OF THE OTHER
COMMITTEE BUT ANYWAY WE HAD TO
THE GOVERNOR BROWN WAS THAT THE
TESTIMONY WE HAD A LEAK THE
DEBATE ABOUT. CLIMATE IN WHAT
CHINA DOES OR DOESN'T DO. WE
CAN AGREE OR WE CAN STUDY BUT
CHINA BASICALLY DOESN'T ABIDE
BY THE RULES WERE. WE'RE GOING
TO NOW BE IN PARTNERSHIP. WITH
CHINA THROUGH THE YOU SIS TO
TALK ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
THEY DON'T ABIDE BY THEIR
POLLUTING. WE'RE CHASING JOBS
OUT OF AMERICA AND OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. AND TRYING TO
COERCE THE CHINESE WHO USE
SLAVE LABOR. TO PRODUCE THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE NEED HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY AND IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THIS IS VERY BAD
PRECEDENCE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I'LL BE OPPOSING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG. MR PRESIDENT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS GLOBAL AND
EVERY ASPECT OF ITS NATURE. WE
AS HUMAN BEINGS TO ARTIFICIAL
LINES IN THE AIR AND WE CALLED
IN CITIES AND STATES AND
COUNTIES AND COUNTRIES. IF WE
ARE GOING TO BE SERIOUS ON THIS
ISSUE IT REQUIRES. THE
COOPERATION ON A GLOBAL LEVEL.
BUT ALL OF OUR PARTNERS OUR
FAMILIES OUR FRIENDS ARE
PERFECT. THEY'RE NOT BUT IT IS
ESSENTIAL WHERE THE TWO LARGEST
EMITTERS ON THE PLANET.
COOPERATE IN EVERY WAY THEY CAN.
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
IS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THIS
ISSUE AND CARES DEEPLY ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE. EVERY PLACE AND
EVERY TIME WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WE SHOULD TAKE IT.
AND WHILE THERE'S CHALLENGES
AMONG FRIENDS AND OFTEN
COMPETITION AMONG. FOLKS TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN FIND ANY
COOPERATION THIS IS THE RIGHT
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO AS WE
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE I ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE. Q.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER BOARDS WHICH- I
WOULD OFFER JUST ONE- ONE OF
CONCERN. IS THAT IN A THINK
TANK FORMAT LIKE THIS- THE
REPUBLIC OF CHINA WILL. BE ABLE
TO REPRESENT ITSELF IN ANY WAY
IT SEES FIT WHEREAS IN A
SANCTIONED. STATE DEPARTMENT
FORMAT THEY'RE MORE
CONSEQUENCES SO JUST PUT THAT
OUT THERE THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. HAS THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK IT
COULD BE HELPFUL. GIVING GIVING
THIS COUNTRY A FORUM IN A SENSE
OF LEGITIMACY ON THESE ISSUES
OUTSIDE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S PURVIEW. COULD
CREATE COULD CREATE SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES BETTER
BEEN EXPLOITED FOR THE LAST TEN
OR TWENTY YEARS WE HAVE ENOUGH
EXPERIENCE. THIS IS HOW. THIS
IS HOW THE COUNTRY OPERATES.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEING AND
SINNERS CAN WHICH ARE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SO I
WANT TO CLARIFY THIS IS A
RESEARCH INSTITUTE AS THE-
FORGET SENATOR FROM- SHERMAN
OAKS OR VALLEY POINTED OUT.
THAT- WITH THE BALANCE. OF FROM.
WE ALREADY HAVE RESEARCH
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND UNIVERSITIES
IN CHINA WE HAVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS STUDYING IN CHINA WE
HAVE CHINESE STUDENTS STUDYING
IN OUR UNIVERSITIES HERE IN
AMERICA BUT ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA THE WHAT THIS DOES
IS HELP US PROMOTE GOOD
RESEARCH FINANCED WHICH YOU
KNOW THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT MAY
NOT GET BEHIND MAY NOT PROMOTE
BUT IF THERE ARE NEW
DISCOVERIES NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AND OTHERS THAT EMERGE THAT
BENEFIT. NOT ONLY OUR STATE BUT
THE GLOBE THAN IT IS BENEFICIAL
AND- I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT IT IS THIS IS NOT A
GOVERNMENT SECURED AS MUCH AS
IT IS A RESEARCH INSTITUTE THAT
WOULD BE HOUSED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WITH
THE REGENTS- OVERSEEING AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM NINETY ONE. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT.
NO BACKER. I PORCHES BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I PROTESTING I.
DALI NO DOG. I THEY'RE AWESOME
HI ADNAN GLAZER FIVE
CONSOLIDATES. I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
NO JONES NO CAN LONGER I
WIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO- TROUBLE I
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBER.
HI MY CASTING I WINNER I WILL
KNOW. ZURCHER PLEASE CALL OUTS
A MEMBER. PORCHES EGGMAN STERN.
PRICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE CENTER THE MALL IN
THE- SHE SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT AT ONE TWO
THREE BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ
WHICH WOULD INCREASE THE
PERCENTAGE OF INCOME A WORKER
COULD RECEIVE WHILE USING THE
STATE'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM IS
ENTIRELY FUNDED BY WORKERS GET
THE BENEFITS AREN'T
REALISTICALLY ACCESSIBLE FOR
MANY LOW INCOME AND MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES WHO PAY INTO
THE PROGRAM CURRENTLY A WORKER
ONLY RECEIVED 6270% OF THEIR
INCOME WHILE ON LEAVE FOR UP TO
EIGHT WEEKS. THIS MEANS THAT A
FULL TIME MINIMUM WAGE WORKER
EARNING FOURTEEN DOLLARS PER
HOUR WOULD STILL ONLY RECEIVE
60% OF THEIR WAGES THE LOWEST
WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE FOR ANY
MINIMUM WAGE WORKER IN THE
COUNTRY. THIS WOULD ONLY
PROVIDE THEIR FAMILY ABOUT ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR DOLLARS PER MONTH. BARELY
COVERING THE AVERAGE RENT FOR A
ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT. PARENTS
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO PAY THE
BILLS THE CURRENT WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATES ARE
INSUFFICIENT AND DON'T PROVIDE
ENOUGH TO LIVE ON ESPECIALLY AT
A TIME WHEN A FAMILY IS
ACTUALLY FACING INCREASED
EXPENSES. FROM A NEWBORN OR
MEDICAL BILLS FOR SERIOUS
ILLNESS THIS HALLMARK PROGRAM
WAS CREATED TO AVOID FORCING
WORKERS TO CHOOSE BETWEEN BEING
PRESENT AT HOME TO CARE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES IN TIMES OF
NEED. AND WORKING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET EIGHTY ONE TWO THREE WOULD
REQUIRE. PAID FAMILY LEAVE IT'S
A IT WOULD BE INSURED PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IS A BENEFIT THAT
ALL WORKERS CAN ENJOY BY
INCREASING THE WAGE REPLACEMENT
RATE FOR ALL PAID FAMILY LEAVE
CLEANS. AND THE FIRST TWELVE
WEEKS FOR STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE CLAIM 290% FOR LOW
INCOME WORKERS. MAKING UNDER
70% OF THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE
WEEKLY WAGE AND IT'S 75% FOR
ALL OTHER WORKERS BY JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
ABC ONE TWO THREE HAS NOT
RECEIVED ANY VOTES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE SENATE AND WE
RESPECT THE ASPIRIN I'VE- THANK
YOU HE FOR THE- OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF GREAT HEARING
SHEENA MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FOLLOWING A NINETY
THREE. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT. BECKER I
FORGES BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
I PROTESTING I DOLLY. DOT FIVE
TORONTO I A GIVEN LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO I HER TADO I JONES. CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE ON THE
MOON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A SHOW A
BOOK I PAN HI PORTS AND TINA I
BROUGHT I REVIEW FIVE SKINNER.
I STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL HI. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS.
EIGHT GORGEOUS BALLY. EGGMAN
GROVE. JONES MELINDA'S STERN.
PRICE. THIRTY TWO THOUSAND ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FALL ITEM
NINETY FOUR SENATOR ALLEN HE'S
PREPARED MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. AT SOME LEVEL FORTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGAR CURRY AN
ACT RELATING TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
OF TICKET TO BE DEALING. CENTER
OUR THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THIS- BILL AN AXE A
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATORY
CONSUMER PROTECTION FRAMEWORK.
AUTHORIZING THE MANUFACTURE AND
SALE OF NON INTOXICATING HEMP
DERIVED PRODUCTS IN FOOD
BEVERAGE. DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS
FOR PET PRODUCTS AND COSMETICS.
ALSO THERE ARE HEMP CBD
PRODUCTS THAT ARE ON STORE
SHELVES THAT ARE UNREGULATED
UNTESTED. ARE THERE NO CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS IN CURRENT LAW
PROVIDING ASSURANCES THAT THESE
PRODUCTS ARE SAFE. AFTER THE
LAST THREE YEARS OR SO SOME
REGULAR CURRY'S WORKED VERY
HARD ON THIS PROPOSAL FOR YOU
TODAY IT'S A ROBUST CONSUMER
SAFETY FRAMEWORK THAT WILL BE
ENFORCED. BY THE COVER THE PART
OF THE CALIPHATE THAT'S THE
PRODUCT OF A HARD WON
COMPROMISE. REPRESENTING A VAST
IMPROVEMENT OVER CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATORY. STATUS QUO LET ME
JUST MENTION TWO THINGS. OFFERS
SOME STAKEHOLDERS- TO SATISFY
THIS LEGISLATION DOESN'T
IMMEDIATELY AUTHORIZE CANNABIS
LICENSEES TO ACCESS AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HELP SUPPLY
CHAIN. TO BE CLEAR THIS IS
SOMETHING THE AUTHOR SUPPORTS
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT A STEP
IN THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PREPARED TO TAKE AT THIS TIME.
BUT THE BILL DOES REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
TO PREPARE A REPORT. BY JULY OF
NEXT YEAR OUTLINING THE STEPS
NECESSARY TO ALLOW FOR THE
CORPORATION OF HEMP PRODUCTS.
INTO THE CANNABIS SUPPLY CHAIN.
SECONDLY I WANT TO MENTION IS
THE RESPONSE. RESPONDING TO
CONCERNS RAISED BY FARMERS.
SMALL AND LARGE YOU FELT THEY
WERE BEING LEFT OUT OF THE
BILL. AND WITH WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT THIS
BILL WAS RECENTLY AMENDED TO
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE AT A
FUTURE DATE TO PERMIT. THE SALE
OF INHALABLE PRINT HEMP
PRODUCTS IF IT SO CHOOSES. BUT
ONLY IF IT FITS IN ACTS OF TAX
ON THE PRODUCTS THEMSELVES-
IT'S IN IT'S INACCURATE TO
ARGUE THE SALE OF INHALABLE
TEMP PRODUCTS WOULD BE
PERMITTED TO CALIFORNIA WHERE
THAT ATTACKS WOULD BE ENACTED.
IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW. IT
JUST. IS IT IF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DO THAT LATER BUT THEY'D
HAVE TO PROACTIVELY DO IT. SO
ON BOTH OF THESE ISSUES MORE
DELIBERATION MORE HARD WORK
MORE ACTION BY THE
LEGISLATURE'S YET TO COME- BUT
AFTER THREE YEARS OF DISCUSSION
DOZENS OF HOURS OF MEETING IN
MUCH PUBLIC DEBATE I HAD A BILL
ON THIS TOPIC TOO. THIS MUCH IS
CLEAR BY BY PASSING THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA WILL REPLACE ALMOST
ENTIRELY UNREGULATED. MARKET
PLACE WITH A FRAMEWORK THAT
INCLUDES ROBUST TESTING
LABELING ADVERTISING
REGISTRATION RECORDKEEPING
REQUIREMENTS. COUPLED WITH
CONTENT RESTRICTIONS ABROAD AT
THE READY FOR IT DPH. TO ENSURE
THAT ANY HEMP PRODUCTS ON THE
MARKET PLACE DON'T CAUSE AN
INTOXICATING EFFECT. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS A BIG AND
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR MYSELF. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. TODAY
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF. HEARING SEEING AND MENTORED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE.
BECKER I FORGES BRADFORD I KERR
BY ADAM HI CORTEZ V. I. DALI.
DODD ARE YOU THERE ALSO I HAD
BEEN. LASER I CONSOLIDATE HI
GROSS. HERTZBERG HI WESTERN I
HER TADO. HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE
MOON. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TROUBLE
HI PAM FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL
HI. M. SECTOR PLEASE CALL THAT
SOME MEMBERS. FAITH GORGEOUS.
DALLY EGGMAN GROVE. MELINDA'S
PAM. STERN AMBERG. BY TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TO. ON THE URGENCY
HIGHS TWENTY NINE KNOWS TOO ON
THE MEASURE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE. TO
MEASURE BEING PRESENTED BY
SENATOR WIENER HE'S PREPARED
FROM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL I MEAN I'M SORRY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AN
ACT RELATING TO YOUTH. CENTER
WINNER I THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF%
SOMEBODY MEMBER REVISTA PRESENT
AT FORTY SEX FIRST OFFICER
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
COMMISSION TIME AND AGAIN USE
HAVE SHOWN US THAT THEY'RE
READY AND EAGER TO BECOME
ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS IN OUR
DEMOCRACY. LAST YEAR WE SAW A
RECORD SHATTERING YOUTH VOTER
TURNOUT OF OVER 70% A CLEAR
SIGN THAT OUR USER USING THE
POWER OF THEIR VOICE. YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AT
LOCAL LEVELS AMBIENCE I
CURRENTLY THERE ARE MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY LOCAL
YOUTH COMMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. HOWEVER
WHILE THERE ARE MORE TO MISS
ADVISING THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
THERE'S NO COMMISSION FOCUSED
ON THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF YOU
AND WE KNOW THAT- USING
CALIFORNIA HAVE VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT- KNEES ON SO MANY
OF THE ISSUES- THAT WE DEBATE
IN THIS CHAMBER- THE IMPACT
USE. MANY TIMES MORE THAN
ANYONE ELSE. THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT COMMISSION I
WILL ADDRESS THE YOUTH OF THE
LACK OF YOUTH REPRESENTATION
STATE POLICY MAKING. BY
BRINGING THE OTHER THIRTEEN
PEOPLE. FROM ACROSS THE STATE
BETWEEN THE AGES OF FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY FIVE TO ENSURE THE
REPRESENTATION OF TRADITIONALLY
UNDERSERVED YOUTH. AT LEAST
HALF OF THEM WILL HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS- FOR
FOSTER CARE JUVENILE
INCARCERATION OR WILL
EXPERIENCE A DISABILITY. THE
COMMISSION'S DUTIES WILL
INCLUDE EXAMINING POLICY
HOLDING MEETINGS OF YOUR
CONFIDENCE IN THE PUBLIC AND
INVESTING IN CRITICAL YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. MAYBE
FORTY SIX ONE POWER UNDER
REPRESENTED YOUTH BY PROVIDING
THEM WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
CIVICALLY ENGAGED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU IN FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF THE
RIGHT. HEARING YOU SING ON
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUR
OWN FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE. ALAN
I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE.
BACKER I PORCHES BRADFORD I
KERR BY OTHER I PROTESTING I
DOLLY. DODD FIVE TORONTO I
EGGMAN BLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI FURTADO I JONES NOPE
CAMCORDER I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MON FIVE MCCOY- I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO
CONTROL BOTH HI PAM. HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH I REVIEW I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG ALL
RIGHT I CAN SKI I WINNER I WILL.
MS OUR THIRD PLEASE CALL AFTER
MEMBERS. FAITH PORGES. DALLY
EGGMAN GROVE NO STERN WELL.
PRICE THIRTY NOTES FOR THE
MERGER PROCESS THE MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN SENATOR SKINNER ARE YOU
PREPARED SHE IS BOUND SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AN ACT RELATING
TO MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. CLEANER
SCANNER. THANK YOU- MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB THREE
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD INCREASE
ACCESS TO FREE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS IN SCHOOLS GRADES SIX
THROUGH TWELVE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAMPUSES AND
CSU CAMPUSES IT ALSO ENCOURAGES
UC SYSTEM TO ADOPT A SIMILAR
POLICY FOR EVERY. CAMPUS ACCESS
TO FREE MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS IS A
VITAL FOR ENSURING THE HEALTH
THE DIGNITY AND THE FULL
PARTICIPATION OF ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR SOCIAL
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HERE IN C. NINE MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN. HEARING CENA AND AJ
THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON A FALL ITEM
NINETY EIGHT SENATOR ALLEN HE
IS READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS IN ORDER OUR- MISTER
PRESIDENT YOU THIS BILL
REQUIRES ANY ENTITIES ARE
CONTRACTING. WITH THE STATE TO
CERTIFY THEY'RE NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION- THE DESTRUCTION
DEGRADATION OF TROPICAL
FORESTED INDUSTRIAL SCALE OUT
EXPLOITATION RESPONSIBLE FOR A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS. EMISSIONS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
AND HAVE A WIDE RANGING IMPACTS
ON BIODIVERSITY HUMAN RIGHTS AS
WELL- SO BY ADOPTING THIS
PROCUREMENT POLICY WE'RE
ENSURING THAT THE STATE IS NOT
IN IN VERDANT CONTRIBUTOR TO
THE DESTRUCTION DEGRADATION OF.
THESE VERY VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US AND JOINED IN BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IS BACKED BY A
COALITION. OF ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY EXPERTS WILDLIFE
ADVOCATES BUT ALSO COMMERCIAL
BUSINESS INVESTORS. AND I
RESPECT FASHIONABLE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
FOUR SIXTEEN AT THAT WOULD
ECONOMICALLY HARM WORKING
PEOPLE COMMUNITIES AND
BUSINESSES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
FOREST PRODUCTS INDUSTRY IT
WOULD PUT GOOD FAMILY WAGE AND
UNIONIZED JOBS IN CALIFORNIA AT
RISK. THE FOREST PRODUCTS
INDUSTRY NATIONAL LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE HAS
OUTLINED THEIR SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL THE
COMMITTEE OF THE NONPROFIT
TRUST FORMED TO PURSUE THE
COMMON PUBLIC POLICY INTERESTS
OF MEN AND WOMEN IN THE FOREST
PRODUCTS INDUSTRY THE COMMITTEE
REPRESENTS MORE THAN TWO
MILLION WORKERS ACROSS THE
NATION. INCLUDING LUMBER
SAWMILL WORKERS WOULD WORKERS
MACHINISTS CARPENTERS AND PULP
AND PAPER WORKERS THEY POINT
OUT THAT THIS BILL GOES WELL
BEYOND AFFECTING TROPICAL
FORESTS WITHOUT CHANGES THAT
WILL FFECT PRODUCTS FROM OUR
TRADING PARTNERS CANADA. BATTED
REPORTING BURDEN WILL AFFECT
MULTIPLE INDUSTRIES WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA
BORDERS WHICH ARE FAR FROM
TROPICAL CLIMATE ZONES AS
AMENDED THE LANGUAGE IS SO
BROAD IT MAY EVEN INCLUDE
PRODUCTS WITH RECOVERED FIBRE
POTENTIALLY AFFECTING EFFORTS
IN CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE THE
USE OF RECYCLED CONTENT IN
PAPER PRODUCTS. LUMBER COSTS
HAVE RISEN SIGNIFICANTLY WHICH
AS WE KNOW IS WORSENING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THE US
SIXTY IS EXPERIENCING A
SHORTAGE OF LUMBER THIS BILL
WILL ONLY MAKE THE SITUATION
WORSE WE ALL WANT TO PROTECT
TROPICAL FORESTS. BUT THIS BILL
IS NOT THE. SOLUTION MY
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF THE VERY.
EARNINGS SEEN ON CENTRE ISLAND
WHICH ARE CLOSE. SENATOR ALAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'M
JUST CLARIFYING MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER PRESIDENT- THE ISSUE
ABOUT INVOLVING THE CANADIANS I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY- THAT IT
WAS INTERESTING THEY- THEY THEY
STRUCK A DEAL AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND IF ANYBODY
HAS ANY INFORMATION TO
CONTRIBUTIONS- TELLS ME THAT
THEY DID THEY STRUCK A DEAL ON
THE BORDER FORCE ISSUE THE
CANADIANS THE CANADIAN STOP
THEIR CONCERNS. AND MIKE IT'S
MY INTEREST MY UNDERSTANDING AS
WELL THE SAME THING HAPPENED
WITH THE CANNABIS ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED BY OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY SO- YOU KNOW
I'M NOT THE AUTHOR I'M NOT AS
INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH THE
BILLS. CERTAINLY SHE IS BUT- I
DO- IT DOES IT DOES APPEAR TO
ME THAT SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE- REFLECT AN EARLIER
VERSION OF THE BILL BEFORE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN- TO ADDRESS THE MANY
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY.
BY FOLKS IN OPPOSITION. SO WITH
THAT I RESPECT FAST TRAVEL.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FOLLOWING NINETY EIGHT. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA. HI ADKINS. FIVE
EIGHTHS NO BACKER HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD HI I CUT BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DOG. I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN GLAZER ICONS
ALL AS HI GROVE NO HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HER TADO FIVE JONES NO
CAMELOT- I LAYERED I LAVER I
THE MOON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO
TROUBLE NO PAN I. FOURTEEN TINA.
FIVE ROTH I RUBIO HI SKINNER. I
STERN I'M BURKE I LIKE HUSKY I
WINNER I WILL. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. EGGMAN
WEST SO I STERN WELL. ARE YOU
SH TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES NUMBER MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON THE FOLLOWING
I'M NINETY NINE SENATOR WIENER
HE'S PREPARED AND SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAM DEALER AND
ACTION RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER WINNER THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT EIGHTY THREE FORTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE
NUMBER ITEM YOU AROUND YOUR-
ARM THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP.
DOCTORS TREAT PATIENTS AS
UNIQUE INDIVIDUALS- BY
INCREASING DOCTORS ABILITY TO
QUICKLY PRESCRIBED MEDICATION-
THAT TELLER TO RESPECT A
PATIENT'S SPECIFIC NEEDS AND
BASED ON THE OPPOSITION'S BEST
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT WOULD BE
THREE FORTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES A
STANDARD- TRANSPARENT AND
TIMELY PROCESS FOR PHYSICIANS
TO EVALUATE. A PATIENT'S
CIRCUMSTANCES REQUEST INSURER
COVERAGE- FOR THE PROGRAMMATIC
CATION AND APPEAL INSURANCE
DECISIONS- IF A REQUEST IS
DENIED MORE THAN TWENTY STATES
HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
SIMILAR LAWS- AROUND SO CALLED
STEP THERAPY OR A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION- AND THROUGH THIS
BILL CALIFORNIA WOULD JOIN IN
THOSE STATES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU IN FURTHER
JUST OF ON THE SIDE OF ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION TODAY. HERE
AND SEEN ON. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM NINETY NINE. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I BAIT BY
BECKER HI PORCHES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE I. DALI I
DON. FIVE TORONTO I A COMMON
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROVE I
HEARD SMIRK I WOULD ASSUME. I
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I GO TO A
VOTE HI PAM I PERSON TINO. HI
RALPH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG ALL RIGHT HI MY
CASKEY FIVE WINNER I WILL HI-
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBER. ADMIN I AM LONGER.
STERN AUGUST THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
IT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM ONE
HUNDRED CENTER HERZBERG ARE YOU
PREPARED HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER HARDBACK
AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVACY.
SENATOR HURTS FOR. AS PRESIDENT
I'M SORRY. OKAY AS WE SPENT
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS
NEGOTIATING. THE ISSUES AROUND
PRIVACY. BOTH WITH RESPECT TO
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IN THE
SPEKTR PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR
IN THE THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF
COMMENTS THAT FOLKS HAVE MADE
ALL SIDES OF THE ISSUE. AT THE
CORE OF OUR DISCUSSION WAS. THE
CONSUMER'S RIGHT TO DELETE
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION OR
OPT OUT OF DATA COLLECTION MADE
A LOT OF SENSE. EXCEPT SOME
REMEMBER BURNER HARBATH HERE
FOUND THE LOOPHOLE THAT ALSO
MAKES SENSE AND THAT IS FOR
MARINE COMPANIES BUT COMPANIES
WHEN THEY HAVE A RECALL AND
THEY WANT TO PROVIDE CONSUMER
INFORMATION ABOUT SOME PRODUCTS
SAFETY THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM. AND SO
IN THAT REGARD THIS MEASURE
MAKES AN EXCEPTION WHICH MAKES
SENSE IT FITS THE FRAMEWORK OF.
PROP TWENTY FOUR DEALING WITH
CONSUMER PROTECTION ASPIRIN I
BOOK. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT HI TO RISE TO
SUPPORT AB THREE THIRTY FIVE IS
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR AND I'VE
BEEN PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
BILL SINCE IT WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED IT WILL PROVIDE BOTH
MANUFACTURES A LEGAL CERTAINTY
THEY NEED TO COLLECT AND RETAIN
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE OWNERS
OF THEIR PRODUCTS TO USE IT TO
PERFORM SAFETY RECALLS WHILE
BENEFITING THE CONSUMERS WHO
PURCHASED THE PRODUCT THERE IS
ALREADY NOTED THE BILL DOES
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE RECENTLY APPROVED PRIVACY
INITIATIVE IN THAT IT PREVENTS
THE USE OF THAT THIS DATA FOR
ANY OTHER PURPOSE INCLUDING-
MARKETING OR SALES PURPOSES THE
BILLS ABOUT CONSUMER
PROTECTION. SAFETY OF THE
VOTING PUBLIC AND I
RESPECTFULLY AND STRONGLY ASK
FOR YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NINE
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING.
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF FALLEN
ONE HUNDRED. HEARING SEEN NINE
OZ THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE I DON'T WANNA ONE
AND SENATOR LAWYER HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEAVE AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL RECORDS- LEARN THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION ABOUT A
PERSON'S CRIMINAL RECORD IS
ACCURATE WHEN PROBATION IS
TRANSFERRED THEIR SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES I ASKED FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY
DESCRIPTION INTERNATIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING IN SCENE NINE
MEMBERS THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR YOU KNOW ACTUAL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE I
DON'T WANT TO ONE. HEARING CENA
ALL EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NON MEMBERS
MOVING ON THE FOLLOWING MORNING
TO CENTER PORN TEEN ARE YOU
PREPARED. HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO DRIVER'S LICENSES-
PORN TUNER FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THAT THIS BILL
WE DEALT WITH EARLIER BUT THEY
WERE CHATTERING A MA'AM AND SO
HAD TO BRING IT BACK- THIS IS A
BILL TO EMPOWER- THE DMV TO WAY
BEHIND THE WHEEL TRAINING FOR
EXAMS FOR A PERSON WITH A
DRIVER'S LICENSE FROM A
FOREIGN. COUNTRY IF CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET- THERE ARE
OTHER STATES TEXAS
MASSACHUSETTS AND WASHINGTON
THAT HAVE SIMILAR AGREEMENTS-
AS I MENTIONED THE LAST TIME I
VISITED WITH THE- COUNTERPART
OF ARDEN MOTOR VEHICLES FOLKS
WHEN I WAS IN SEOUL KOREA A
COUPLE YEARS AGO TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THEIR STANDARDS WERE AS
RIGOROUS AS OURS AND THEY ARE.
AND I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
THIS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR BATES. I
MEAN SENATOR BREAUX I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION-
FROM CAUCUS I DEEPLY RESPECT
OUR CAUCUS AND- UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY DID THAT BUT SERVING
UNITED STATES MILITARY OVERSEAS
IN GERMANY- YOU GOT A
INTERNATIONAL DRIVER'S LICENSE
IF YOU CAME FROM CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE BEHIND THE WHEEL
TRAINING THE TESTING THAT YOU
TICK. AND THEY GAVE YOU AN
INTERNATIONAL DRIVER'S LICENSE-
I THINK THAT IF A FOREIGN
COUNTRY- WHETHER IT'S GERMANY
CREARE WHEREVER HAS THE SAME
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEIR PUBLIC
IS SAFE THAT WE SHOULD ACCEPT
THAT. N. LIMITED BEHIND WILL
TRAINING ESPECIALLY IF OTHER
COUNTRIES QUALIFY OR EXCEED THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT WE HAVE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
CHAIN NINE CENTER POINT TO KNOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
FROM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE I DON'T WANT TO.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
HATE. BACKER. FIVE FOR HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T HI
CORTEZ V. I. DALLY. GOD ARE YOU
THERE AWESOME I EGGMAN GLAZER
ARKANSAS AS I GROW HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LABOUR I THE MOON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A TRUCK BOTH HI PAM
HI PERSON TINA HI RALPH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. I STERN AMBER HI
QUITE HOW SKI I WINNER. I WELL
I. IN CENTER PLEASE CALL THAT
SOME MEMBERS. BABIES NO DALLY
NO. ADMIN STERN. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE THIRTY THREE NOS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE GONNA SKIP FILE ITEM ONE
OH THREE. AND WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE I DON'T WANT TO FOR.
SYNERGY BURGER YOU PREPARED FOR
FALLEN ONE FORTY IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
WHEN HEAR ME YEAH THANK YOU-
CALIFORNIA LAW CORPORATIONS
GENERALLY REQUIRES THAT ON
BOARDS OF DIRECTORS ARE ELECTED
ANNUALLY- THE IT WITH RESPECT
TO HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION THAT
REQUIRED EVERY YEAR- REGARDLESS
OF THE NUMBER OF HOMEOWNERS WHO
STEP UP TO SERVE. HOWEVER
MEMBERS- WHEN IS THE NUMBER OF
HOMEOWNERS STEPPING UP TO
SERVICE EQUAL TO OR LESS THAN A
NUMBER OF POSITIONS BEING
ELECTED. IS REALLY NO POINT IN
GOING THROUGH THE TIME EXPENSE
AND TROUBLE OF HOLDING
ELECTIONS. THE MEETING IS HELD
THIS IS NOT A VALID VOTING IS
DETERMINES THE OUTCOME IN THE
DIRECTORS SEEKING THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF VOTES WIN. REGARDLESS
IF THEY GET A MAJORITY. THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF THIS MEASURE I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF IT
ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING AND
SEEING NINE. MINUTE SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I'M
FOLLOWING FOR. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I BASE I BACKER.
PORCHES I BRADFORD I HAVE A HI
CORTEZ C. I. DALI I DON. HI
THERE ALSO HI AIKMAN GLAZER
ICONS ALL THIS HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I TANTO HI
JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MOON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S I MEN FIVE NEWMAN I
NELSON I TROUBLE HI PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. I RALPH I RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN- BERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL HI-
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. AFTER I. EGGMAN GROWTH
I STERN HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
MILLS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
NON MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX SENATORS
SCANNER PREPARED SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. CENTERS MANNER
THANKS MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT
A. B. FOUR FOUR SEVEN RESOLVES
THREE TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT
HAVE ARISEN WITH- IN
RELATIONSHIP TO OUR LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM IS THE PRIMARY METHOD
FOR FINANCING ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
OF AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA D. B. FOUR
FOUR SEVEN- FACILITATES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE UNITS BY
RESOLVING THOSE THREE TECHNICAL
ISSUES AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I DON'T. THINK YOU HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEING NONE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW STROKE
ALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION BY
MEMBERS USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ON FILE ITEM ONE ON SIX.
HERE IN C. NINE ICE THIRTY
EIGHT. KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON THE FOLLOWING ONE OF. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO SENATOR
ALLEN HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY MARY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORIO AN ACT
RELATING TO SOLID WASTE SOONER
OUR- PRESENT THIS PROBLEM
BEHALF OF FOR SOME RECOVERY OF
THIS BUILDS ON OUR EXISTING
EFFORTS TO COMBAT WASTE FROM
SINGLE USE ITEMS AND REDUCES
UNNECESSARY. COSTS FOR
BUSINESSES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
THE PANDA HAS INCREASED
RELIANCE ON TAKE OUT FOOD
DELIVERY CONSEQUENTLY THE USE
OF SINGLE USE FOOD ACCESSORIES
AS CONTRIBUTING APPROXIMATELY
2100523100% INCREASE IN SINGLE
USE PLASTICS. AND A 30%
INCREASE IN WAYS WHICH OF
COURSE IS NOW INCREASING.
CONSUMER COSTS AT THE CITY
LEVEL RATE COSTS FOR WASTE
MANAGEMENT IT'S AFTER. SO I
TODAY MANY FOOD FACILITIES AND
FOOD DELIVERY SERVICES PROVIDE
SINGLE USE FOOD WHERE BEVERAGE
ACCESSORIES REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE NEEDED.
MOST CONSUMERS DON'T WANT THEM
THEY ALREADY HAVE A REUSABLE
ITEMS AT THEIR HOME OR
WORKPLACE IS A YOU KNOW MOST
PEOPLE WOULD TAKE IN THERE.
THEY WANNA SUPPORT A LOCAL
BUSINESS ARE GONNA TAKE THEIR
FOOD HOME THEY'RE GONNA NEED
ALL THE GUYS PLAY CLUB CUTLERY
AND YET. THEY'RE PROVIDED WITH.
WITH THESE- ADDITIONAL PLASTIC
THIS PLASTIC WHERE THEY DON'T
NEED AND SO OFTEN IT'S JUST
BEING DISCARDED WITHOUT EVER
BEING USED SO. IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE PLASTIC STRAWS UPON
REQUEST LAW TO INCLUDE MORE-SINGLE USE FOOD WHERE
ACCESSORIES MORE FOOD
FACILITIES. AND THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY PLATFORMS INCLUDING
FOOD IS TAKEN AWAY DELIVERED OR
SERVED ON SITE. THIS BILL ALSO
PROVIDES FOOD FACILITIES MUCH
NEEDED FLEXIBILITY TO OFFER.
SINGLE USE FREEWARE ACCESSORIES
TO DRIVE THROUGH BECAUSE
CONSUMERS ONLY IT'S A WASTE
REDUCTION MEASURE REDUCES WASTE
UPSTREAM BEFORE IT'S CREATED.
EXPERTS AGREE THAT SOURCE
REDUCTION IS OF UNNECESSARY
SINGLE USE ITEMS IS BY FAR THE
MOST EFFICIENT COST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO PROTECT RESOURCES.
COMMUNITIES AND HELP CALIFORNIA
REDUCE WASTE. REDUCTION AND
CLIMATE GOALS. MEMBERS ARE THE
OTHER WORKED REALLY HARD TO GET
TO A PLACE. WHERE THERE IS
LITERALLY NOW NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. WHICH INITIALLY
CAME FORWARD THE BILL AS YOU
MIGHT IMAGINE THERE WAS
CONCERNS FROM INDUSTRY FOR
BUSINESS FROM RESTAURANTS. HE
WORKED REALLY HARD. TO KEEP.
INTEGRITY WITH THE BILL BUT
ALSO ENSURE THAT SHE
INCORPORATED- THE MANY BUSINESS
CONCERNS THAT WERE OUT THERE SO
THERE'S LITERALLY NOW NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION THIS BILL
AND I. REALLY HOPE YOU JOIN ME
IN SUPPORTING. THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT WILL HELP TO
REDUCE PLASTIC WASTE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE
HEARING CHAIN NINE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
HATE. BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD HI I HAVE A BETTER
LIFE FOR TESTING HI DOLLY NO
DOG. I TORONTO I EXAMINE LASER
I CONSOLIDATE I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I HEARD
SADDAM. HER DAUGHTER. JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MOON HI WIRE FIVE MELINDA'S.
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A
TURBO NO PAN I FORTUNE TINO. I
BROUGHT FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI WHAT
COUNTS SKI I WINNER I WILL KNOW.
INSERT PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. FAITH NO FOR JUST NOW.
EGGMAN TADA. HER TADO NO. STERN
THE. MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH KNOWS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FILE I
DON'T WANT TO EAT SENATOR
CAFIERO IS PREPARED TO PRESENT
THAT MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLLY
AND ACTS RELATING TO HOUSING
CENTER CARRIER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY 2% AB
TEN NINETY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLLY WHICH
CREATES PARITY IN STATE AND
LOCAL HOUSING PROGRAMS.
HOMEOWNERSHIP CONTRIBUTES TO
THE FINANCIAL SECURITY OF
FAMILIES AND STABILITY OF
COMMUNITIES BY OFFERING STABLE
HOUSING COSTS AND INCREASED
SAVINGS AND PURCHASING POWER
UNFORTUNATELY HOMEOWNERSHIP
LEVELS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE THEIR LOWEST
SINCE THE NINETEEN FORTIES.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLORS WHERE
OWNERSHIP RATES FALL FAR BELOW
THE STATE AVERAGE HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE OF FIFTY FOUR PERCENT. ONE
OF THE PRIMARY BARRIERS TO
INCREASING AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. IS THE LACK OF
AVAILABLE STATE AND LOCAL
FUNDING SOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP DEVELOPERS MANY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
SUCH AS HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
BUILD DEED RESTRICED HIGH
DENSITY INFILL PROJECTS CLOSE
TO TRANSIT BUT CONTINUE TO FACE
FUNDING BARRIERS BECAUSE
PROGRAM SELECTION CRITERIA.
OFTEN ONLY CONTEMPLATE RENTAL
HOUSING POLICIES. AB TEN NINETY
FIVE CREATES A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD FOR AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROJECTS BY
ALLOWING STATE HOUSING PROGRAMS
TO INCLUDE CRITERIA IN THEIR
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR BOTH
OWNERSHIP AND RENTAL
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE GUIDELINES
IT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
HOMEOWNERSHIP STRENGTHENS
COMMUNITIES. STATE AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF THE THESE DEVELOPMENTS
PROVIDE AND CREATE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD ALLOWING ALL
PROJECTS TO COMPETE EQUALLY FOR
NECESSARY FUNDING. AB TEN
NINETY FIVE HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HE FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HEARING CHAIN NINE
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE I
DON'T WANT TO EIGHT. HEARING
SEEN ON AUGUST THIRTY EIGHT.
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM ONE ELEVEN SENATOR CAFIERO
IS READY AGAIN MADAM SECRETARY
MARY. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL AN ACT RELATING TO
HOMELESSNESS SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TO PRESENT EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. THIS BILL WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY STRENGTHEN
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY FOR STATE FUNDED
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND WOULD
ALLOW POLICYMAKERS AND THE
PUBLIC TO BETTER TRACK AND
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS. OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND QUITE
FRANKLY MEMBERS THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE SPENDING ON THE PROGRAMS.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
REQUIRE STATE INDIAN ENTITIES
THAT ADMINISTER FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS SERVICES TO ENSURE
SERVICE PROVIDERS COLLECT AN
INTER PERTINENT DATA INTO THE
HOMELESS MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM. THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
NOT ONLY OUR TAXPAYERS DOLLARS
ACCOUNTED FOR BUT THIS THEY CAN
BETTER MEASURE OUTCOMES OF THE
SERVICES. THIS BUILD. BUILD
BUILD ON SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR AND IS SUPPORTED BY A
WIDE RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS SUCH
AS THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION COMMISSION ON AGING
AND THE CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
JUST TO NAME A FEW. THIS BILL
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE HOUSING AND HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND VERY
HEARING SEEN NINE MEMBERS THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ON
FOLLOWING A MORAL OVER. HEARING
CENA AND ICE THIRTY EIGHT MILLS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. BY
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM
ONE TWELVE. BY SIX INTERCOM
LOGGER YOU PREPARED. COM LOG ON
BEHALF OF TOM LONGER.
MANCHESTER PLEASE RE ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SIXTY TWO BY SOME
MEMBER BY SENATOR CAN LONGER
AND ACTUALLY INTO SOLID WASTE.
SINNER COME OVER THANK YOU. MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB NINE SIX
TWO WILL PAVE THE WAY FOR
REUSABLE BEVERAGE BOTTLES.
BOTTLE SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA BY
ALLOWING BOTTLES TO FLOW
THROUGH THE CAL RECYCLE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM. EIGHTY NINE SIX TWO
WILL LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR A
MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE BUSINESS
MODEL BY CREATING AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD FOR THE USE OF
REUSABLE BEVERAGE BOTTLES BY
BEVERAGE MANUFACTURERS. IT'S
ABOUT MAKING SURE THE REUSABLE
GLASS DOESN'T GET CRASHED INTO
ALLOW BOTTLES TO THROW THE WORK
FLOW THROUGH THE CAL RECYCLE
BOTTLE BILL. AND PROVIDE BOTTLE
WASHERS THE SAME PROCESSING
PAYMENT THAT IS CURRENTLY PAID
TO CERTIFIED RECYCLERS. AND THE
SAME QUALITY GLASS INCENTIVE
PAYMENT THAT IS CURRENTLY PAID
TO CERTIFIED RECYCLING
PROCESSORS THIS IS A STATUTORY
FIX WITH SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS RECENTLY
THE STATEWIDE COMMISSION ON
RECYCLING ISSUED A UNANIMOUS
SEVENTEEN TO ZERO
RECOMMENDATION TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. SAYING THAT THIS WOULD BE
A NECESSARY TOOL TO SUPPORT
THIS NEW AN ESSENTIAL WASTE
REDUCTION INFRASTRUCTURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
THE VERY. ON SCENE AND MEMBERS
THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING AN OUNCE
ROW COLUMN FOLLOWED HIM ON
TWELVE. C. NINE EYES THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES BELL MEMBERS REMOVAL IN
THE FALL I DON'T ONE THIRTEEN.
ONE THIRTEEN SENATOR THE MON
ARE YOU PREPARED SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT AND
AFTER RELATING TO FARM. SHIN
REMOVED THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
DURING THIS PANDEMIC FARM
WORKERS HAVE CONTINUE TO RISK
THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE HOME ORDERS 90% OF
OUR FARM WORKERS WERE BORN
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES
PUTTING THEM IN A- IN A
UNIQUELY VULNERABLE POSITION AS
THEY SEEK HELP AND ASSISTANCE.
RECOGNIZING THIS NEED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN GRASSROOTS FARMWORKER
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY CURATED
THE VENTURA COUNTY FARMWORKER
RESOURCE CENTER SINCE ITS
OPENING IN TWENTY NINETEEN IT
HAS SERVED OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED FARMWORKERS EIGHTY NINE
FOUR ONE ENCOURAGES OTHER
COUNTIES TO CREATE SIMILAR
CENTERS BY ESTABLISHING A GRANT
PROGRAM FOR THEM TO DO SO AND
IS IMPLEMENTING POLICY FOR THE
THREE MILLION. APPROPRIATED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FOR
FARMWORKER RESOURCE CENTER
GROUNDS RECENT FORM AND THEN
SIMPLY REMOVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS PORTION OF
THIS BILL THAT IS NOW PART OF
THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
ENJOYED STRONG BIPARTISAN.
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATEON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HERE IN CHINO THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CALL ITEM ONE THIRTEEN. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BASE.
BECKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A BETTER LIFE FOR TESTING
HI DALLY. DOT HI THERE ALSO I
HATE MEN LASER EYE CONSOLIDATES
HI GROSS. HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO. I JONES. CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED. I LLEVA I
THE MOON I ALL RIGHT WHERE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. HI I HAVE A SHOW
ALTHOUGH I CAN I FORTUNE TINO.
I BROUGHT I REVIEW. NUMBER ALL
RIGHT I CAN SKI HI WINNER FIVE
WELL I. M. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS. BASED.
PORCHES I DALLY. EGGMAN GROVE.
JONES MELINDA'S STERN. YEAH
MARCH THIRTY THREE KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES THE MEMBERS
REMOVE IT ON THE FILE ITEM ONE
FOURTEEN SENATOR WINTER
PREPARED. HE IS MAN SECRETARY
MARY. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
ACTUALLY DO HOUSING. CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES EIGHTY FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR IS THE ANNUAL
HOUSING OMNIBUS BILL MAKES A
SERIES OF TECHNICAL NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO OUR
STATE HOUSING LAWS WITHOUT THE
ON THE BUS WE WOULD NEED AT
LEAST TEN STANDALONE POLICY
BILLS TO MAKE THESE CHANGES.
ALL PROVISIONS AND NONE OF US
HAVE BEEN VETTED BY A DIVERSE
BIPARTISAN REVIEWER POOL AND
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES SO FAR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON FALL
ITEM ONE FOURTEEN. HERE IN ST
NINE MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE. HEARING SEEN NINE OZ
THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE I DON'T WANT FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE WE HAVE
SENATOR WHITE COUNTY PRESENTING
THAT ITEM HE'S PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION
CENTER OR COACH SMITH'S MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO- FOR HIS
EXTENDED INTO SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WOULD DOUBLE PETERSON
VARIOUS SUSPICIONS AND BUT
BEFORE POLICE ONLY HAVE
JURISDICTION TO ISSUE
PROHIBITION ORDERS ON PROPERTY
THAT BAR OWNS. IN IN IN THIS
CASE THE SANTA CLARA VTA ON
SEPT PROPERTY SO WHAT'S A
PROHIBITION ORDER IT'S
BASICALLY A STAY AWAY ORDER TEN
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S BEEN CITED
THREE TIMES WITHIN THE LAST
NINETY DAYS. N. OR BEEN
ARRESTED FOR VIOLENT CRIMES AT
THIS BASICALLY ALLOWS BAR
PLEASE THE ISSUE THOSE ORDERS
IN THESE TWO- SANTA. CLARA BART
STATIONS AVERAGE AND I WROTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION IS VERY ON THE SIDE
OF THE FURTHER DISCUSSION WITH
IT ON THIS OF. HERE AND SEEN ON
THIS IS IDEAL FOR YOU NATURAL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
FOLLOWED A ONE FIFTEEN. M. C.
NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS IT
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FOLLOW AND ONE
SIXTEEN. SIR WAY SO HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL OF FOURTEEN
OH THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVIN AN ACT RELATING TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES IN DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE OF STATE
BACKED MEDIA LINK THROUGH- SO
THANK YOU A. B. FOURTEEN OF
THREE AUTHORIZES A GOVERNOR TO
DECLARE STATE OF EMERGENCY OR A
LOCAL EMERGENCY. DUE TO A DE
ENERGIZE ATION EVENT PLANNING
CLUED IN THESE EVENTS WITHIN
THE DEFINITION OF CONDITIONS
THAT WARRANT A STATE OF
EMERGENCY DECLARATION
pDOUBLE JOINED WITH US B. FIFTY
TWO BY CENTER DOT WHICH WOULD
ACCOMPLISH THE SAME GOAL OF
THIS BILL- FOR LOCAL EMERGENCY
DECLARATION- SO UNDER CURRENT
LAW THE STATE THE CALIFORNIA
MERGES YOU SERVICES ACT.
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR TO
ISSUE A STATE OF EMERGENCY OF
CONDITIONS EXIST THAT THREATEN
THE PERSONAL SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS OF PROPERTY.
HOWEVER DEAR AT ENERGY STATION
EVENTS DO NOT FALL CLEARLY
WITHIN SPECIFIED. CAUSES
ADDITIONS OF SPECIFIED. UP DO
NOT FALL WITHIN CONDITIONS OF
DISASTER OR PERIL UNDER
EXISTING LAW. ADDING THE ENERGY
IS ATION AND P. S. P. S.
OFFENSIVE DEFINITION OF
CONDITIONS THAT WARRANT STATE
EMERGENCY DECLARATION. WILL
HELP THE STATE QUICKLY ADDRESS
HARMFUL IMPACT ON PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND PUBLIC SAFETY
CAUSED BY ONE OF THESE EVENTS
ARE RESPECT THAT FOR FIVE OF.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THIS
ITEM. ANY FURTHER DESCRIPTION
OF A HEARINGC. NINE MANCHESTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE I
FALL AND ONE SIXTEEN TH. ALAN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ADKINS I BASE.
BACKER HI FORTIS. BRADFORD I
COME BY OTHER HIGH PROTESTING I
DALLY. DOT I TORONTO HI EGGMAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG WESTERN HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAMEL UNDER I
LAYERED. I LABOUR HI THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S THE MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH.
NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH I RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG HI KELSEY HI
WINNER I WILL KNOW. MA'AM SIR
RICHARD PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. FAITH NO PORCHES.
DALLY. EGGMAN GROWTH HERTZBERG
I MELINDA'S. NEWMAN NIELSEN NO
STERN. MARCH TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
FIVE ON THE URGENCY HIGHS
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS FIVE ON THE
MEASURE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. ONE NINETEEN. WE HAVE
SKIN CENTER SCANNER. SHE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY MARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FORTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
YOUR FLOOR'S YOURS- THANK YOU.
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
FORTY CLARIFIES. WHAT'S KNOWN
AS SECOND LOOK SENTENCING WHICH
AUTHORIZES COURTS. TO RE VISIT
SENTENCES OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE ONLY WHEN RECOMMENDED BY
SPECIFIED LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
SECRETARY OF OUR CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT AND ELECTED DA.
BANDS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE POOR BOARD AND FINALLY
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS. THE
BILL STRENGTHENS DUE PROCESS BY
ESTABLISHING COURT DEADLINES
ENSURES THE RIGHT TO A HEARING
IN A RIGHT TO COUNSEL IT DOES
NOT EXPAND IN INDIVIDUALS THAN
THEINDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR REFERRAL IT SIMPLY
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
FOR JUDGES REGARDING THE RE
SENSING PROCESS. BEYOND THE
CATEGORIES OF PEOPLE WHO CAN
RECOMMENDED AND STATUS INSURERS
DUE PROCESS AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION TODAY. HERE AND SEEN
ON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ROLLING FOLLOWING A WIN
NINETEEN. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS I HATE NO BECKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A-
CORTESE I DALLY NO DOG. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG.
I WEAR SO I HER TADO NO JONES
NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MOON. HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. NO MAN. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A TURBO NO PAM I
PERSON TINA. I. ROSS. HI RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN A MEMBER. WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL KNOW.
M. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL LAB TO
MEMBERS. COME BY OTHER. EGGMAN
LASER GROWTH. MAN RUBIO. STERN
AMBERG. FIVE TWENTY THREE KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES THEM
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
THE FALL ITEM ONE TWENTY. WE
HAVE CENTER CORTESE HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT AND ACTUALLY INTO
WORKER CLASSIFICATION SENATOR
PURCHASING. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TEN- COLLEAGUES ARISE
PRESENT AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE.
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS
FOLLOW UP LEGISLATION ON MAYBE
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN. A
CONSOLES LEGISLATION OF TWENTY
TWENTY ON EMPLOYMENT STATUS IN
THE APPLICATION OF THE A. B. C.
TO US THIS BILL MAKES FOLLOWING
CHANGES AND CLARIFICATIONS.
EXTENDS FOR THREE YEARS UNTIL
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THE SUNSET ON THE EXEMPTION
FROM THE APPLICATION OF THE ABC
TO US. FOR A LICENSE MANICURIST.
WITH A HIGH DEGREE OF CONTROL
OVER THEIR WORK. TO EXTEND ALSO
FOR THREE YEARS THE EXEMPTION
FROM THE ABC TEST FOR
SUBCONTRACTORS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRUCKING INDUSTRY.
FROM A CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE IS
NOT REQUIRED TO SATISFY
SPECIFIED REQUIREMENTS. THREE
ADDS TO THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
EXEMPTION TO THE ABC TELLS
PERSONS WHO PERFORM CLAIMS
ADJUSTING OR THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATION. FOR CLARIFIES
THE DATA AGGREGATOR EXEMPTION
BY REFERRING TO AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO PROVIDES FEEDBACK. AS A
RESEARCH SUBJECT IT REMOVES
LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAT THE
COMPENSATION RECEIVES
EQUIVALENT TO AN HOURLY WAGE
RATE. AND LASTLY CLARIFIES THE
MANUFACTURED HOUSING SALES
PERSON EXEMPTION THIS BILL HAS
BEEN ON CONSENT. THROUGHOUT THE
ASSEMBLY THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NINE MEMBERS THIS
IS AUDIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY. IN
NINETEEN NINE ALL EYES THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS IT IS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM ONE TWO
ONE. SENATOR ARCHULETA ARE YOU
PREPARED- SECRETARY MARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND THE ECONOMY AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS. SENATOR
ARTILLERY THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR A
COMMITTEE BILL FROM THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE. A. B.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR ENHANCES
THE ABILITY OF THE STATE TO
COURT TO PROSECUTE FRAUDULENT
CONTRACTING ACTIVITIES
INCREASES COLLABORATION AMONG
SMALL BUSINESS AND DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS ENTERPRISE.%
THE BILL PROVIDES MORE TARGETED
SUPPORT TO AWARDING DEPARTMENT
IN ACHIEVING SMALL BUSINESS AND
DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROCUREMENT
PARTICIPATION GOALS. AND
REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES TO MAKE
CONTINUOUS EFFORTS TO EXPAND
THE POOL OF SMALL BUSINESSES
AND MICRO BUSINESSES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THE AGES
CONTRACTS. ABC FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR CLARIFIES THAT BOTH A
WORKFORCE AND WORKPLACE
PROCUREMENT PREFERENCE CAN BE
AWARDED UNDER THE TARGET AREA
PROCUREMENT ACT. THERE IS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. I
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ANC NONE
OF MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO FOR YOU
KNOW AND THROW CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FOLLOWING A ONE TWO ONE.
HEARING SEEN ON AUGUST THIRTY
EIGHT. KNOWS IT IS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON
THE FILE FILE ITEM ONE TWO TWO.
SENATOR CORTESE HAS HE PREPARED
HE IS MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN
ACT RELATING TO PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR CORTESE YES
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX. WHICH RELATES TO THE
CURRENT TEMPORARY EXEMPTION OF
THE NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY FROM ABC
TELLS FOR EMPLOYMENT STATUS
THIS BILL AS A RESULT OF
THOUGHTFUL NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE INDUSTRY. SPECIFICALLY THE
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS CONSULTATION AND
FEEDBACK FROM LABOR
STAKEHOLDERS AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
WILL EXTEND THE TEMPORARY
EXEMPTION FROM THE A. B. C.
TESTS FOR NEWSPAPER CARRIERS
FOR THREE YEARS SO THAT IT WILL
EXPIRE ON JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THIS EXTENSION
INCLUDES CRITICAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER FOR THE-STATE AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
ASSESS THE USE OF THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR MODEL IN
THE INDUSTRY. UNDERSTAND ANY
TRENDS IN CARRIER MIS
CLASSIFICATION ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IS END
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THE SENATE. AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT
ROLE. THAT NEWSPAPERS PLAY IN
EDUCATING INFORMING OUR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT CRITICAL
ISSUES IMPACTING THEM BUT DOES
SO WITH THE LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY TO ENSURE. NEWSPAPERS
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LABOR
LAW. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THAT THIS ITEM ON FILE ITEM
ONE TWO TWO. HEARING SCENE-
INTO MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE SIDE OF.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS.
BASE I BACKER. I FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM ARE YOU
PROTESTING I DALLY I DONT. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE I HURTS
BERG I WAS SO HYPER TANTO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MAIN I MEAN WIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN
HI FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT I
REVIEW I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
HI LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
HI. M. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS EGGMAN
NIELSEN. STERN NIELSEN I. STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NOTES ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES THEM MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON THE FILE
ITEM ONE. TWENTY THREE WE HAVE
SENATOR BECKER HE'S REPAIRED
MADAM SECRETARY MARY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR BOOKER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT A
B. SEVEN A ONE BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN
GONZALEZ. THE MEMBERS I FEEL
HONORED TO REPRESENT THAT MUCH
OF SILICON VALLEY IN THE HEART
OF OUR TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY.
HAVE DONE ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND
TECHNOLOGY SINCE THE EARLY DAYS
OF THE INTERNET AND THAT'S WHY
EXACTLY I AM PRESENTING THIS
BILL HERE TODAY. I KNOW THAT WE
CAN LEAD WITH TECHNOLOGY THAT
POSITIVELY ADVANCES HUMANITY
AND WE CAN DO SO IN A WAY. THAT
DOES NOT NEGATIVELY AFFECT
WORKERS HEALTH AND SAFETY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS NOT
HAPPENING TODAY IN MANY OF OUR
WAREHOUSES. TO MAKE NEXT DAY
DELIVERY POSSIBLE BUSINESSES
HAVE FORCED WORKERS TO WORK
FASTER AND WITH THEIR OWN
BODIES IN THE PROCESS. THESE
COMPANIES ARE PUTTING VITAMIN
WORKERS ARE TREATED PRETTY MUCH
LIKE MACHINES. EVERY DAY THEY
FACE INCREASING NETWORK SPEED
REQUIREMENTS TO BE RELENTLESS
PRODUCTIVITY QUOTAS. JUST
MINUTES BETWEEN SKINNY PACKAGES
THE SYSTEM CAN FLAG WORKERS OFF
TASK RESULTING IN AUTOMATIC
DISCIPLINE AND EVEN TERMINATION.
FORCING MANY WORKERS TO NEGLECT
BASIC NEEDS SUCH AS GOING TO
THE BATHROOM. CORPORATIONS LIKE
AMAZON MACHINE INDUSTRY
STANDARD. OF WHAT'S CONSIDERED
COMPETITIVE THE ONE MOST
PHYSICALLY DANGEROUS JOBS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. MS OUR
WORKERS ARE INJURED ON THE JOB
AT TWICE THE AVERAGE RATE OF
THE OVERALL WAREHOUSING
INDUSTRY. AND THREE TIMES THE
RATE OF ALL PRIVATE EMPLOYERS.
BUT THE OPPORTUNITY SPEECH
WORKERS INCLUDING LONG TERM
FRIENDS OF MINE WHO WORKED IN
THESE WAREHOUSES AND SHARE
THEIR STORIES WITH ME. WE
CANNOT ACCEPT THESE UNSAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS AS THE NEW
FUTURE OF WORK. WITHOUT WORKERS
TO CONTINUE PUTTING THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY ON THE LINE
FOR CORPORATE PROFITS. EIGHTY
SEVEN OH ONE WOULD MAKE A CLEAR
WORKERS COULD NT BE
DISCIPLINED FOR FAILING TO MEET
A QUOTA THAT DIDN'T ALLOW THEM
TO COMPLY WITH EXISTING HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS. BOURBON STREET
WORKERS WILL NOT BE PENALIZED
OFF TASK FOR COMPLYING WITH
BASIC SAFETY RULES ARE USING
THE BATHROOM. THE BILL ALSO
CREATES TRANSPARENCY. BY
REQUIRING DISCLOSURE OF QUOTAS
AND WORKS BE DATED TO WORKERS
AND TO STATE AGENCIES.
ESTABLISHES PROTECTIONS AGAINST
RETALIATION FOR HER TO MAKE
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO UNSAFE
QUOTAS. THE AUTHOR HAS WORKED
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
MAJOR CONCERNS IT IS NEAR THE
BILL WHERE APPROPRIATE MOTHER
THINGS THE BILL DOESN'T EXTEND
PAGA TO ANY LAWS OR STANDARDS
NOT CURRENTLY COVERED. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT READING THE
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE AND
REASSERTING DIGNITY ENTER
INNOVATION. LET'S STOP THE RACE
TO THE BOTTOM ESPECIALLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE. ON A. B. SEVEN
OH ONE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING CHAIN
NINE MINUTES SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FALL ITEM ONE
TWO THREE. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD I HAVE I
DON'T. CORTESE I DALLY NO DOT
NO TORONTO I EXPLAINED GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROSS NO HERTZBERG.
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO. NO JONES
NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED FIVE
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A TRUCK BOTH NO PAN.
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH. I
REVIEW I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I
WILL. NO MMHM SIX- PLEASE CALL
UP TO MEMBERS. COME BY OTHER I.
EDMUND GLAZER. STERN. VICE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWLES ELEVEN THE
MEASURE. I'M SORRY HIGHS TWENTY
SIX LIVES TWENTY SIX KNOWS A
LEVIN THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY FIVE NOW TURN OVER
THE. THIS. SENATOR ROTH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SIMPLY
BILL SIX NINETY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AROUND THE ISLAND AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THIS BILL HELPS
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS BY CLARIFYING
THE TERM PRIVATE PRACTICE AND
OTHER PSYCHOTHERAPIES SETTING
DEFINITIONS THIS CLARIFICATION
WILL LEAD TO FULL UTILIZATION
OF ASSOCIATES AND TRAINEES BY
REDUCING THE CONFUSION ABOUT
WHERE THEY CAN WORK. AND WHERE
THEY MAY TRAIN THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SUPERVISION
IN PRIVATE PRACTICE SETTINGS
THE MEASURES EVEN ANIMUS
SUPPORT RESPECTIVELY AS FOR
ANOTHER VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
RALPH MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE.
MEMBERS THIS IS
YOU IT QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ANY OBJECTION IS A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ALL EYES THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN
SENATOR LAYERED HE'S READY TO
GO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SERVER
THANK YOU MA'AM OR MADAM
PRESIDENT THEY B. ELEVEN
THIRTEEN EXPANDS EXISTING LAW
TO ADD LICENSED PHYSICIANS AND
NURSES. WHOSE DEATHS WERE
CAUSED BY COVERT NINETEEN TO
THE LIST OF ELIGIBLE FEE
pAND SPOUSES THEIR SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES I ASKED FOR MY PHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SIR ANY OBJECTION. SINGING
HERNANDEZ THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MAJOR PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE.
SENATOR LAYERED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO WILDFIRES CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT EIGHTY SIX FORTY TWO
ISN'T ON WINDOWS ARM NO BOOKS
FIRE PREVENTION BILL THAT MAKES
VARIOUS CHANGES TO SUPPORT
CULTURAL AND PRESCRIBED FIRE
AND PROTECT COMMUNITIES FROM
WILDFIRES THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES I WOULD ASK FOR MY PHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED
MEMBERS IN DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THIS IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE SENATOR
DODD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX BY A FAMILY MEMBER
GRAY AN ACT RELATING TO PARK
PROPERTY SENATOR DODD. THANK
YOU AT PRESENT SENATORS AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX WILL ALLOW
THE CITY OF MODESTO CA
DISPOSING TRANSFER OWNERSHIP OF
BEARD BROOK PARK TO A PRIVATE
ENTITY IN EXCHANGE FOR LANDS OF
EQUAL OR GREATER VALUE- BROOK
PARK WOULD GIVE TO THE CITY OF
MODESTO IN NINETEEN NINETEEN.
BUT THE PARKS USES HAS BEEN IN
STEADY DECLINE SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETIES THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE CITY
CLOSED THE PARK TO THE PUBLIC
ENTIRELY THE CITY WOULD LIKE TO
TRANSFER OWNERSHIP TO A-
PRIVATE ENTITY IN EXCHANGE FOR
LAND LESS THAN A HALF A MILE A
MILE AWAY SKEWS ME. IN THE LAND
WILL BE CONVERTED TO A PARK WHO
ALSO ENABLE THE CITY TO
COMPLETE A BIKE TRAIL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL- THANK YOU IS THIS. IS
ANYONE OBJECTING TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING AND
HEARING NONE HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEMS ONE
THIRTY TWO SENATOR ALAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO CONSERVATORSHIP
SENATOR ALAN. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU- CALIFORNIA'S
CONSERVATORSHIP SYSTEM IS
CURRENTLY UNDER THE NATIONAL
SPOTLIGHT. MEDIA COVERAGE OF
THE CASE OF BRITNEY SPEARS AND
OTHERS REVEAL SYSTEM IN NEED OF
BETTER OVERSIGHT OF GUARDIANS
AND CONSERVATORS. AND MORE
ROBUST DUE PROCESS RIGHTS FOR
CONSERVATIVES. CONSERVATORSHIP
IS ARGUABLY THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL CIVIL
RESTRICTIONS LEVIED AGAINST
CALIFORNIANS THE COURT ACTING
IN WHAT IT DECIDES TO BE THE
CONSERVATIVES BEST INTEREST. IS
DEPRIVING AN INDIVIDUAL
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS THE RIGHT TO
MANAGE PROPERTY TO SPEND MONEY
TO HANDLE THEIR OWN MEDICAL
AFFAIRS EVEN TO MAKE EVERYDAY
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT TO EAT. OR
WHO TO SPEND TIME WITH. SUCH
CONSEQUENTIAL LIFE ALTERING
RESTRICTIONS SHOULD ONLY BE
IMPOSED WHEN ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. AND IN THE PRESENCE
OF AN ATTORNEY WHO IS ACTIVELY
PURSUING THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ALTERNATIVES ON BEHALF OF A
CONSERVATIVE. BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO CONVINCE THE JUDGE BUT- WE
NEED AN INDEPENDENT-
INDEPENDENT ATTORNEY FOR THESE
CONSERVATORS. APRIL OF NINETY
FOUR IT MAX NUMBER OF IMPORTER
FORMS TO CALIFORNIA'S
CONSERVATORSHIP FRAMEWORK AMONG
OTHER THINGS IT BOLSTERS THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY BUTTE
BUREAU'S ABILITY TO DISCIPLINE
PROFESSIONAL CONSERVATORS AND
GUARDIANS. RESTRICTS CERTAIN
EXORBITANT FEES AND PERMITS
FINANCIAL CONFLICTS IT ENHANCES
THE REMEDIES AVAILABLE TOWARDS
THE CONSERVATIVES WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY THEIR GUARDIANS.
OR CONSERVATORS. WHAT YEAH
IT'S- IT'S SUBJECT TO FOR A FEW
FOR YOUR PREPARATION OF PLACES
NEW REQUIREMENTS ON COURTS TO
INVESTIGATE AND REVIEW
CONSERVATORSHIP AND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT THING THAT I WAS
WORKING ON IT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO FOLD INTO THIS BILL. THIS
BILL PROVIDES CONSERVATIVES
WITH A CLEAR RIGHT TO CHOOSE AN
ATTORNEY OF THEIR PREFERENCE.
WHILE ALSO REQUIRING THESE
ATTORNEYS ACT AS ELLIS
INDEPENDENT ADVOCATES. ON THEIR
CLIENTS BEHALF. THE LEGISLATION
IS GUARDED ROBUST BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECT FOR US RIVALS. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION A BIT ON THE
SIDE I'M SENATOR MEN. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR PROPOSING
THIS BILL I. URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE HI BRITNEY. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS ON THIS MEASURE
HEARING TINA AND SENATOR OUT
WHICH ARTICLES I WANT TO SEE
MYSELF WITH MY THE COMMENTS
FROM MY FRIEND FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND RESPECT FOR US RIGHT
UP. THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE AND
ONE THREE TWO. HEARING SEEN
NINE ICE THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS IT
IS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
FALL ITEM ONE THIRTY. A MEASURE
THAT WILL BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR. LABEL SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY SIX
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION AN ACT RELATING TO
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION CENTER LEVEL THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB
FORTY SIX IS THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE K. TWELVE EDUCATION OMNIBUS
TECHNICAL BILL. ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE SPONSORED
BILL THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL
AND OTHER NON CONTROVERSIAL
REVISIONS TO NUMEROUS
PROVISIONS OF THE EDUCATION
CODE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
HEARING SEE NONE OF THE MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW
SEVERAL CALLS OR ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS ITEM FOLLOWING HIM ONE
THIRTY HERE IN C. NINE HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO FALL
INTO. ONE THREE THREE. WE HAVE
SENATOR DODD HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AN ACT
RELATING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION. SENATOR DOT THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
FIREFIGHTERS PROTECT US IN OUR
HOMES AND NOW WE CAN PROTECT
THEIR SACRIFICE AND MAKE SURE
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO THE
FINANCIAL WORRY THAT THEIR
INJURY MAY HAVE COST D. B.
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO WOULD
AUTHORIZE FIREFIGHTERS EMPLOYED
BY CAL FIRE TO RECEIVE A 100%
OF THEIR WAGE IF THEY SHOULD
BECOME INJURED ON THE JOB YEAH
BRING THEM TO PART WITH OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON FALL AND ONE THREE
THREE. HEARING SCENE KNOWN AS-
MEMBERS IS AS WELL AS POSSIBLE
FOR YOU KNOW THROW CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNITED FOR A CALL. AND C.
NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS AS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON-
ONE THREE FOUR SENATOR CAFIERO
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
READ. SOMEBODY FELL SEVEN OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
AN ACT RELATING TO HAZARDOUS
WASTE CENTER COPIER. MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THE MERCURY
CONTAINING THERMOSTATS HAVE NOT
BEEN SOLD IN THE STATE SINCE
TWENTY TWENTY OH SIX THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF THERMOSTATS IT
NEED TO BE COLLECTED FOR PROPER
DISPOSAL. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO COLLECT
MERCURY THERMOSTATS FOR
RECYCLING HOWEVER THE PROGRAM
WAS NEVER FUNDED AND MANDATED
COLLECTION TARGETS HAVE NEVER
BEEN MET. EIGHTY SEVEN OH SEVEN
REWRITES AND IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM FOR MERCURY THERMOSTAT
COLLECTION BY MAKING THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES REQUIRES THE
FULLY FUND THE REGULATORY
COSTS. TO COLLECT TRANSPORT AND
RECYCLE MERCURY THERMOSTATS TO
PROVIDE NO LESS THAN NINE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER TO
DO A ROBUST EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. AND HAS A
BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE COLLECTION OF
MERCURY THERMOS. THERMOS
THERMOSTATS I THINK THE KEY
HERE MEMBERS IS IT MERCURY AS
YOU KNOW IS A POISON AND WE
NEED A PROCESS AND MONEY IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT.
AND DISPOSE OF THESE THERE IS
NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE SIGN I'M
HEARING SEEN ON MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR USING AN OUNCE
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE INTERNET
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FOLLOWED A
ONE THREE FOUR. HEARING C. NINE
ALL EYES THIRTY EIGHT. WHO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
FOR MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
THE FILE I DON'T ONE THREE
FIVE. FOLLOWING A ONE THREE
FIVE SENATOR A BURGER YOU
PREPARE TO PRESENT FOLLOWING A
ONE THREE FIVE. AND SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR UMBERG AIMS
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT NO OPPOSITION
GOOD BILL JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
UNDER THIS BILL VOTE I. E.
EDITION DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THE SIDE OF. HEARING CHIGNON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. I ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS. EIGHT HI BECKER HI
FORGES HI BRADFORD HI I COME BY
ADAM HI FOR TESTING I TALLY.
GOD HI THERE ALSO HI ADNAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE GROVE.
HURTS ROAD I HEARD SPURRED I
WAS SO. I TANTO I JONES RIGHT I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MOON HI WIRE. BELINDA'S I
MEAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. THE
TROUBLE OKAY HI TAM FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT I RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN NUMBER FIVE
CASSIE I WINNER I WILL. I
SENATOR BYRD MOVES A CALL
NUMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM ONE THREE SIX SENATOR
ALERT HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE AN ACT
RELATING TO FISH AND WILDLIFE.
TO EARLIER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- AB THREE FIFTEEN SIX
TO ENCOURAGE LANDOWNERS TO
CONSENT. TO GOVERNMENT FUNDING
HABITAT ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION
PROJECTS ON THEIR PROPERTY BY
CLARIFYING LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS FOR LANDOWNERS
THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I
ASKED FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SCENE NINE MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FALL
FOLLOWING HIM THREE ONE THREE
SIX. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE HI BACKER I
PORCHES I BRADFORD HI I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING HI DALLY. I
DONT I TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER
ARKANSAS IS GROWTH. HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO. I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR. I THE MOON HI WIRE
MELINDA'S I BEEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT
HI RUBIO. I SKINNER I TURNED
AMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL HI. SINNER LORED MOVED TO
CALL. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM ONE THREE
SEVEN SENATOR AWHILE. HE'S NOT
AVAILABLE ARE GOING TO PASS ON
FILE FOR A MINUTE. NOW MOVING
ON TO FALL ITEM ONE THREE EIGHT
SENATOR ALAN YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT. HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
MARIE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL AN ACT RELATING TO
LEGAL ASSISTANCE SENATOR AL
MEMBERS THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
THE WAY LEGAL DEFENSE AND
EDUCATION FUND TO PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA
RENTERS TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
BEFORE IT BEGINS. I RESPECT S.
RIVALS. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
AND SEEING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
FOLLOWED A ONE THREE EIGHT.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS I
FACE. NO BACKER. I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I FOR
TESTING I DALLY NO DOG. HI
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE GROSS NO HERTZBERG
HI I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
I LLEVA I THE MOON I WIRE
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. I A TROUBLED. NO PAM I
FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER HI STERN I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
NO CINDERELLA MOVES CALL IS OUR
MOVING ONTO FILE ITEM ONE THREE
NINE SENATOR PAN HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY MARY. I SIMPLY
BILL SIX NINETEEN BY A FAMILY
MEMBER CALLED IRAN AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH
CENTER PENN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS- RATES
PERCENT EIGHTY SIX NINETEEN BY
SARAH CALDERON WHICH REQUIRES
COUNTY STREET PLANS TO ME FOR
MANAGING DEFECTS OF WILDFIRE
SMOKE ON VOCALS POPULATIONS
WITH GUIDANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PARK PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS BILL MEDICAID THE IMPACTS
OF WILDFIRE SMOKE ONLINE HEALTH
EXPECT THE ASPIRIN I DON'T.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HERE IN
ENCINO AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I HATE
FIVE BECKER HI FORGES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I
PROTESTING I DALLY I DONT. FIVE
TORONTO. THEY'RE ALSO HI EGGMAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE. GROVE. HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO I HER TADO
I JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LABOR HI THE MON HI MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S. I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I UNTIL ABOUT FIVE PM I
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT I
REVIEW I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
HI WHAT KIND OF SKI I WINNER. I
WILL I. INTERBRAND MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL I DON'T KNOW ONE FORTY
CENTER COM LOGGER ON BEHALF OF
HIS FAMILY MEMBER BLOWN THEM
SECRETARY MARY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN OH NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AN ACT RELATING TO
AGRICULTURE CENTER KOMAR THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
PRESENT AB. TEN OH NINE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
WHICH ESTABLISHES THE FARM TO
COMMUNITY HUB PROGRAM WITHIN
THE OFFICE OF FARM TO FORK AND
PROPOSES FUNDING FOR A PILOT
PROGRAM TO ESTABLISH AT LEAST A
THREE FARM TO COMMUNITY FOOD
HUBS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FOOD HUBS OFFER A REGIONALIZED
APPROACH TO FOOD DISTRIBUTION
THAT HAS PROVEN TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL FOR PROMOTING
DIRECT FARM AND RANCH SALES TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS RESULTED
IN THE UNPREDICTABILITY AND
LOTS OF MARKETS. WHICH HAS HAD
A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL SCALE
FARMERS. DURING THE PANDEMIC
THOSE AREAS THAT HAD COMMUNITY
FACING FOOD HUB WERE ABLE TO
PIVOT QUICKLY TOWARD RE
DIRECTING THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS
TO AREAS OF NEED. THE FIRM TO
COMMUNITY FOOD HAVE CREATED
UNDER THIS BILL WILL PRIORITIZE
AGGREGATION AND DISTRIBUTION
FROM FARMS AND RANCHES THAT-
COOPERATIVELY OWNED OPERATING
ON FIVE HUNDRED ACRES OR LESS
WERE OWNED BY SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED BEGINNING LIMITED
RESOURCE VETERANS MINORITY OR
DISABLED FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND OTHER
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. ON A. B. TEN OH NINE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. WE HAVE
CENTER JONES. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME DETAILS IN
THE BILL- AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE FLOOR MANAGER QUESTION
REGARDING THE INTENT OF SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE FROM THE AUTHOR IN
THE ASSEMBLY. SENATOR COME ARE
WE ENTERTAIN A QUESTION. YES
THE TERRORIST CENTER THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT YOUR PRESIDENT-
THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT STATES. PARTICIPATING
FARMERS AND RANCHERS MUST
COMPLY. WITH ALL LOCAL ALL LAWS
RULES AND REGULATIONS WHICH
SEEMS TO IMPLY. THAT CALIFORNIA
FARMERS RANCHERS- ARE NOT
CURRENTLY COMPLYING WITH-
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS. AND SO
IS THAT THE IMPLICATION THAT
THE AUTHOR IN THE ASSEMBLY IS
TRYING TO MAKE WITH THIS
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL. TO- TALK
JUST WA YES I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION FROM THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM STAND T. THE ANSWER IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND THE FLOOR MANAGER
LOVE FARMS AND FARMERS. THIS
PROVISION DOES NOT SUGGEST
THAT- THAT FARMERS AND RANCHERS
DO NOT COMPLY WITH STATE LAW.
BECAUSE THE FARM TO COMMUNITY
FOOD HUBS WILL BE ACCEPTING
GRANT DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
THE PROVISION- THAT'S BEING
REFERENCED INSURES THAT THE
FARMS AND RANCHES. WITH WHICH
THE FOOD HUB WILL BE WORKING
ARE IN GOOD STANDING FARM
BUREAUS FLOOR ALERT REFERENCES
A PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL
CITING FAIR LABOR PRACTICES
THAT LANGUAGE HAS SINCE BEEN
AMENDED OUT OF THE BILL AND
INSTEAD NOW READS FARMS AND
RANCHES FOLLOWING STATE LABOR
PRACTICES. WHICH IS CLEARLY IN
LINE WITH THE STATE'S GOALS AND
VALUES UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL THE FOOD HAVE
OPERATORS WHO RECEIVE GRANTS
WILL ENSURE THAT THE SUPPLIERS
THEY WORK WITH COMPLY WITH-STATE LAW. IT CAN BE PART OF
THEIR GRANT APPLICATION TO SHOW
HOW THEY INTEND TO DO THIS THEY
COULD FOR EXAMPLE MONITOR
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATABASES OR
EVEN CONTRACT WITH A THIRD
PARTY TO DO SO. AGAIN THIS
REQUEST IS GUIDANCE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE GRANT PROGRAM
BUT DOES NOT IMPOSE ANY
REGULATORY BURDEN ON ANY ENTITY.
IS THAT SATISFY THE QUESTIONER
JR THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I DO
APPRECIATE THE FOUR MANAGERS
VERY DETAILED AND ARTICULATED
ANSWER TO MY QUESTION. I DO
HAVE REMAINING CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL I'LL BE LAYING OFF
TODAY- BUT CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE CONCEPT AND THE IDEA BEHIND
THE BILL AND APPRECIATE THE
FLOOR MANAGERS PROFESSIONALS
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
HERE. SENATOR MELINDA BUSH.
THANK YOU- I NEED TO HAVE A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS AND HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE FLOOR MANAGER
IF I MAY SAY- COME OVER WE TAKE
QUESTIONS. S. H. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO- A COUPLE THINGS IN THE
BILL ONE. IT TALKS ABOUT THOSE
BEING ELIGIBLE AS BEING
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGE AND I
WONDER IF YOU COULD PROVIDE A
DEFINITION OF WHAT SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED MEANS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS BILL. SO
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED. CAN
MEAN- FARMERS OF COLOR IT CAN
MEAN FARMERS WHO- ARE
CONSIDERED LOW INCOME- THOSE
ARE A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES I'M
SURE YOU MIGHT HAVE OTHER
CONCERNS AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I CAN ELABORATE ON
THAT ANSWER. WHILE YOU ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION. I HAVE- JUST
TWO QUESTIONS BUT THE YOU KNOW
THE ONE THAT THAT HAS
CONFOUNDED ME A BIT IT IS THE
DEFINITION OF SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED BECAUSE FROM- THE
ANALYSIS THAT I HAVE READ AND
SO THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING THE
QUESTION PERHAPS YOU CAN EXPAND
ON IT PERHAPS I'M WRONG BUT
FROM THE ANALYSIS THAT I'VE
READ. IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED- RELATES
TO- AN ETHNIC SORT OF BAD A
BENCHMARK IN OTHER WORDS IT'S
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO RACE
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS- IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE THAT WOULD PUT
SOMEONE IN THE CATEGORY- FOR
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED WITH
RESPECT TO THESE FARMERS. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SO
IN THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL IT DOES NOT SPECIFY THAT
RACE WOULD BE A DETERMINING
FACTOR. AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW
IF THAT WOULD BE ALLOWABLE
UNDER THE LAW BUT SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED CAN ALSO MEAN IF
YOU ARE A VETERAN IF YOU ARE
DISABLED. IF YOU HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES. WITH WHICH TO-
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE ON YOUR
FARM SO THOSE ARE OTHER
EXAMPLES THAT ALSO- HELP TO
HOPEFULLY DEFINE WHAT SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED. MEANS I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM OUR
RESIDENT FARMER ON THE SENATE
FLOOR WHO TALKS ABOUT HOW
EXPENSIVE IT IS TO MAINTAIN
YOUR FARMLAND AND THOSE THAT
ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES. THAT'S YOU SENATOR.
FROM A CLOUD- ARE ALSO INCLUDED
IN THIS DEFINITION. RACE IS
NOT- IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL. OKAY SO THEN THERE IS- I
WILL GO BACK AND LOOK AT IT
THERE IS A DEFINITION PROVIDED
WITHIN THE BILL AS TO WHAT
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGES IS THAT
CORRECT. IT IS- ACTUALLY ON
PAGE FIVE OF THE BILL AND IT IS
ONE OF THE- LISTED CRITERIA.
AND THEY DO GIVE EXAMPLES OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN- I FOR MY
FINAL QUESTION WOULD BE IF
THERE IS ANY CONCERN- GIVEN
THAT WE ARE ON A FEDERAL LEVEL
YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME-
ISSUE AND SOME. LITIGATION
RELATING TO. FUNDING GIVEN TO
DISADVANTAGED- FARMERS WITH
RESPECT TO COVERT RELIEF AND I
BELIEVE THAT WAS CHALLENGED IN
COURT AS BEING UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BECAUSE IT WASN'T OFFERED TO-
EVERYONE IN THE FARMING
COMMUNITY JUSTIN CURIOUS IF
THERE'S CONCERNS WITH THE SPELL
THAT THAT. MIGHT FALL INTO THE
SAME CATEGORY. I DON'T THINK
THAT IS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL THE
LANGUAGE IN AB TEN OH NINE DOES
PROVIDE DIRECTION TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO AWARD. THOSE
GRANTS TO THOSE FOOD HUBS- THAT
SHOW HOW THEY WILL BE
FINANCIALLY SELF SUFFICIENT AND
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
TRAPS HAVE BEEN RUN AS IT
RELATES TO THIS BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT RUNS PARALLEL WITH
STATE. AND FEDERAL LAWS. VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE CLARITY.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS OR DEBATE
AS IT RELATES TO FALL ITEM ONE
FORTY. HEARING AND SEEING NO
OTHER DISCUSSIONS SENATOR TOM
ARE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I JUST WANNA THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR QUESTIONS
BECAUSE- I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S
GREAT TO- HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON
AND THE FARMERS THAT WORK IN
OUR STATE AND PROVIDE US ACCESS
TO GREAT- FOOD AND VEGETABLES
AND SUSTENANCE- AND ASK THAT
YOU ALL WILL SUPPORT. EIGHTY
ONE OH ONE TEN OH NINE WHICH
WILL ALLOW FOR A GRANT. PILOT
PROGRAM TO HELP SOME OF THESE
SMALLER FARMERS I CONTINUE TO
DO THE AMAZING WORK THAT THEY
DO FOR CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
STATE WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOUS SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FALLEN
ONE FORTY. WITH ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I BASE.
BACKER HI FORGES BRADFORD I
HAVE A- CORTESE I DALLY. DOT I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER.
GONZALES I GROSS. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HI FURTADO FIVE JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE HI WIRE. MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON BUT
CHICAGO HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO
HI RALPH I REVIEW HI SKINNER.
HI STERN NUMBER FIVE WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL.
HOME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT
SOME MEMBERS. BASED PORCHES.
COME BY YELLOW I DALLY. EGGMAN
GLAZER I GROSS I JONES. MCGUIRE.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO.
STERN WELL. SENATOR COMMA
REMOVES A CALL. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE GOING ON A FILE I DON'T
ONE FOUR ONE SOONER WINNER HE'S
REPAIRED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING. CENTER WINNER THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT OUR COLORS ARE
RISING PERCENT AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF SOME
REMEMBER BLOOM. THIS BILL MAY
LOOK FAMILIAR TO YOU
COLLEAGUES- WE BECAUSE I
AUTHORED IT LAST YEAR AND WE
PASSED IT OUT OF THE HOUSE OF
ORIGIN ON AND UNFORTUNATELY I
YOU MAY RECALL THOSE WILL
TURMOIL AT THE END OF. A
SESSION WE HAD A RESUME
SITUATION WE HAD- SOME DISPUTES
WITH THE OTHER HOUSE- AND-
UNFORTUNATELY- THE BILL DID NOT
TAKE A BACK. POCKET CURRENCY
UNTIL. THE CLOCK STRUCK
MIDNIGHT A LITTLE BITE WAS SONG
AND THE SESSION WENT INTO A
DEEP SLEEP- SO SUMMER BLOOM HAS
BROUGHT THIS BILL BACK AND A.
B. THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT
PROVIDES. THAT A JURISDICTION
THAT HAS FAILED TO ADOPT AN
EIGHT CITY APPROVES HOUSING
ELEMENT. BY THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE MUST COMPLETE A
REZONING PROGRAM WITHIN ONE
YEAR. CURRENTLY HAVE A
JURISDICTION DOES NOT ADOPT THE
HOUSING ELEMENT BY THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE YOU MUST
ADOPT A REVISED HOUSING ELEMENT
EVERY FOUR YEARS RATHER THAN
EVERY EIGHT THIS PENALTY FOR
NONCOMPLIANCE- HAS PROVEN
EFFECTIVE AND WEEKENDS HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW. FOR EXAMPLE UNDER
CURRENT LAW A CITY OR COUNTY
CAN THE DOCTOR LEGALLY
DEFICIENT HOUSING ELEMENTS
ALMOST FOUR MONTHS AFTER THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE WITH NO
CONSEQUENCES. IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS ADOPT ELEMENT-
WAS NOT REVISED TO CORRECT THE
LEGAL DEFICIENCIES FOR MORE
THAN TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
DEADLINE AND SOME EGREGIOUS
CASES IT WASN'T CORRECTED FOR
YEARS IF EVER. BY AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT SIX TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY SHORTENING THE
TIME PERIOD. IN WHICH. EARNING
IT STRENGTHENS HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW AND INSURERS- THAT THIS
PROCESS HAS MEANING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I GO. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT HAVING
SERVED TO AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE CITY AND COUNTY- IN A
SMALLER- COMMUTING CALIFORNIA-
COMPARED TO SOME OF THE COASTAL
CITIES I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
IS. BEYOND BURDENSOME. WELL A
LEGALLY COMPLIANT. THE HOUSING
ELEMENT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
EXPECTED BUT IT SOUNDS MUCH
EASIER SAID THAN DONE IF WE'RE
IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT DEALING
WITH OUR HOUSING ISSUE IT'S NOT
PUNISHING THE LOCAL FOLKS IN SO
FAR AS WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE BIG BROADER STROKES
AFFECTING OUR SHORTAGE THAT
INCLUDE SEQUEL REFORM. SO I
THINK YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH PLENTY OF SEQUEL
EXEMPTION SYKORA BYPASSES IN
SYNC WITH STREAMLINES WHICH I
THINK IS A MAJOR IMPEDIMENT BUT
WE'RE DANCING AROUND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST WHITE ELEPHANTS IN THE
ROOM SO IMPOSING THIS
OBLIGATION TO CITIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SUCH A PUNITIVE
FASHION. I THINK IS REALLY A
TESTAMENT OF ALREADY IN ACTION
AT THE STATE LEVEL. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING IN
SCENA NINE CENTER WHERE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- TO MY
COLLEAGUE I WILL SAY THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS AUTHORED
VARIOUS HOUSING SYKORA-
STREAMLINING EXEMPTION PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING- THE LATEST ON A
CRUISE SHIP THAT- I TOTALLY
AGREE THAT HOUSING ON THE BY
ITSELF IS NOT. GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM WITH IS A LOT OF
THINGS WE NEED TO DO- AND- I
KNOW WE WORK LIKE COLLABORATIVE
WAY CROSS THE AISLE- IN THIS
BODY TO TRY TO MOVE FORWARD
GOOD HOUSING LEGISLATION- BUT
THE HOUSING ELEMENT IS- AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE PROCESS
AND IT IT HIM IN EMPOWERS
FRANKLY CITIES EVERY YEAR IS
TO- COME UP WITH A PLANNING
DOCUMENT SAY THIS IS HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MEET OUR HOUSING.
GOALS AND I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PROCESS EVEN THOUGH
IT CAN BE PAINFUL- POLITICALLY
BUT IT FORCES THAT KIND OF
DISCIPLINE TO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR
MANY YEARS THE HOUSING ON A
PROCESS WHERE IT WAS JUST AT
TIMES IT WAS A JOKE- THERE'S NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR EITHER BLOWING
IT OFF OR FOR HAVING. JUST
REALLY UNREALISTIC ITEMS WITHIN
THE HOUSING ELEMENT THAT THEY
WERE NEVER GOING TO GET BUILT
AND SO WE'RE FINALLY GETTING TO
THE POINT WHERE WE'RE
STRENGTHENING AND CLOSING
LOOPHOLES AND I DO THINK THIS
IS PART OF THAT SO.
RESPECTFULLY I S. ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU. BENCIC PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FOLLOWING A ONE FOR
ONE. WITH FALLON I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS. EIGHT NO BACKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A HI
COURTESY I DALLY NO DODD. I
THEY'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATE. GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG. I WAS SO HYPER TANTO
I JONES NO CAMCORDER. I LAYERED
I LLEVA I THE MON. MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN.
NIELSEN NO A TRUCK BOTH KNOW
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS.
RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE STERN
NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW SKI. I
WINNER I WILL KNOW. SINNER
WINNER MOVES TO CALL MEMBERS
WERE NOW MOVING ON TO FALL AND
ONE FORTY TWO. SENATOR DHIRAJ
SO SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY RE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AND
ACTUAL RELATING TO IMMIGRATION
ZERO ZERO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I MONITOR PRESENT TEN
NINETY SIX A LATINO CAUCUS
PRIORITY I'M SORRY A. B. TEN
PRIORITY. THIS BILL THE LEADS
THE OUTDATED AND OFFENSIVE TERM
ALIEN. WHICH IS FOUND
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE LAWS AND
REPLACES IT WITH THE
APPROPRIATE LEGAL TERMINOLOGY
SUCH AS NON CITIZEN. ALL THE
TURN ALTHOUGH THE TERM ALIEN
ORIGINALLY REFERRED TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NON
CITIZENS THE WORD HAS SINCE
BEEN WEAPONIZED AND USED IN
PLACE. OF AN EXPLICITLY RACIAL
SLUR THERE'S A DIRECT LINK
BETWEEN WORDS AND ACTIONS AND
HISTORY HAS PROVEN. THAT
DEHUMANIZING LANGUAGE OFTEN
PRECEDES VILE ACTIONS AB TEN
NINETY SIX PROVIDES CALIFORNIA
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT
HIS RACIST RHETORIC AND INSTEAD
INSURERS ARE LAWS CONSIST OF
TERMINOLOGY. THAT ALIGNS WITH
OUR IDEALS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON A. B. TEN
NINETY SIX WELL YOU GO RIDING
THROUGH SHERWOOD FOREST. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
AND SEEING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FOLLOWING A ONE FOUR TWO. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS BATES.
BACKER I PURCHASED NO BRADFORD
I HAVE A I DON'T HI CORTESE I
DALLY NO DOG. HI TORONTO I
EGGMAN LASER I CONSOLIDATE
GROSS NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI
HER TADO. HI JONES NO CAMELOT-
I LAYERED I LABOR I LIVE ALONE
HI WIRE. MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I PERSONS YOU KNOW
I BROUGHT FIVE RUBIO. HI
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
NO. SENATOR ALSO MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM ONE FOUR THREE
SENATOR GLAZER HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY MARY ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
EMPLOYMENT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE ONE THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA REQUIRE
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
TO DEVELOP REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION POLICIES FOR
STATE WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT OF THE HIRING
PRACTICES OF WORKERS WITH
DISABILITY AND CIVIL SERVICE.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA STATE. EMPLOYEES
WITH DISABILITIES. CERTAINLY
SUPPORTED BY FRIENDS OF
GINGERBREAD. ENJOYED WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE SIDE
ON. HEARING NONE AS SEEN ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FALL AT ONE FOUR THREE.
SIX ALAN. HI ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS. BATES BACKER I PORCHES.
HI BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
POTENTIALLY HI DOLLY I DONT HI
THERE AWESOME HI EGGMAN GLAZER
AIKENS OLIVE. GROVE. HERTZBERG
I WENT SO I HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MON HI WIRE. MELINDA'S MAN
I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A CHILD
BOTH. I CAN I PERSON TINO I
BROUGHT. I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
HI STERN NUMBER HI FLY CASTING.
I WINNER I WILL I. YES SIR
NIELSEN NOTED HI SENATOR GORE'S
REMOVES A CALL. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM
ONE FOUR FOUR SENATOR. THANK
YOU THIS MEASURE PROVIDES A
RENTAL CAR INDUSTRY WAS SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC WITHOUT SACRIFICING
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THERE WAS SOME OPPOSITION BUT
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION AMONG
THE MOTHER OF THE GROUPS
INDICATED THEY WERE MOVED THE
OPERATION OF THEIR OPPOSITION
BECAUSE OF EQUITY AND FINANCING
WHICH IS OFTEN USED WITH THE
OUTWARD THE ALGORITHM THE
ALGORITHM THE ACRONYM HEALTH.
S. FOR NINE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE IS JONES. SIR JOHN NOW.
OKAY THERE'S NO FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
FOLLOWED A ONE FOUR FOUR. ALAN
I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. EIGHT HI
BACKER. FORGES ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
PROTESTING HI DOLLY. I DON I
TORONTO I A COMMON LASER I
CONSOLIDATE GROVE HI HURTS BERG
I WEAR SO. HI HER TADO I JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
I THE MOON I REQUIRE. MELINDA'S
MAN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN THE
TROUBLE I CAN HI FORTINO FIVE
ROCK I RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
STERN I'M BERG I BUY CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL. HI SOON HER TO
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE GOING ON A FILE AND ONE
FORTY FIVE WILL BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR VOICE SO HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY A FAMILY MEMBER
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AND ACTUALLY
NEED TO FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
CENTER WHERE SO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD STUDY HOW
THE STATE COULD CREATE A STATE
WIDE RETAIL BANKING OPTION TO
WHICH EVERY CALIFORNIA CONNECTS
ACCESS. ZERO COST FINANCIAL
SERVICES LIKE CHECK CASHING
DIRECT DEPOSIT AND DEBIT CARDS
NOW WHO CAN POSSIBLY VOTE
AGAINST THAT I RECOMMEND I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE I'M HERE IN
CHINO AND- WHEN THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON.
FOLLOWING A ONE FORTY FIVE.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS
BATES NO BACKER. I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I DALLY. NO GOD I
DRAW SO I EGGMAN GLASER I
CONSOLIDATE GROVE NO HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I JONES
NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR
I THE MOON. HI WIRE MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A
TURBO NO PAM I FORTUNE TINO I.
ROSS. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
STERN I'M BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO SOONER WHICH
REMOVES A CALL MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO FALL AT ONE
FORTY SIX INNER SKIN ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM. SHE IS
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSE THREE OF US
AN ACT RELATING TO HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTHS AND
DECLARED THE URGENCY THERE OF
SIX MEDIALLY. SOONER SOONER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
MAYBE TWENTY SEVEN IS A
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY AND IT ESTABLISHES A
STANDARDIZED PROCESS FOR
IDENTIFYING HOMELESS STUDENTS
AND FOR PROVIDING SERVICES TO
OUR HOMELESS YOUTH AND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS. RATHER
THAN THE CIRCUS LIKE NON
PROCESS THAT EXISTS TODAY. IT
CREATES THREE TEMPORARY TAGS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
WITH FEDERAL FUNDING THESE
ASSISTANCE CENTER SUNSET WHEN
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS EXPIRE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE OF
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION RIGHT ON
THE SIDE OF. HEARING SEEN NAINA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FOLLOWING A ONE FORTY
SIX. ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS.
EIGHT I BACKER I FORGES I
BRADFORD I COME BY IT ALL HI
CORTESE I DALLY. I DONT HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE ROSE. HI HURTS BERG
I WEAR SO I HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR.
HI THE MON I ACQUIRE MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. A CHORE
BOTH. I CAN HI PERSON TINA. HI
RALPH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL HI. SINNERS CAN
REMOVE THE CALL. MEMBERS NOW WE
MOVE ON TO FALL ITEM ONE FORTY
NINE FIGURE LOWERS SHE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY MAY
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH FACILITIES CENTER LEVEL
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I JUST REALIZED THAT AFTER THIS
WEEK I'M NOT GOING TO SEE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME SO I WANT TO
WISH YOU A HAPPY EARLY
HALLOWEEN. I RISE TODAY 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS A NUMBER OF COMMON
SENSE REFORMS TO PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REQUEST MOST
IMPORTANTLY GIVING OUR
FRONTLINE NURSES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT ON
CRITICAL HOSPITAL SAFETY
DECISIONS THIS BILL SUPPORTED
BY ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF FIGHTING FOR
WORKERS AND SERVING OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING SEIU
CALIFORNIA YOU NAP AFTER ME AND
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. MEMBERS BY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. DEFENSE
SECRETARY IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE SIDE I'M
HEARING CHAIN THEN MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. ADKINS. EIGHT NO
BACKER HI FORGES NO BRADFORD.
HI BYRON I FOR TESTING I DALLY
NO DOG. I TORONTO I EGGMAN
GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO. HI JONES. NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO A SHOW OF
BOTH NO CAN I FORTUNE TINO. HI
ROSS. I REVIEW FIVE SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBER FIVE CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL KNOW. SOONER OR
LATER MOVED TO CALL. NEXT UP IS
FALL ITEM ONE FIFTY SENATOR PAN
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
MARY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE PROPERTY. PETER PAN YES
THE SURPRISE AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN TO THE ACTIVE
FILE THANK YOU. THIS WILL NOT.
WORK. NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO FALL ITEM ONE FIVE TWO
SENATOR RUBIO SHE'S READY MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD AN ACT
RELATING TO VITAL RECORDS.
SENATOR RUBIO. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE I'M PROUD TODAY
TO PRESENT THIS BILL AND ALSO
BE A CO AUTHOR TO A B. TWO ONE
EIGHT A BILL WHICH HAS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITIONAL PILE
TRANSGENDER CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE TO BE TREATED WITH THE
SAME RESPECT AND DIGNITY AT ALL
CALIFORNIANS EXISTING LAW
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS TO
UPDATE THEIR OWN FOR TWO
TICKETS TO REFLECT THEIR CHOSEN
IDENTITIES THIS BOOK SINCE THE
SAME PROCESS FOR TRANSGENDER
INDIVIDUALS TO UPDATE THE MERIT
CERTIFICATES AND UPDATE THE
BIRD TWO TICKETS OF THEIR
CHILDREN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HE KEREN
CENA AND MANN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FALL AND ONE
FIVE TWO. WITH FALLON FIVE
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS. EIGHT NO
BACKER FIVE FORTUS. FOR JUST
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ C. I. DALI. NO DODD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN LASER AIKENS
OLIVE GROVE NO HURTS BURKE I
WAS SO. HER TADO I JONES. NO
CAMELOT- I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
THE MON I REQUIRE MELINDA'S NO
MAN. I NEWMAN I NELSON NO A
TRUCK BOTH KNOW PAM. HI FORTUNE
TINO. I BROUGHT HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER FIVE
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL
KNOW. SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A
CALL. A MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM ONE FIVE
THREE SENATOR LEYVA SHE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY MARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AN
ACT RELATING TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID. SENATOR LOGO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AV FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
WHICH MODERNIZES STREAMLINES
AND EXPANDS ACCESS TO THE
LARGEST STATE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM CAL GRANT. FOR YEARS OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM CAL GRANT
HAS BEEN OUTDATED OVERLY
COMPLEX AND EXCLUSIONARY FOR
MOST UNDERSERVED STUDENTS THE
PANDEMIC HAS ONLY WORSENED THE
INEQUALITIES TO ACCESSING
AFFORDABLE HIGHER EDUCATION.
THIS YEAR THE BUDGET MADE
SIGNIFICANT STEPS AND MAKING
COLLEGE AFFORDABLE AND
ATTAINABLE TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND EXPANDING ACCESS
TO MIDDLE CLASS STUDENTS EVENSO THE STATE CANNOT ACHIEVE ITS
GOALS OF TIMELY DEGREE
COMPLETION AND DEBT FREE
COLLEGE WITHOUT MAKING SURE
THAT OUR STATE FINANCIAL AID
RESOURCES. COVER THE TOTAL COST
OF EDUCATION TUITION AND FEES
AS WELL AS HOUSING AND BASIC
NEEDS A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
FINALLY ADDRESSES THESE
CHALLENGES BY ENACTING SEVERAL
NECESSARY REFORMS IT REMOVED
ALL ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS TO CAL
GRANT SIMPLIFIES AND MODERNIZES
THE PROGRAM. ALIGNS A STATE
WITH FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID
POLICIES THIS BILL IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO THE BUDGET ACT
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THE JOB
WE GET THE JOB DONE FOR ALL
STUDENTS. THIS IS A POLICY THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AND I. N.
A SUMMER PARTY HAVE CHAMPIONED
BOWL IN THE BUDGET AND
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR THE
PAST THREE YEARS AND I AM PROUD
TO BRING THIS FINAL PRODUCT TO
YOU TODAY. MOREOVER WE HAVE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STUDENTS OUR UNIVERSITY
SEGMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ACTUALLY GET
THIS RIGHT THIS IS A HISTORICAL
YEAR OF INVESTMENTS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD MAKE THIS THE YEAR WE
FINALLY CREATE A PATH. TO DEBT
FREE COLLEGE AS WELL THIS
BILL'S ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM HERE NINETEEN
NINES CENTER OF TROUBLE. MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AS CHAIR
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX EIGHTY
FORTY FIFTY SIX MODIFIES THE
EXISTING CAL GRANT AWARD
STRUCTURE TO EXPAND ACCESS AND
REMOVE BARRIERS. THE AUTHOR HAS
PUT IN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK ON THIS BILL WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE CAUCUS IS
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF HIS WORK. I
ASKED FOR AND I BET. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL. COMMENTS CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
QUESTION THE AUTHOR. SENATOR
WOULD YOU TAKE LEVEL WOULD YOU
TAKE QUESTION I WOULD LOVE A
QUESTION. SENATOR BREAUX THE
INJURED DURING THEIR ROLES
CONFIRMATION HEARING OF SOME OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD
MEMBERS WE RECENTLY TALKED
ABOUT A FRAUD SCAM THAT HAS
PENETRATED OUR- COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEMS ON THE GRANT
PROGRAM DO YOU THINK THE BILL
SHOULD ADDRESS ANYTHING ABOUT.
THE GRANTS THAT ARE BEING- THE
GRANTS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN UP
BY WHAT THEY CALL BOT STUDENT
CENTER WILL STUDENTS THAT ARE
APPLYING FOR GRANT FUNDING THEY
WERE OVER. THERE WERE SEVERAL
COLLEGES THAT HAD IDENTIFIED A
MISAPPROPRIATION OF FUNDS THAT
WENT TO WHAT THEY CALLED BOTS
OR NONEXISTENT STUDENTS AND I
KNOW THE BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS
THAT BUT I WAS JUST CURIOUS
ABOUT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT. SO
SINCE IT IS TOO LATE TO AMEND
THE BILL IF THAT IS ACTUALLY A
REAL PROBLEM WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY ADDRESS THAT WHEN WE
COME BACK IN JANUARY THANK YOU
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE AWARE OF THE PROBLEM OF
THE GRANTS. AT THE GRANT SCAMS
THAT WE HAVE GOING ON IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
A GREAT BILL PART OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE CAUCUS IT'S MY HONOR TO
BE A PART OF THAT CAUCUS. AND
IT'S THIS IS A VERY GOOD BILL
TO MOVE FORWARD BUT WE DO
REALLY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
GRANTS AND BEING DISPERSED TO-
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NOT REALLY
STUDENTS AND THAT ARE IN ROLE
TAKING UP SPACE IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN ACCESSING
RESOURCES. THIS A BODY
APPROPRIATE SINCE THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME MAKE THOSE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU CENTERMAN. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
PRESENTER- WE KNOW THAT. HIGHER
EDUCATION IS AT THE HEART OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM. AND AS A
FORMER UC PROFESSOR MYSELF I
KNOW THAT TOO MANY OF OUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND POST GRAD
STUDENTS- STRUGGLE WITH THE
STRESS OF STUDENT DEBT- I AM I
CAN'T BECAUSE MY WIFE AND I
JUST PAID OFF OUR STUDENT DID A
FEW YEARS AGO. AND STUDENT DEBT
LOADS ARE RISING DRAMATICALLY
DUE THE RISING COST OF TUITION.
AND ALL THE FEES AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH COLLEGE SO. WE
HAVE TO GET BACK TO DEBT FREE
COLLEGE THIS BILL TAKES A HUGE
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION BY
RECOGNIZING THAT TUITION. IS
ONLY ONE PART OF THE BIG MUCH
BIGGER PICTURES FOR STUDENT
COSTS INTO STUDENT. POTENTIAL
DEBT OVERLOAD- YOU KNOW PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT DIFFERENT COLLEGES
SOME KIND OF. ASPIRATIONAL
GREEN THAT CAN OCCUR. BUT IT
WASN'T UNTIL THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THAT WE ACTUALLY
STARTED IMPLEMENTING TUITION
AND ARE YOU SEASONS YES USE. I
THINK WE CAN GET BACK ON TRACK
AND AGAIN THIS BILL TAKES A
HUGE STEP IN THAT DIRECTION SO-
I HEARD AND I VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. KAREN SEEN NONE SENATOR
LABEL WHICH ELECT CLOSE TO SELF
RESPECT CLASS AND I HAVE A SHE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS EIGHT I BACKER HI FORGES
I BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM HI
CORTESE HI DALLY I DONT I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE ROVE HI HEARD
SPURRED BY WESTERN HI HER TADO.
I JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LABOR HI THE MOON HI WIRE.
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I- TELEVOTE HI PAM I
FOURTEEN TINO I ROCKED I REVERE.
HI SKINNER. HI STERN AMBERG HI
HI WE CASKEY I WINNER I WILL HI.
SENIOR LEVEL MOVES CALL MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO FOLLOWED A
ONE FIVE FOUR WE HAVE SENATOR
RUBIO SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AN ACT
RELATING TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALING SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
TODAY I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AP
AT THREE TWENTY. THREE TWENTY
HELP STUDENTS GRADUATING FROM
pNEWLY ESTABLISHED INSTITUTES OF
HIGHER EDUCATION BECOME
ELIGIBLE TO SERVICE PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS RECENT FLOOR
AMENDMENTS THAT DOUBLE JOINTING
LANGUAGE TO SP FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT A. B. THREE TWENTY WILL
RECTIFY CALIFORNIA'S TEACHING
SHORTAGE AND RESTORE EQUITY TO
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
SENATORS I BELIEVE TEACHERS
DESERVE THE BEST IN MY BOOK
THEY ARE SPACE JAM QUALITY
TEACHERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL OR IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING ENOUGH ROLL
CALL ON FILE I DON'T ONE FIVE
FOUR. HEARING C. NINE. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASUREPASSES BY MEMBERS
REMOVE IT ON TO FILE I DON'T
ONE FIVE SIX. SENATOR RALPH HE
IS PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY REACH A SOMEBODY FELL
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS CENTER ALL.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS IS
THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY THE BILL MAKES
CHANGES TO PHARMACY LAW ON
BOARD OPERATIONS. INCLUDING
EXTENDING THE BOARD'S
OPERATIONS BASED ON RECENT
JOINT SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
EFFORTS UNDERTAKEN BY THE
RESPECTIVE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES IN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY. YOU
KNOW WE HAD SOME TURBULENCE
DURING A RADIO SHOW THIS YEAR
WITH THE TWO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES. HE HAS TO MAKE
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO SUNSET
BILL PRACTICE CYCLING WHICH HAD
BEEN CAREFULLY CRAFTED- BY THE
TWO LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES. BUT
THANKS TO LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP IN THE CHAIRS OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES WE
WERE ABLE TO RESOLVE THE
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES HIT THE
RESET BUTTON AND THE LANGUAGE
NOW. IN THIS BILL. AND THE
OTHER ONE IN THE OTHER HOUSE
REFLECT WHAT WAS CAREFULLY
CRAFTED AND APPROVED BY THOSE
COMMITTEES THROUGH THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS WITH ONE
ADJUSTMENT IN THIS BILL. HAVING
TO DO WITH THE ENFORCEMENT
PENALTY FOR SOME VIOLATIONS.
AND A FEW MINOR CHANGES
REQUESTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN SUMMARY.
AMONG OTHER THINGS THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD TO BRING
AN ACTION FOR REPEATED
VIOLATIONS OF MATERIAL SIMILAR
PROVISIONS BY THREE OR MORE
PHARMACIES OPERATING UNDER
CALMER COMMON OWNERSHIP OR
MANAGEMENT WITHIN A CHAIN
COMMUNITY PHARMACY. AND THE
MEASURE INCLUDES OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PHARMACIES TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH PHARMACY LAW.
PRIOR TO BEING SANCTIONED I E.
A RIGHT TO CURE UNLESS THE
VIOLATION RESULTED IN ACTUAL
HARM TO ANY CONSUMER OR SERIOUS
POTENTIAL HARM TO THE REPUBLIC
TO THE REPUBLIC TO THE PUBLIC
SEES ME THANK YOU. RESPECTFULLY
AS FEAR OF A- ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINNER MELINDA'S THANK
YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS- YOU
PROBABLY HAVE NEVER HEARD THIS
BEFORE BUT MY PREDECESSOR WAS A
PHARMACIST- I DIDN'T I DIDN'T
THINK YOU'D HEARD THAT BEFORE
SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
YOU ALL KNEW- AND I WILL NOT BE
CHANNELING MY PREDECESSOR
HOWEVER AND I WILL KEEP THIS
VERY BRIEF AND JUST SIMPLY ASK
FOR YOUR EVENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT SENATOR
BREAUX. HOW DO YOU RESPECT MY
COLLEAGUE HIS PREDECESSOR WAS A
PHARMACIST IN ORDER TO CHANNEL
HE HURT HIS. INNER PERSON. HE
WOULD NEED AT LEAST FIFTY PAGES
OF NOTES THAT HE QUIETLY READ
ARE ABSOLUTELY READ THROUGH AND
THEN TURNED AND PLACED THEM ON
HIS SEAT AND THEN TURNED AROUND
AND READ THOSE NOTES AGAIN. SO
JUST A FEW COMMENTS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
OKAY ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HERE IN
CHINO AND SENATOR RALPH WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE-
THANK YOU. OKAY ANSWER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I HATE I BACKER. FIVE
PORCHES I BRADFORD I COME BY
IT- I CORTEZ C. I. DALI. I DON
I TORONTO I A COMMON GLAZER I
CONSULTED I GROW HI HURTS BURKE
I WAS SO. FIVE HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOUR I THE MON. I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I UNTIL ABOUT FIVE PM
HI PERSON TINO I. ROSS FIVE
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN AMBER
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
I. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE I DON'T
ONE FIVE SEVEN SENATOR WILKIE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. AT SOME LEVEL THREE
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAZE AN ACT RELATING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THROUGH
OPEN FOR GEORGE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT EIGHTY THREE NINETY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE IN
CHAD MAYES WHO'S NOT A
PHARMACIST REGARDING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
UNDER CURRENT LAW AN APPLICANT
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS CAN HAVE THEIR
BENEFITS TERMINATED IF THEY
SUBMITTED AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT. HOWEVER MANY
STATEMENTS EDT FLAGS ARE NOT
INTENTIONALLY INACCURATE BUT
INSTEAD MISSTATEMENTS OR DO. DO
DOOP CONFUSING FORMS. BUT THIS
IS WHAT CAUSED ALL OF OUR
OFFICES TO RECEIVE HUNDREDS OF
CALLS FROM BENEFICIARIES THIS
PAST YEAR WHO WERE LOCKED OUT
OF BENEFITS FOR ANYWHERE FROM
FIVE TO TWENTY THREE WEEKS.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY AN ACCEPTABLE
OUTCOME HE WENT SO WHEN SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE RELYING ON
THESE IMPORTANT ECONOMIC
LIFELINE BENEFITS. EIGHTY THREE
NINE SEVEN WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO SINK CLEAR NOTICE
TO CLAIMANTS IF F. F. ET DE HAS
IDENTIFIED THIS ISSUE WITH
THEIR APPLICATION AND ALLOW FOR
A RIGHT TO CURE. THIS
LEGISLATION DOES NOT CHANGE THE
AGENCY'S ABILITY TO INVESTIGATE
AND PROSECUTE FRAUD INSTEAD IT
CLARIFIES AND SIMPLIFIES THE
MAZE OF FORMS INDIVIDUALS MUST
NAVIGATE TO KEEP THEIR
BENEFITS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. LOVE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE- DEBATE ON
ASYLUM HERE IN CHINO AND THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
FOLLOWED A ONE FIVE ONE FIVE
SEVEN. HERE IN NC NINE ALL EYES
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIVE EIGHT. SENATOR RUBIO
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SERVE ON TESTS
AN ACT RELATING TO EVIDENCE
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT EIGHTY NINE THIRTY NINE
THE DENIM DAY ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
NINE FULFILLS THE PROMISE OF
DENIM DAY IN CALIFORNIA BY
PROHIBITING OF SURVIVORS.
MANNER OF DRESS FROM SERVING AS
EVIDENCE ASK CONSENT IN A COURT
OF LAW BY MAKING IT CLEAR THAT
THE SURVIVORS CLOTHING CANNOT
BE USED AS EVIDENCE. OF CONSENT
WE CANNOT HELP CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT FOR SURVIVORS TO
FEEL MORE EMPOWERED TO PURSUE
CHANGES AGAINST THEIR
PERPETRATORS PERPETRATORS
SENATE FLOOR AMENDMENTS. UP CO
AUTHORS AND DOUBLE JOINTING
LANGUAGE TO AVOID CHAPTER NOT
ISSUES SENATE COLLEAGUES
CLOTHING. DOES NOT PROVIDE
CONSENT FOR THAT REASON AND AS
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE ON EIGHTY NINE THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DESCRIPTION OR THE
BREAK ON THE SIDE OF. CURRENCY
NINE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS MEASURE. SHE NINE ALL EYES
THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PROCESS. MEMBERS THAT
WERE ON FILE I DON'T ONE FIVE
NINE. WE HAVE SENATOR BECKER
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ SOME LEVEL THREE
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUIS RIVAS AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE. SENATOR BOOKER
GOOD AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS EIGHTY THREE TWENTY SIX
REMOVES THE SUNSET DATE ON THE
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE OR D. M. H. C.
AFTER WAS TWO DECADES THE
CONSUMER PROGRAM IS NO LONGER A
NEW AND EXPERIMENTAL INVESTORS
NEED TO PING PONG BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN EXISTING AND NOT
IT'S A WELL DEMONSTRATED A
SUCCESSFUL TOOL PROVIDING
CONSUMERS AN IMPORTANT
ADVOCATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE ON A. B. THREE
TWENTY SIX. Q. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. HEARING AND SEEING
NINE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FOLLOWED A ONE
FIVE NINE. WITH ALAN. ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER I
FOR JUST NOW BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY. NO GOD
I DRAW SO I EGGMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HER TADO. I
WAS SO. JONES NO CAN MONITOR I
LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN. HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A TURBO
NO TEN HI FORTUNE TINO. HI ROSS
I REVIEW I SKINNER. FIVE STERNE
AMBER I WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER I
WILL KNOW. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. ALAN I
ADMIN WELL SO I STERN. MARCH
TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO. WE'RE GONNA
PAUSE FOR THE CAUSE. OUR
MEMBERS SHREWD BUT TO MOVE TO
AN FINISHED BUSINESS. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS HERE AND FIRST
UP IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY SIX.
FILE I AM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
ALAN ARE YOU PREPARED FOR YOUR-
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION ONE BY SENATOR
ALAN RELATIVE TO STUDENT LOAN
DEBT. CHIRALA. MEMBERS LAST
YEAR ONE CALLS ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO FORGET FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN
DEBT FOR STUDENT BORROWERS
ACROSS THE NATION- THE COST OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS RISING WE
NEED TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
WHETHER THEY WANT TO BE A
MANUFACTURER WHERE THEY WANT TO
OPEN THEIR OWN SMALL BUSINESS
WHERE THEY WANNA BE A COWBOY.
LET'S LET'S PASS THIS YEAR WENT
BY FAST TRAVEL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR DOLLAR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO STAND UP
IN OPPOSITION. I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF STUDENTS
OUT THERE. BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF DEBT IN AMERICA. AS YOU
KNOW THE NATIONAL DEBT IS TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR
EVERY MAN WOMAN AND CHILD IN
AMERICA WHY SHOULD WE SETTLE
THEM WITH MORE DEBT WHEN THEY
WERE THE ONES THAT GOT THE
EDUCATION. MAKES NO SENSE. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
I'M ALSO OPPOSE THE BILL BIT
MORE. MAYBE AT A THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL I'M I'M
KIND OF CONFUSED BY THE
CONVERSATION IS TAKING PLACE IN
AMERICA TODAY. THAT THERE'S
THIS PUSH FOR. THE GOVERNMENT
TO FORGIVE THE STUDENT LOANS.
WHEN IT'S- STUDENTS. UNDER THE
DIRECTION OR WITH COUNSEL WITH
THEIR PARENTS- ADULTS THAT ARE
TAKING THIS OBLIGATION UPON
THEMSELVES FRELY. THEY'RE
PURSUING EDUCATION AND A VERY
HIGH EXPENSE THAT SOMETIMES
COMES WITH A HIGH PAYING JOB OR
SOMETIMES DOESN'T. BUT THERE'S
NO COERCION- TO REQUIRE
SOMEBODY TAKE THIS DEAD UPON
THEMSELVES AND IN CALIFORNIA AS
A MATTER OF FACT IT'S ENTIRELY
POSSIBLE TO GET A HIGH QUALITY
FOUR YEAR DEGREE FROM EITHER
THE CSU SYSTEM OR THE UC SYSTEM
AND GRADUATE WITH LITTLE OR NO.
DEBT 30% OF AMERICANS GO TO
COLLEGE. AND PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION. IF WE FORGIVE THESE
LOANS IT'S TAXPAYER MONEY IT'S
AMERICAN OTHER AMERICAN DOLLARS
THAT ARE GOING TO PAY OFF THAT
DEBT. WHY IS IT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE 70% OF
AMERICANS THAT DON'T GO TO
COLLEGE TO PAY FOR THE COLLEGE
EDUCATION OF THE THIRTY
PERCENT. THAT DO GO TO COLLEGE.
MEMBERS I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE
COME BACK TO THESE CHAMBERS IN
A MORE CREATIVE FASHION NEXT
YEAR. AND FIND A WAY TO HOLD
THE COLLEGES ACCOUNTABLE
THEY'RE PUTTING THE CHILDREN
AND THEIR PARENTS INTO THIS
DEBT. I SEE CHILDREN ACTUALLY
TOLD BY THE TIME THEY GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE SO THEY'RE ADULTS-
TAKING ON THIS BURDEN. WHAT WHY
DON'T WE FIND A WAY TO REMOVE
THE GOVERNMENT OUT OF THE
PROCESS OF EVEN- SUPPORTING
THESE LOANS IN THE FIRST CASE
IN THE FIRST PLACE. A LOT OF
THESE HIGHER EDUCATION.
INSTITUTIONS HAVE HUGE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF ENDOWMENTS. WHY
DON'T WE REQUIRE THE COLLEGES.
TO BACK UP THESE LOANS WITH%
THEIR ENDOWMENT RATHER THAN
WITH TAXPAYER DOLLARS I URGE A
NO VOTE ON SJR ONE.THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
MELINDA THANK YOU SO MUCH- I
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
IF I MAY. GENERAL YOU TAKE YOUR
QUESTION TO HAVE ANSWERED IF
YOU HAPPY TOO THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'M SO CENTER I JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF THERE IS- IS THERE A
LIMITATION TO. WHO THIS WOULD
APPLY TO ANOTHER WORDS AND
SUGGEST FROM A DATE CERTAIN
GOING FORWARD DOES THIS APPLY
TO SAY SOMEBODY WHO GRADUATED
FROM COLLEGE IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND IS THERE SOME SORT OF
LIMITATION OR IS THIS APPLY TO
EVERYONE. SO THIS IS THIS IS
THIS APPLIES TO EVERYONE WHO
HAS IT IS FOR IS- EXISTING
STUDENT LOAN DEBT THIS IS THE-
THE PROPOSAL THAT IS CURRENTLY
BEFORE CONGRESS. OKAY AND DOES
IT APPLY ONLY IF YOU WENT TO A
STATE SCHOOL OR IS IT- PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS AS WELL. WITH BOTH.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THOSE QUESTIONS I'M ON MY OWN
TIME I JUST WOULD LIKE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT THAT THAT- YOU KNOW
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS SENATE
WHO'S ATTENDED COLLEGE PERHAPS
YOU WENT TO PRIVATE UNIVERSITY-
PERHAPS YOU INTO A VERY
EXPENSIVE UNIVERSITY OR
PERHAPS. YOU ARE WELL EQUIPPED
TO PAY BACK YOUR STUDENT LOANS-
YOU MAY HAVE CHOSEN TO DO SO
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME THAT. WE
WOULD ALL BE ELIGIBLE TO HAVE
THIS SUBJECT HE RAISED EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE FULLY CAPABLE OF
PAYING IT NOT TO MENTION THE
FACT THAT YOU COULD GO BACK.
YOU KNOW MANY I MEAN DECADES IF
SOMEBODY IS. EXTENDING THIS
LOAN OUT OVER YOU KNOW TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS PERHAPS LONGER
YOU ARE ERASING FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN DEBT FOR SOMEBODY
WHO COULD YOU KNOW VERY WELL
AFFORD TO PAY IT BACK RATHER
THAN ASKING THOSE AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM C. N. T. MENTION
WHO MAY HAVE NEVER ATTENDING
COLLEGE. AND ASK THEM TO PAY
FOR THE COLLEGE EDUCATION OF
SOMEONE WHO IS CERTAINLY ABLE
TO PAY FOR IT THEMSELVES SO I
WOULD URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION A VASE INTERNAL MAW.
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE S. J. R. ONE AS SOMEONE WHO
SPENT ELEVEN YEARS WORKING WITH
COLLEGE STUDENTS- I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT DEATH DOESN'T
NECESSARILY- IS NOT LIMITED TO
UNDER 500-005-0000 I WOULD NEED
STUDENTS THAT THROUGHOUT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY WOULD HIT
YOUR DEBT UP TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND HAND I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
DEBT RELIEF TO STUDENTS SOME OF
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE GOING TO
MOST BENEFIT FROM SOMETHING
LIKE THIS ARE MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES. ARE MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES IN THIS STATE WHO
DON'T QUALIFY FOR SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR AND
WHO DON'T HAVE FAMILIES THAT
CAN JUST WRITE A CHECK FOR THE
ENTIRE AMOUNT OF COLLEGE IN THE
ELEVEN YEARS I SPENT WORKING
WITH COLLEGE STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I ALSO SAW
THAT- MANY STUDENTS WHILE
TRYING TO JUGGLE A JOB. AND HAD
TO DEAL WITH THIS RAPID
INCREASE OF TUITION FEES BOOKS
HOUSING AND EVERYTHING THAT
COMES WITH A COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
WITH A GRADUATE UNIVERSITY SO I%
THINK THAT THIS RESOLUTION IS
VERY MEANINGFUL AND I DON'T
WANT US TO LOSE SIGHT THAT
EVERYONE BENEFITS FROM THIS
LOWER DEATH BENEFITS- ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS AND WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT UP TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
STUDENTS OR THEIR FAMILIES WILL
PUT IN THEIR PORTION. IT MEANS
THAT THIS IS A TYPE OF RELIEF
IF YOU READ THAT STR EIGHT UP
TO RIGHT FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IT'S A TYPE OF RELIEF THAT
BENEFITS THEM BENEFITS OUR
COMMUNITY OUR ECONOMY AND
ALLOWS FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF A
COLLEGE AND GRADUATE DEGREE SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BROKE. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER OUR CULTURE. MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION- THESE ARE OLD
TIRED ARGUMENTS AGAINST
RELIEVER RELIEVING. STUDENT
DEBT THEY'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
FIFTY YEARS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. NOT THAT FAR LONG AGO.
ANY PERSON IN THE UNITED STATES
COULD GO INTO BANKRUPTCY COURT
AND GET THEIR FEDERALLY
GUARANTEED LOANS. OR THEIR
PROPERTY PRIVATE STUDENT LOANS
DISCHARGED THE BANKRUPTCY
BECAUSE THEY MADE A SHOWING
THAT THEY WERE UNABLE TO PAY
BACK THE DEBT. AND IF SOMETHING
UNFORTUNATE HAPPENED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS
MAGICALLY WE SAID WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DISCHARGE FEDERALLY
STUDENT LOANS BECAUSE HIS
ARGUMENT THAT. THE GOVERNMENT'S
GOING TO PAY BACK OR PEOPLE
HAVE TO. HAVE RESPONSE HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY BUT- WE CUT OFF
THAT. AVENUE THE PEOPLE HAD TO
DISCHARGE THEIR STUDENT LOANS
YOU CAN MARK YOUR CALENDAR IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN
PEOPLE STARTED ACCUMULATING IT
DOESN'T WORK IT WASN'T WHAT
PEOPLE RAN IN THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT. DISCHARGED IF THEY
NEEDED TO HAVE THE RELIEF THEY
HAD AN OPTION. AND IN THE END
WE STILL- WE STILL- PRIDE
OURSELVES IN HAVING PEOPLE
HAVING ACCESS TO EDUCATION IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE THAT PROBLEM
GOT WORSE BECAUSE IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE CHANGES TO THE
UNITED STATES BANKRUPTCY CODE
RICK ALLOW THAT PRIVATE STUDENT
LOAN BANK OF AMERICA WELLS
FARGO EVERY BANK IN THE WORLD
COULD GIVE YOU A PRIVATE
STUDENT LOAN AND THAT IT WOULD
NOT BE DESTRUCTIBLE FOR EVER
FOR EVER YOU WERE STUCK WITH IT
IT IS A TRAGEDY THAT THAT IS
THE LAW OF THE LAND IN THE
UNITED STATES THE PEOPLE CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR FEDERAL
BANKRUPTCY COURTS. AND SEEK
RELIEF TO RELIEVE THAT SO WHAT
YOU HAVE NOW IS THE NUMBERS GO
UP A TRILLION A TRILLION FOUR
TRILLION FIVE AND ALL THIS
RESOLUTION DOES IT SAY LET'S
GIVE SOME RELIEF SOME AVENUE
FOR PEOPLE WHO CAN'T PAY BACK
THE MONEY WHO CAN'T PAY BACK
THE MONEY IN THE ACCESS IT'S A
TIRED ARGUMENT IT'S A IT'S NOT
FOUNDED IN IN ANY OF THE
ACADEMIC JOURNALS THAT HAVE
BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT THIS OVER
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO CHANGE AND
I WOULD URGE. THE RESOLUTION
HERE TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CAN JOIN IN THE CHORUS- VOICES
SAYING WE NEED TO GIVE THE
STUDENTS SOME RELIEF AND I
REGION EVER. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONS VADER JUST DISCUSSION
THIS ITEM SENATOR GROW. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR. YES SOONER- YOU TO
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY THROUGH THE
CHAIR DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
CHARGING AND CURRENT DEBT WOULD
CREATE A BUTTERFLY EFFECT. FOR
THE FUTURE. HI IF YES THROUGH
THE CHAIR I DO BELIEVE IT WOULD
CREATE A BUTTERFLY EFFECT IN
THE SENSE THAT BYE BYE HOPING
STUDENTS OUT WITH THEIR DAD. IT
WILL MAKE IT SO THEY'LL BE MORE
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO START A
BUSINESS TO BUY A HOME TO GET
THEIR LIVES ON MOVING. THE FACT
THE MATTER IS ONE OF THE BIG
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN SO MANY OF
US AND THE NEXT GENERATION IS
THAT THE AMOUNT OF DEBT THAT
THE NEXT GENERATION IS STARTING
TO ACCRUE JUST TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO HAVE A HIGHER
EDUCATION IS SO MUCH HIGHER.
THAN IT EVER WAS BEFORE AND IN
THE END OF THE DAY THAT IS
WHAT'S MAKING IT SO DIFFICULT
FOR PEOPLE TO REALLY START
THEIR LIVES AND PROVIDE THE
KIND OF ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO OUR
ECONOMY INTO OUR SOCIETY THAT
WE- THAT WE THAT WE WANT THEM
TO PROVIDE WHEN WE WHEN WE WENT
WHEN WE SENT THEM TO COLLEGE IN
THE FIRST PLACE JUST TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE THE AVERAGE GRAD HAD
NINETY THREE THOUSAND. THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WORTH OF DEBT
NOW IT'S OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS EVEN THOUGH THE
SALARIES HAVE ONLY GONE UP. A
LITTLE BIT SINCE THEN I'M SO
THAT WOULD BE THE BUTTERFLY
EFFECT RIGHT THE FACT THAT THIS
THIS- THIS THIS IMPACT- BY BY
BY BY GIVING MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO THESE YOUNGER PEOPLE WHO'VE
ACCRUED SO MUCH THAT. IT WILL
OPEN UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
TO REINVEST IN GAYS IN OUR
ECONOMY BUILD LIVES BUILD
BUSINESSES. AND- AND GIVE BACK
TO OUR SOCIETY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SPONSOR. THE
BUTTERFLY EFFECT IS A SMALL
CHANGE NOW WHICH READ RESULTS
IN A DRASTIC CHANGE IN THE
FUTURE. AND I THINK THAT THIS
SMALL CHANGE NOW TO DISCHARGE
COLLEGE DEBT- IS GOING TO
DRASTICALLY HURT US IN THE
FUTURE FINANCIALLY IN THE
REASON WHY IS BECAUSE- THE SAME
THING THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LAKE ELSINORE SAID. THAT YOU
KNOW THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
GRADUATE WITH THE TURN FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR DEBT- I KNOW
SOMEBODY WHO IS- WORKING ON A
DOUBLE LOT AGREE THAT. A LOT A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IS SOMETHING
ELSE AND- SHE ACTUALLY HAS A
JOB WITH SPACEX AND MAKES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
DISCHARGE THAT DEBT. WOULD JUST
BE- NOT RIGHT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO PAY FOR SOMETHING IN ORDER
TO BE- INVESTED. AND SO I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR TODDLE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- NOT TOO LONG AGO AT
NOT TOO LONG AGO MAYBE A FEW
YEARS AGO I WAS A SENIOR AT CAL
STATE SACRAMENTO AND JUST ABOUT
MY SENIOR YEAR OF COLLEGE- WE
HAVE THE DOWNTURN OF THE
ECONOMY AND THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS. AND THE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT THE IN THE DOWNTURN OF THE
ECONOMY HAD REAL IMPACTS ON ON
MY FAMILY AND ON MY EDUCATION.
I WAS THE FIRST TO GRADUATE
HIGH SCHOOL AND MY FAMILY BUT
ALSO THE FIRST TO ATTEND AND
GRADUATE FROM- A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY AND IN MY FAMILY.
AND I'LL SAY THAT. I DIDN'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO FILE-
MY STUDENT LOAN DEBT FOR
BANKRUPTCY WHEN I DID SO MY
SENIOR YEAR IN COLLEGE I MEAN I
HAD TO. MAKE SURE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET AND HELP MY FAMILY THAT.
TOOK ON CREDIT CARD DEBT. AND
THIS IS A STORY OF MANY
STUDENTS IN MY GENERATION AND-
THAT NOT ONLY HAD TO DEAL WITH
ONE RECESSION ANOTHER HAVING TO
DEAL WITH TOO ON TOP OF THE
FACT THAT THERE'S- STILL HAVE A
LOT OF DEBT. AND THAT GETS IN
THE WAY OF. EVERYTHING FROM
BUYING A HOME TO BUYING A CAR
TO EVEN APPLY UNDER BRENT BRENT
AT THE DEPARTMENT. IT'S THIS
HERE ACTUALLY IN JULY IT'S BEEN
OFFICIALLY TEN YEARS SINCE I
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY AS A
STUDENT. AND IT HAS GOTTEN IN
THE WAY OF SO MANY THINGS AND
OF ECONOMIC. SUCCESS FOR ME- SO
I THINK THAT THIS THIS THIS
RESOLUTION IS GOING TO
SIGNIFICANTLY SENT MESSAGE. OUT
TO THE STATION TO THE STATE- TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT. STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF ARE NOT GOING TO BE LEFT
BEHIND THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SUPPORTED AT THE WORKING TO
FIND A SOLUTION TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
AT. LIVING THE AMERICAN DREAM
SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. HEARING SEEN NINE
SENATOR ALAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I REALLY WANT TO THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SINGER FOR. FOR
BRINGING UP WHAT EXACTLY IS AT
THE HEART OF THIS THIS
RESOLUTION I MEAN THE END OF
THE DAY FOLKS WHO COME FROM
FAMILIES WITH RESOURCES DON'T
HAVE TO ACCRUE A LOT OF COLLEGEDEBT THEIR FAMILIES ARE ABLE TO
PAY FOR THEM TO GO TO COLLEGE-
IT'S ACTUALLY WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO ACHIEVE. ACCESS TO
UPWARD MOBILITY IN OUR SOCIETY
AXES WHICH IS ONLY PROVIDED BY
A COLLEGE DEGREE. WHO HAVE TO
STRETCH AND STRAIN TO BE ABLE
TO AFFORD A BASIC COLLEGE OUR
KIDS EDUCATION AND- FRANKLY
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING. THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS HAD TO DEAL WITH. I
JUST ISN'T OVER CASKEY
MENTIONED. PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS- THEIR COLLEGE
EDUCATION WITH HEAVILY
SUBSIDIZED. BY THE GOVERNMENT.
AND OUR PARTNERS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL HAVE
RECOGNIZED. HOW MUCH VALUE.
THEIR SOCIETY GAINS BYE BYE BY
INVESTING IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND MAKING IT SO THAT. STUDENTS
CAN GO TO COLLEGE. ARE
VIRTUALLY FOR FREE. BECAUSE
THEY REALIZE HOW MUCH BENEFIT
THERE IS FOR THEIR BROADER
SOCIETY FOR THEIR ECONOMY. FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET HIGHLY
TRAINED THEY CAN GO INTO THE
WORKFORCE THAT CAN BUILD
BUSINESSES THEY CAN BE
PRODUCTIVE. INSTEAD HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY OVER TIME WE HAVE
DECIDED TO SHIFT MORE AND MORE
OF A NORM IS DEAD BIRD INTO
YOUNG PEOPLE. AND IT'S HARMING
OUR ECONOMY AND IT'S ALSO
EXACERBATING UNFAIRNESS. I TRY
NOT TO BE- I TURN OUT TO BE A
PARTISAN PERSON BUT I CAN'T
HELP BUT FEEL AS THOUGH A LOT
OF OUR FRIENDS IN THE SIDE OF
THE AISLE ARE WILLING TO
SUBSIDIZE. SO MANY ASPECTS OF
OUR ECONOMY. AND SO MANY-CORPORATE INTERESTS- WHEN WE
HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
SIMPLY TRYING TO GET. ACCESS TO
THE AMERICAN DREAM. AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO GET THAT ACCESS
TO GET THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND TO DO SO IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T SETTLE THEM OF A
LIFETIME. OF DEBT BURDEN WHICH
MAKES IT SO MUCH HARDER FOR
THEM TO GET THEIR- FEET ON THE
GROUND. BY A HOME RACE THE
FAMILY BUILDING BUSINESS AND BE
PRODUCTIVE THAT'S WHAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS ALL ABOUT.
MEMBERS THIS IS ABOUT FAIRNESS
IS ABOUT ACCESS THIS IS ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE NOT. SADDLED WITH THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF DEBT FOR
THEIR ENTIRE LIVES JUST BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO GET A COLLEGE
DEGREE SO I'M WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU AND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE I'M
TWENTY SIX. ALAN. HI ARCHULETA
FIVE ATKINS I BAIT. NO BACKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T I COURTESY I DOLLY. NO
DODD. I ALSO HI A COMMON GLAZER.
I CONSOLIDATE. GONZALEZ FIVE
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WESTERN
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED. HI LLEVA I
THE MON HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S NO
MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO JOGO.
NO PAM HI PERSONS YOU KNOW HI
ROSS HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI WHAT CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL NO. ALWAYS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES. AND ITS CONCURRENCE-
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA TRY TO PLOW
THROUGH ANOTHER HOUR BEFORE
GOING TO WAR- DINNER AT FIVE
THIRTY AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO WORK FOR ANOTHER HOUR BEFORE
FIVE THIRTY DINNER SO IF YOU'RE
HUNGRY. FIVE FIVE TWENTY ALL
I'M SORRY. HI I'M- OH OH I'M
SORRY I DON'T KNOW OKAY. WELL
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO
WE'RE GOING TO. WE'RE GOING TO
DINNER IT IN TEN MINUTES. WE'RE
GOING TO TURN INTO MOTIONS
AROUND THE RESOLUTIONS RIGHT
NOW. SENATOR SENATOR SCANNER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION
ON FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN. YEAH THERE'S
MOTION TO RECONSIDER IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO RECONSIDERING
FOLLOWING ON NINETY SEVEN. C.
NINE. ME RECONSIDERATION IS
CRACKED THANK YOU FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT I FACE. HI
BECKER. I PORCHES I BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DOLLY. DOT HI TORONTO. I EGGMAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I HER TADO
HI JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LLEVA I THE MON HI WHERE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A TROUBLE. I PAM I
PERSON TINA. HI RALPH I RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN NUMBER I LIKE
HOW SKI. FIVE WINNER I WELL I.
SURGERY PLEASE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. TALLY EGGMAN JONES.
STERN. NIELSEN NOTED HI. PRICE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS TOO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS AND NOW
WE'RE GOING BACK TO MOTIONS OR
RESOLUTIONS CENTERS GLAZIER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR- I WOULD
REQUEST THAT A. B. FIFTEEN
TWELVE FILE AT A ONE SEVENTEEN
BE MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN MOVED
TO THE INACTIVE FILE TO THE
NOTE JUST ONE OF.
THE CARD
MEMBERS SO MUCH FOR THE FIVE
THIRTY DINNER BREAK WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE WITH UNFINISHED
BUSINESS SO. IF YOU'RE HUNGRY
GRAB SOME LETTERS ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU THIS
PRESS AT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORIZATION REMEMBER MCCARTY.
PLEASE MOVE A. B. SEVEN FIVE
NINE TO BE AN ACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU THE DUST WILL NOTE.
ANY OTHER UNFINISHED AS
SENATORS THE MOBILE. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE.
FILE SO ORDERED. ANY OTHER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AT THIS
TIME. SENATOR PRO TEM. NO OKAY.
REMOVE ACTION UNFINISHED
BUSINESS MEMBERS WERE HERE NOW
ON FILE I'M TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR LOTT MON. MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR LAMONT AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SOONER
LIMO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS DID YOU KNOW THAT
TODAY'S STAR TREK TEAM AND LIKE
SPOCK SAID WHEN SERVING ABROAD
THE USS ENTERPRISE LIVE LONG
AND PROSPER AND IN THAT SPIRIT
SP THREE SIX EIGHT REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS TO COMMUNICATE FOR
EVERY MONTH IN WHICH HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR USE AND UNTIL
CONSUMERS REACH THEIR FULL
DEDUCTIBLE FOR MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET COST. ASSEMBLYMEN
INSULATED AFFECTED DATE OF THIS
BILL BY SIX MONTHS WHICH
REMOVED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE OF
CENTER WORKERS. YOUR OKAY.
HEARING CENA MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM. TWENTY EIGHT TH. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASED. NO
BACKER. I PURCHASE NO BRADFORD
I HAVE I DON'T I PROTESTING I
DALLY NO DODD. I TORONTO HI
ADNAN LASER I CONSOLIDATE I
DROVE. NO HERZBERG FIVE WEST SO
I HER TADO I JONES. NO CAN
LONGER. HI LAYERED I PLAY A HI
THE MOON I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S.
NO MAN HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
TROUBLED NOPE PAN I FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG ALL
RIGHT I LIKE CASKEY FIVE WINNER
HI WELL NOW. R. K. HODGE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE. THE MINUTES
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE. SENATOR NEWMAN IS.
OKAY SOONER NEWMAN MADAM
SECRETARY MARY SENATE BILL SIX
SIXTY BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS SENATOR
NEWMAN SAID THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SB SIX SIXTY YEARS
BACK- FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM OKAY ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF. I WAS HEARING AND SEEING
NONE OF THEM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE I'M
TWENTY NINE. ALAN ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS I BASE. NO BACKER I
PURCHASED NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
I DON'T. NO PROTESTING I DALLY
NO DOT HI TORONTO. HI A COMMON
GLAZER NO CONSOLIDATES I GROW.
NO KURTZ BURKE. I WAS SO HYPER
TADO. FIVE JONES NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON HI
WIRE. I MELINDA'S. NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO- SHOW BOTH
KNOW PAM. I FORTINO HI ROTH. HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER
I Y. CASKEY I WINNER I WILL
KNOW. MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
UP TO MEMBERS. ALAN EGGMAN
STERN. FIVE TWENTY SIX NO
ELEVEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS
WROTE RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR
MELINDA IS WHAT PURPOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- BECAUSE I KNOW THE
MAJORITY LEADER HAS MISSED
HEARING THIS MOTION PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I
MAKING A MOTION TO WITHDRAW AS
C. R. FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR BASIN GENTLEMAN HAS BEEN
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR DAYS
SINCE THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY EVERYONE
WANTS THE VACCINE CAN GET ONE
THE DATA SHOWS 81% OF
CALIFORNIANS TWELVE AN OLDER
HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE
IN THE LA TIMES REPORTS KEVIN
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE NO LONGER
RISING. AS SHARPLY AS THEY ONCE
WERE IN MOST PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
MAJORITY LEADER- I HAVE INDEED
BEEN HAPPY NOT TO HEAR THIS
MOTION BUT I WOULD- ASKED THE
MEMBERS TO VOTE NO ON THIS YET
AGAIN. THANK YOUS CENTER
MELINDA'S IS ASKING FOR A VOTE
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN NO
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BATES I
BACKER NO PORCHES I BRADFORD NO
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW CORTEZ HE-
DALLY. I DON NO TORONTO.
TERRAZZO NO ADMIN LASER. NO
GUNS ALLAH'S NO GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG. NO WEST SO NO HER
TADO NO JONES I CAN LONGER. NO
LAYERED NO LLEVA NO LIMO OWN.
NO MCGUIRE NO MELINDA'S I MEN
NO NEWMAN NO NIELSEN I A TURBO.
HI PAM. NO FORTUNE TINO NO ROSS.
NO RUBIO. KNOW WHAT SKINNER.
SCANNER NO STERN AMBERG NO WAY
CASKEY NO WINNER NO WELL HI.
FIVE NINE KNOWS TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION TO WITHDRAW FAILS
MEMBERS NOW WE WILL SENATOR MAN
WE SAW THE MOTIONS AND THIS IS
ON THE MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS-
ESTHER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS-
PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE FIFTY ONE ASSEMBLY MET BILL
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AT THE REQUEST OF
THE OFFICE. THE TEST WILL NOTE
SENATOR RUBIO. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE ONE SIX TO THE
INACTIVE FILE THANK YOU THE
DEATHS FROM THOSE THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL MOTIONS OR
RESOLUTIONS AT THIS TIME.
HEARING CHAIN NINE MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW. BREAKING FOR DINNER
WE ASKED EVERYONE TO BE BACK AT
PROMPTLY AT SIX O'CLOCK WILL
LEAVE THE DOOR OPEN UNTIL SIX
O'CLOCK SO BE BACK PROPERLY.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
GET BACK ROLLING BECAUSE WE RUN
IT. KEEP THIS PARTY GOING YES
WE'RE WE'RE NOW I'M GOING TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO YOU HAVE
SENATOR DODD HE'S PRESENTING AT
THE FOUR NINE FOUR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT SENATOR DODD MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I AM
SURE THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO ONE
THAT IS BINGE WATCHING THESE
SESSIONS DUE TO THE QUALITY AND
THE QUANTITY OF THE FLOOR
SPEECHES. HOWEVER IF B. FOUR
NINETY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. WHEN THIS BILL LEFT
THE SENATE IT ADDED THE
DELAWARE HANDICAP TO THE GROUP
OF OUT OF STATE HORSE RACES
THAT ARE EXEMPT FROM THE FIFTY
DAY RACE LIMIT. IN THE SAME WAY
THEY AMENDED THE BILL. WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING
SPECIFICALLY. THE BILL REQUIRES
OF THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS. AND TRAINING
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO IMPLEMENT A
COURSE OF INSTRUCTION FOR THE
TRAINING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. IN THE USE OF
ADVANCED INTERPERSONAL
COMMUNICATION SKILLS. IT
REQUIRES A COURSE IN SCIENCE
BASED INTERVIEWING. TO BE
INCLUDED AT THE ROBERT PRESLEY
INSTITUTE OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. ALRIGHTY SIR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IN REGARDS
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO.
APPEARING SEEN ON MOUNT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA HI ADKINS I BAIT
I BACKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM CORTEZ HE I DAILY.
I DONT I TORONTO EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. WEST SO HI
HER TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN
I NIELSEN I TRIED BOTH. PAM I
POURED TINA HI RALPH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER I STERN I'M BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI. I WINNER. I WELL
I. CENTERED ON MOVES TO CALL
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
FALL ITEM THIRTY THREE. WE SEE
CENTER HURTADO AS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ
SENATE BILL EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO OIL AND GAS WELLS
SOONER TITLE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE SP
EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AROUND
ORPHAN WHAT REMEDIATION AND
GIVES US. A BETTER PICTURE OF
WHAT EQUITY IN WATER MEDIATION
CAN AND SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY REQUIRED CONSIDERATION
OF SP EIGHTY FOUR REPORTING AND
PRIORITIZING WHILE RUMINATION
AND ADDRESS CHAPTER IN COMPLEX.
KOMPLEKS WORKED OUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. NOT IN SUNDAY SCHOOL
LIKE THE GOOD OLD DAYS- BUT YOU
KNOW THE BILL HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION AND HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND WE HOPE
YOU CAN JOIN ME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL
ON THIS MEASURE. CENTER I'M
BURT. THE QUESTION OF- CENTERED
BOTTLE. SHOULD WE TAKE
QUESTIONS. YES SO THE CENTER
TOTALED MY GOOD FRIEND OUR GOOD
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE FROM
LOCKING OUT OF FRANKLIN RAGES
DESCRIBES BILLS AN ICE CREAM
SUNDAE IS THAT CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
MMHM REMOVE SUSPECT THERE
AREN'T ANY OTHER DISCUSSION A
BIT ON THE SIDE AND SENATOR
ALAN. WITHOUT QUESTION THE
AUTHOR CENTER WE TAKE A
QUESTION YES SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OIL AND GAS WELLS
HAZARDOUS AND ITEMS ARE DID
WELLS AND FACILITIES.IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THIS IS I GOT THIS
BILL IS REALLY A ALMOST A ROMEO
AND JULIET- COMING TOGETHER TO
DIFFERENT KINDS OF FAMILIES TO
DIFFERENT- SERVE- GROUPS I JUST
HOPE THAT THE BILL DOESN'T END
UP QUITE A TRAGICALLY WE DO WE
DO YOU DO YOU THINK THAT SEVEN
THIRTY COMMENTS ON THIS. IF I
MADE THROUGH THE- YES YOU MAY
RESPOND I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S
NOT LIKE ROMEO AND JULIET
BECAUSE THAT IS A SIN AND THIS
MEASURE HERE. IS IT'S EASY FOR
EVEN A SUNDAY SCHOOL TEACHER TO
SUPPORT SO. JUST TO CLARIFY
THEY DO GET MARRIED IN THE- SO-
THERE'S A FRIAR INVOLVED IN
EVERYTHING ELSE. BUT LEAVE THE
DOOR OPEN ON OUR CURRENT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING C. NINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I
HATE. BACKER HI FORTUS HI
BRADFORD HI I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I TALLY. I DON FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROW. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED BY LABOR
I THE MOON. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON I WILL GO.
PAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINO. I. ROSS
I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG HI HI LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL I. ALL RIGHTS TO
CENTER HER DAUGHTER MOVED TO
CALL. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX.
SENATOR UMBERG HE'S READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL TWO ELEVEN BY SENATOR
UMBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
ATTORNEYS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
TRADITIONALLY THIS IS THE
ANNUAL STATE BAR FEE BILL WHICH
IS NOT PARTICULARLY
CONTROVERSIAL BUT SOMETHING HAS
CHANGED THIS YEAR ONE THE
HOUSEWIVES OF BEVERLY HILLS AND
TO TOM GIRARDI- IT IS AS SOME
OF YOU MAY HAVE SEEN. THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN ISSUES
CONCERNING THE INVESTIGATORY
ABILITY AND DILIGENCE OF THE
STATE BAR AND THEN ALL KIDDING
ASIDE THAT WAS EXPOSED THROUGH
THE EVENTS SURROUNDING THE
BAKUL OF TIME GIRARDI AND IN
HIS LAW FIRM- IT WAS APPARENT
THAT. THERE HAD BEEN HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE THAT WERE VICTIMIZED
OVER THE COURSE OF MANY MANY
YEARS VICTIMIZED ONCE FOR
EXAMPLE AS THE VICTIMS OF A
PLANE CRASH OR SOME OTHER HUGE
TRAGEDY THEN SECONDLY. BY
LAWYERS WHO STOLE THEIR
SETTLEMENT. AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THERE WAS AN
AUDIT WHICH HAS NOT BEEN SHARED
WITH US BUT THIS BILL PROVIDES
FOR STATE AUDIT NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO IS THAT THERE HAD
NOT BEEN A CHIEF TRIAL COUNSEL
IN OTHER WORDS THE PERSON
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS. IN THE
STATE BAR FOR FIVE YEARS IN THE
BILL REGIONALLY SAID AFTER HIS
MODIFIED THAT THERE BE NO BAR
DUES UNTIL THE STATE BAR
NOMINATES THE CHIEF TRIAL
COUNSEL TO FILL THAT ROLE. SHE
TRUCK COUNCIL HAS TO BE
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE- THEY
HAVE NOMINATED CHIEF TRIAL
COUNSEL I KNOW THE PERSON TALK
TO THE PERSON'S PERSONAL
QUALITY- ALTHOUGH NOT CONFIRMED
BY THE SENATE AND WILL NOT BE
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE BY
SEPTEMBER THE TENTH I TRUST
THAT WE WILL CONFIRM HIM. AND
SO THUS WE PUT THE MONEY BACK
IN- THERE ARE SOME OTHER
CHANGES TOO IN TERMS OF THE-
STATE THE LEGAL SERVICES TRUST
FUND COMMISSION PROVIDES THE
TWO COMMISSIONS WILL BE
APPOINTED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE INTO BY THE SPEAKER
OF THE ASSEMBLY- THE ACTUAL.
AMOUNT OF THE DUES WILL BE THE
SAME AS LAST YEAR- I URGE AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
OKAY ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. OKAY ON
HEARING SEEN NONE AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL. ALL THIS IS
ELIZABETH YES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING AN OUNCE
ROLL CALL ON FILE I'M THIRTY
SIX. HEARING SEEN ON AUGUST
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS AS ZERO THE
MEASURE TO DATA AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR LEYVA SHE'S
PREPARED. MADAM SECRETARY YOU
CAN READ IN ABOUT TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT CENTER LEVEL THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS TO
SEVENTY EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY REFLECT
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKE CHANGES TO
THE GO FORWARD PAYMENT PART OF
THE BILL AND SEEK TO PROTECT
PROTECT AGAINST MALFEASANCE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ESPECIALLY
ASKED FOR AND I BOTH. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THE SIDE OF. C. NINE FROM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS I FACE.
BACKER ALL RIGHT FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD HI BYRON I PROTESTING
HI DOLLY. I DONT HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HYPER TADO. I JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE ON I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN.
5% YOU KNOW HI RALPH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG ALL
RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. HI. THIS MAN PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. FAITH HI
ADNAN STERN GROSS. NO DOUBT HI.
ALL EYES THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
SOME OF THE MOMENTS ARE CURTIN
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO FALL ITEM THIRTY ONE
HELLO SENATOR RAZA THAT'S SHE'S
PREPARED MENTOR TERRY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
BY SENATOR ALSO AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SENATOR
RUSSELL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY NARROWED
THE BILL FROM A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM TO A TEN YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT THE
TEN YEAR PILOT PROGRAM WILL
pENABLE THE LACC D. TO
REPURPOSE. UNDERUTILIZED REAL
PROPERTY OR EXISTING FACILITIES
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THROUGH JOINT
OCCUPANCY ARRANGEMENTS THE
PROVISIONS F THIS BILL ARE
PERMISSIVE THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION EXCEPT FOR LED
ZEPPELIN THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM HERE AND
SEEN NINE. MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
I'M THIRTY ONE. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE EIGHTHS
NO BACKER HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD
I HAVE ITEM HI CORTEZ C. I.
DALI. GOD I TORONTO I EGGMAN
GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WEST SO
I HER TADO I JONES NO CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOR HI
THE MON I WHERE I. MELINDA'S NO
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. KNOW
WHAT YOUR VOGUE HI PAM. FIVE
FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT FIVE
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I STERN I'M
BERG HI MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. HI MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUTS A MEMBER. DALLY.
EGGMAN STERN. PRICE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS SIX THOSE IN THE MOMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN NON MEMBERS
WERE GONNA MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT NO WE'LL PASS
ON THAT AND MOVE TO FILE EINEM
THIRTY NINES. WE WERE GOING. TO
COMING BACK FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
AND WILL BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR WIN MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR STERN AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SENATOR WIENER I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR STERN. SP THREE
SEVENTEEN IS BACK ON HER
CURRENT SINCE AN IMPORTANT
STEP. FORWARD BECAUSE IT
ENSURES THAT AN INCOMPETENT
DEFENDANTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
SAME TIME SERVED CREDITS FOR
GOOD CONDUCT AS ANY OTHER
DEFENDANT. AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY DO A COUPLE OF THINGS
OUR FIRST- CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS OF THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO MISDEMEANOR CASES-
AS WELL AS OTHER TECHNICAL-
AMENDMENTS. OF THE BILL HAS NO
FORMAL OFFER A POSITION SIMILAR
TO A BABY GRAND PIANO BECAUSE
WHAT'S NOT TO LOVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I DON'T.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF FALLEN THIRTY EIGHT TH
ALAN. I ARCHULETA FIVE ACTIONS
I BASE NO BACKER HI FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I
PROTESTING I DALLY. I DON. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HURTS
BERG HI WEST SO HI HER TADO. I
JONES NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LIVE ON I LIVE ALONE I WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO- SHOW BOTH I CAN I
PORT IN CHINO HI ROB I. RUBIO.
I SKINNER. I STERN ON BERG I AM
FIVE FOUR CASKEY I WINNER I
WILL KNOW. PLEASE CALL THAT'S A
MEMBER. PORCHES EGGMAN STERN.
FIVE THIRTY TWO. KNOWS FIVE THE
SEMI SO SIMPLY MEMORABLE
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
THIRTY NINE WE HAVE SENATOR PAN
HE'S READY TO GO MADAM
SECRETARY MARIE SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR PAN
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. SENATOR GRAHAM THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS- SP
THREE TWENTY SIX IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE WHICH INCLUDES THIS
BILL INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT ACA
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW SO THAT
CALIFORNIANS GIVE ACCESS TO
PEOPLE ACTUALLY KNOW HOW TO USE
STETHOSCOPES. THE SEVENTY MM
IT'S POLITE TO THE BILL TO
HEALTH INSURERS AND AVOID
TAPPING OUT ISSUES ARE STRICTLY
AS PER NIGHT AT. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION IS BASED ON
THE SIDE ON ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE SIDE
OF HEARING SEEN NINE. MEMBERS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ON FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE. HEARING SHEENA EYES
THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS ZERO THE
SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
AND- NOW MOVING ON TO YOU. FILE
I'M FORTY. SIX SENATOR JOHN
SHE'S REPAIRED MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ SENATE BILL FOUR
HUNDRED BY SENATOR JONES AN ACT
RELATING TO HOMELESS CHILDREN
AND YOUTH CENTER JONES. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT A SENATE BILL
FOUR HUNDRED HAS FILED A
MARCHING BAND BACK OVER FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WAS SOME
AMENDMENTS. AND US SENATE BILL
FOUR HUNDRED REQUIRES A
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT TO SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
ASSISTING HOMELESS STUDENTS
ESTIMATES INCLUDE THOSE
PROPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO REDUCE COSTS AS WELL
AS CHATTERING AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DATABASE SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU I STRONGLY-
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
HUNDRED I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL ENSURING THE
IDENTIFICATION OF HOMELESS
YOUTH THROUGHOUT REACHES SIMPLE
IT'S EXTREMELY SIMPLE IT'S NOT
LIKE THE OPENING CEREMONIES. OF
THE OLYMPICS SO WITH THAT I
URGE RIVAL THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE SIDE OF. IN NINETEEN NINETY
SENATOR JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. AS A PATIENT AND I WILL.
ALL RIGHT THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR YOU TO MANAGE ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
ANNOUNCER- CALL ON FILE I'M
FORTY. HEARING SEEING NINE OZ
THIRTY EIGHT. KNOWS IT WAS ZERO
THIS ONLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
AND NOW MOVING FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE SENATOR CAFIERO SHE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOUR OH NINE
BY SENATOR CAFIERO AN ACT
RELATING TO PHARMACY CENTERED
OVER HERE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS BEFORE- NINE IS
BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND
ASSEMBLY ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
A HEARING SCENE NINE MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW
AND THROW CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON FILE I'M FORTY
ONE. AND NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS ZERO THAT CERTAINLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND
MEMBERS MOVING TO FILE I'M
FORTY TWO SENATOR WHY BECAUSE
HE HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
CENTER WALK US THROUGH THE
FLOOR'S YOURS IS PRESENT- SP
FOUR THREE TWO IS A SMALL
FOLLOW UP BILL TO ONE OF MY
PRIOR BILLS WHICH MADE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE ELECTIONS
IN THE HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS
THERE WERE- FINE TUNING
LANGUAGE THAT WAS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY AMONG OTHER THINGS AS
BEFORE THREE TWO RESTORES THE
ABILITY OF A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION. TO HAVE BOARD
MEMBERS TERM LIMITS SO LONG AS
THIS IS INCLUDED IN THERE-
ALEXION RULES AND I CAN IMAGINE
GROUCHO MARX BEING TOLD BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE H. AWAY THAT
YOU GOT TERM LIMITS YOU CAN'T
RUN HE'D SAY. PLEASE ACCEPT MY
RESIGNATION I DON'T WANT TO
BELONG TO A CLUB THAT WOULD
HAVE ME AS A MEMBER. WITH THAT
I WOULD URGE AND I BOTH. GREAT
IDEA ANYWAY- ANY FOR THIS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM HEARING SENA MEMBERS
THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
KNOW THROW CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING OUR
UNIONS ROLL CALL TO THIS ITEM.
DURING C. NINE HIGHS THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO. THE SIMPLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
MEMBERS REMEMBER TO FOLLOW I'M
FORTY THREE CENTER HEARD FIRST
REPAIRED MADAM SECRETARY. AT
ABOUT FIVE THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
SENATOR HERTZBERG MAN O.
MANISCHEWITZ THIS BILL TOOK A
LOT OF TIME DEALS WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP NINETEEN
IT'S BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
MAKING THREE POINTS CLARIFYING
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
INTERGENERATIONAL PROPERTY
TRANSFERS REFINING WHICH LEGAL
PARCELS UNDER QUOTE THE TERM OF
THE FAMILY FARM IN THREE MAKES
OTHER IMPORTANT TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT BROUGHT A LARGE
COALITION TOGETHER ALL I CAN
TELL YOU IS WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR FROM B. BRAUN THIS FELT
LIKE THE PRINCESS AND THE FROG
AND I DON'T KNOW WHO TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
DALLY. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I THANK THE GOOD
SENATOR. FOR PUTTING UP WITH ME
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT A
FAMILY FARM REALLY IS AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT- AS A
THIRD GENERATION FARMER- IN
THIS PROPOSITION WE DEFINED AND
THEN THIS THIS LANGUAGE HERE
WILL ACTUALLY- ALLOW THE
ASSESSORS AND THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION TO UNDERSTAND. HOW
IT SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED SO I
WANT TO THANK- THE FIREFIGHTERS
AND THE FOLKS WHO WERE. IN THE
TRENCHES WITH. THE SENATOR
WORKING ALONGSIDE US TO GET
THIS RIGHT THIS IS GOING TO BE.
VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN KEEPING
FAMILY FARMERS ON THEIR FARMS
IN THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
PASS THEIR LAND ON TO THEIR
CHILDREN- IN A REALLY TOUGH
ENVIRONMENT THIS THIS THIS
EXCLUDES. ALL CORPORATE FARMS
THERE ARE GOING TO BE. IN A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY AS THEY
SHOULD BE BUT THIS WILL
DEFINITELY HELP- THOSE OF US
WHO ARE TRULY FAMILY FARMER SO
I WANT TO JUST THANK THE- GOOD
CENTER FOR KEEPING HIS WORD.
AND WORKING VERY HARD AND I
WOULD LIKE TO. ENCOURAGE AND I
VOTE ON SP FIVE THREE NINE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF A HEARING SAYING
ON SOONER FOR WHICH ARTICLES. I
VOTE FOR THE PRINCESS AND THE
FROG VIVO YEAH RIGHT- MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
NO. USABLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEN NONE HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
AND NOW MEMBERS REMOVING TO
FALANDO FORTY FOUR SENATOR
CORTESE IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL FIVE SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
CORTEZ SEE AN ACT RELATING TO
HOSPITALS. SENATOR FOR GEORGE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS
SO I THOUGHT BY THIS TIME THIS
EVENING WILL BE A LOT CLOSER TO
THE FINISH LINE- THROUGH NO
FAULT OF YOUR OWN OF COURSE SP
FIVE SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES TO
PUBLIC BECAUSE BUBBLES IN MY
DISTRICT- CONNOR HOSPITAL SANTA
CLARA VALLEY MEDICAL CENTER.
WITH A REASONABLE EXTENSION OF
TIME TO ACHIEVE FINAL SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE UNFORTUNATELY
THEY'RE NOT AT THE FINISH LINE
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY IMPLEMENT SUGGESTIONS
PROVIDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION FORMALLY OFSHE PART
REGARDING THE ORIGINAL TUNE
AFTER DYLAN EXTENSION AS WELL%
AS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE HOSPITAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT THE BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION. I. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I BOTH THANK YOU.
CANIT HE FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING SAYING ON
MEMBERS THIS AS WELL AS-
ELIGIBLE FOR. THE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THE PIPELINE IS
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THE SIDE
OF. HEARING C. NINE OZ THIRTY
EIGHT. KNOWS IT ZERO THIS
FAMILY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
AND- NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY FIVE SENATOR JONES. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATING
TO FOSTER CARE CENTERS JONES
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS SP FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
WILL REQUIRE RESOURCE FAMILIES
ALSO KNOWN AS FOSTER PARENTS.
TO BE TRAINED ON HOW TO CARE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH. RISK OF
EXPERIENCING CHILD LABOR
TRAFFICKING AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
MARY POPPINS IS SOMEWHAT OF A
FOSTER PARENT. AND SHE SAYS
THAT THESE A SIMILAR AMENDMENTS
MAKE MAKE THE BILL PRACTICALLY
PERFECT IN EVERY WAY. I ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. MMHM. ALL RIGHT
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON THIS ISSUE. HEARING
AND SEEING ON MEMBERS THIS TOO
IS ALL DOUBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING OUR YOU KNOW
THROW CALL ON THE SIDE OF.
HEARING SAYING NINE OZ THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS IT ZERO. THE
CINEMAS ARE CONCURRED IN NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR HERTZBERG ONCE AGAIN.
DEFENSE SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE. CENTERED
FOR THE CONCURRENT AMENDMENTS
MAKE MINOR CLARIFYING CHANGES
ADDRESS TRAPPING ISSUES AND
TAKE ON THE EXTRAORDINARY TASK
OF FINDING NEMO ASKED FOR I'VE-
MMHM. ALL RIGHT- ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN C. NINE MEMBER
SINCE TWO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS ANY
PROBLEM WITH APPLYING OUR YOU
KNOW INTRO CALL TO THIS ITEM.
HEARING C. NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT
MILLS ZERO. THE SCIMITAR
CONCURRED IN NOW MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY FILE ITEM FIFTY WE
HAVE. ALL RIGHT. FORTY EIGHT
I'M SORRY. I WAS. PART WE AVE
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT SENATOR
WHAT IS STILL. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR WEST SO
AN ACT RELATING TO COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT THROUGH A SO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SANDERS
DOES ANYBDY REMEMBER SKY MALL.
SKY MALL USED TO BE A COMPANY
THAT EVERYBODY'S HEARD OF AND-
IF YOU FLEW UNIT SKYMALL WELL
IF YOU REMEMBER SCAM ALL YOU
PROBABLY REMEMBER REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES AS WELL THAT NO
LONGER. EXISTS THAT HAVE KIND
OF GONE THE WAY OF THE SAME
COMPANY BUT- BELIEVE IT OR NOT
LIKE- SKYMALL STRUGGLING TO
STAY IN BUSINESS AS
REDEVELOPMENT OF SOME COMPANIES%
ARE STILL HAVE DEBTS TO THEIR
COUNTIES. THIS BILL. HELLO IS
BACK ON- CONCURRENCE WHICH
WOULD HELP TO PROTECT THE
FISCAL SOLVENCY OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES BY ALLOWING THEM TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RE NEGOTIATE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF DEBTS.
ACCRUED THROUGH THEIR CAREER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY- THIS
BILL. AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY HELP GIVE CITIES MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND ADDEDCO
AUTHORS. HI THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE SONIC ITEM HERE AND SEEN-
MEMBERS THIS TOO IS EIGIBLE
FOR THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
ITEM. SHE NINE HEARING ON ICE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IT ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW TO FOLLOW
ITEM FIFTY DOCTOR PAN HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY MARY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. AND
ACTUALLY IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SURE CAN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS THE
CANADIAN HEALTH PROBLEM THIS
BILL IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS MADE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO CONFORM TO
EXISTING LAW RELATED TO ONE OF
THE PROVISIONS. OF THIS BILL
REGARDING OPIOID AGONIST TO
TREAT OPIOID OVERDOSES AND ALSO
BRINGS BACK THE LION KING
ESPECIALLY AFTER NIGHT BUT. ALL
RIGHT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSIONS.
OUR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE MEMBERS
THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
KNOW AND THROW CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM HEARING SEEN ON ICE THIRTY
EIGHT. KNOWS IT IS ZERO. THIS
IN THE MOMENTS ARE COMPARED AND.
NOW WE'RE GOING BACK A LITTLE
RETRO FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN
TIME- WE'RE DOING. THIRTY FIVE.
THIS IS A REALLY MEMBERS THIRTY
FOR ME FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
AND THIRTY FIVE SENATOR MCGUIRE
HE'S PREPARED. AND CLARK YOU
MAY RE. SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT
RELATING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION CENTER MCGUIRE.
AS IN THE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
THIRTY ONE SKIN ALLOW CALTRANS
TO TRANSFER THE BLUES BEACH
PROPERTY. ON COASTAL MENACING
COUNTY TO A NONPROFIT AGENCY
ORGANIZED BY THREE NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND THEN
SECONDLY SIMPLY INCLUDE
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP AND CLARIFY
THE PROPERTY WILL BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION BY LOCAL NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AT NO COST TO
THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN C. NINE
MEMBERS THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLY
ARE UNITED FOR- CALL TO THIS
ITEM FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR HERE
AND SEEN- EYES THIRTY EIGHT.
NOES ZERO THE SIMPLY MOMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE. SENATOR MCGUIRE AGAIN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE HURRY.
SENATE BILL TWO OH SIX BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. CENTER
MAGOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO A FINAL ONE
FOR THIS EVENING FOR ME SP TO A
SIX CANAL OUT TEMPORARY AND
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE PROTECTIONS.
PROVIDED IN THE STATE
FIREFIGHTER BILL OF RIGHTS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE SIMPLY
CLARIFY THE TYPE OF APPEALS
HEARING THAT WILL APPLY FOR
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN THE
STANDARD FOR THE BURDEN OF
PROOF. WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION A BIT ON THE
SIDE OF. DURING C. NINE MEMBERS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW
NATURAL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING OR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FOLLOW
I'M THIRTY FIVE. HEARING C.
NINE EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THE SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND.
ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO
CALL ON SOME OUTSTANDING ITEMS.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. FACE FOR JUST. NO
DALLY. EGGMAN GROVE. HERTZBERG
HI WEST SO. I CAN LONGER. I A
TROUBLED. STERN. ARE YOU TWENTY
NINE KNOWS FIVE THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED. NOW MEMBERS
MOVING TO FOLLOW ONE THREE
FIVE. FOLLOWING HIM ONE THREE
FIVE. M. SECRETARY. ATKINS I.
DALLY EGGMAN. GONZALES I WIRE I
NIELSEN. NO STERN. VICE.
CURRENT PRICE THIRTY SIX KNOWS
ONE. THE APPOINTMENT IS ON THE
MEASURES PASS.
ZERO THE MOTION
PASSES NOW FILE ITEM ONE THREE
EIGHT. FOR LOOKING CALL. EGGMAN
GONZALES HI MAGUIRE I STERN.
NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW. PRICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON.
TO ONE THIRTY NINE. CLICK TO
CALL. EGGMAN GONZALES I CHOIR I
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
IS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY. I AM SECRETARY FAITH. NO
GORGEOUS. DALLY EGGMAN JONES.
MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S. STERN
WILKE. HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS
TOO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW TO
FILE ITEM. ONE FOUR ONE.
ARCHULETA. ADKINS I EGGMAN
GONZALES I THE MON. HI MCGUIRE
I NEWMAN. ROTH. I STERN. MARCH
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES KNOWN TO FALL ON
ONE FOUR TWO. ATTENDEES I BASE.
EIGHT STATES NOW. EGGMAN
GONZALEZ I REQUIRE I STERN. ALL
EYES THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FALL INTO. ONE FOR
THREE. AT KINS I EIGHT. I
EGGMAN GONZALEZ I GROVE I WIRE
I MELINDA'S I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM. ONE FOUR FOUR.
ATTENDEES I AFTER. HI ADNAN
GONZALEZ I RICK MCGUIRE I
BELINDA'S I NEWMAN. NIELSEN
STERN. FIVE THIRTY SIX KNOWS IT
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. ONE
FOUR FIVE. ADKINS I EGGMAN
GONZALES I REQUIRE. I STERN.
FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL I DON'T ONE FORTY SIX.
ATKINS I EGGMAN GONZALEZ I
MCGUIRE I LANDIS I NIELSEN I
STERN. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY ALL EYES
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE I
DON'T ONE FOUR NINE. ATKINS HI
EGGMAN GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
MCGUIRE. I STERN. HIGHS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON FILE I DON'T
ONE FIVE TWO. AT KENS FIVE
PORCHES NO. EGGMAN GONZALEZ. I
WAS SO I WIRE HI STERN. ALL
EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS ONE
FIVE THREE FIVE ALL IN ONE FIVE
THREE. AT KINS HI ADNAN
GONZALES I REQUIRE HI STERN.
PRICE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING
BACK TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO.
UNDER UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALAN. HI
FORGES. I BY ADAM. I TORONTO HI
ADNAN GLAZER I HERTZBERG I. CAN
LONGER HI MELINDA'S I MEN I
NIELSEN I. OTERO VOGUE I TURN.
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONQUERED
AND NOW TO FILE ITEM. THIRTY
THREE. FAITH. EGGMAN GROWTH.
MELINDA'S OTRO VOGUE I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO
THOUGH SOME OF THE MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THAT COMPLETES
OUR CALL LIST. MEMBERS WE'RE
READY TO MOVE BACK TO SIMPLY
THIRD READING WE HAVE SEVERAL
ITEMS WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH
REAL QUICK SILVER GONNA START
WOULD FALL ITEM. ONE SIXTY. WE
HAVE CENTER OFFICE PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AN ACT
RELATING TO BUSINESS GENERALS
FAMOUS PRESIDENT THE BILL MAKES
VARIOUS TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
NON CONTROVERSIAL REFORMS TO
LAWS COVERING PROFESSIONS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS SUPPORT
SUPPORT VOTE I. ALL RIGHT ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS I DON'T. HEARING C.
NINE MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
YOUR HANDS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEN ON AUGUST
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE SIX ONE. THE SENATOR
CORTESE HE IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SENATOR CURTIS OR-
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SADDAM
IN MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB-
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAD TODAY
THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
ESTABLISH A PROCEDURE. TO
RELEASE INDIVIDUALS FROM
DETENTION THE FACE OF VIOLATION
OF PROBATION. TYPICALLY WHEN
ONE IS ARRESTED AND CHARGED
WITH A CRIME YOU'RE ENTITLED TO
SOME FORM OF PRE CHART PRE
TRIAL RELEASE. HOWEVER UNDER
EXISTING LAW IT'S UNCLEAR AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT A PERSON
DETAINED FOLLOWING AN
ALLEGATION. OF V. O. P. OR
VIOLATION OF PROBATION HAS THAT
SAME RIGHT TO BAIL AND OPTIONS
FOR ROOT FOR RELEASE ARE NOT
PRESCRIBED OR DESCRIBED. THIS
BILL WOULD ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
BY DIRECTING THE COURT TO
RELEASE PEOPLE DETAINED ON A
VIOLATION OF PROBATION PRIOR TO
THE FORMAL REVOCATION HEARING
UNLESS THEY FIND TAT THE
INDIVIDUAL POSE A THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY OR FLIGHT RISK.
LASTLY THE AUTHOR HAS WORKED AS
HARD AS THE BOBCAT. TERSELY ON
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVE THE
CHEAP PROVISIONS OFFICERS FROM
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY URGE-
I BOTH. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR NELSON. I URGE A
NO VOTE I'M GLAD THE PROBATION
OFFICERS OF A- COME AROUND ON
THIS A LITTLE BIT BUT- IT IS I
DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
OKAY. THIS IS MORE OF
DIMINISHING THE CONSEQUENCES
FOR YOUR BEHAVIOR. AND NOT
HOLDING YOU ACCOUNTABLE FOR
YOUR BEHAVIOR. THE. THIS SO
CALLED PROBATION VIOLATION. AND
THEY THEY'RE CREATING A
PRESUMPTION HERE THAT IT'S NOT
A BIG DEAL SO YOU'RE NOT SHOULD
NOT SUFFER ANY GRIEVOUS
SANCTION OR GREAT SECTION. NO
MATTER WHAT THE BEHAVIOR WATCH
AND THE IF YOU WILL THE
PLACEMENT SHOULD BE THE QUOTE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE. AND YEAH YOU
HAVE TO CONSIDER. SOME OF THE
BEHAVIOR. BUT THE PRESUMPTION
AND THE WAITING EITHER IT IS IN
FAVOR OF LENIENCY WE'VE GOT WAY
TOO MUCH OF THAT ND I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS A PLACE TO
DO IT PARTICULARLY WHEN THE
PROBATION SENTENCE IS THE LEAST
OF ALL SENTENCES. THE CRIMINAL
OFFENDERS FACE. AND IT IS
ALREADY THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THEM. TO DEAL
WITH. I WOULD PRETTY MUCH JUST
THE DUMBING DOWN THE- JUSTICE
SYSTEM BOTH IN LIFE THIS IS
ANOTHER BUILDING TO THE SAME
STUFF I HEARD A NOBLE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING CENA SENATOR
CORTESE WHICH ELECTRICALS. WE
URGE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM ONE SIX ONE. ALAN
I ARCHULETA ATKINS I FACE NO
BACKER. HI FORGES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A I PROTESTING HI DOLLY NO
DOT I TORONTO I EGGMAN LASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE NO HERTZBERG I
WENT SO. HI HER TADO NO JONES
NO KEN WALKER I LAYERED I
LABOUR HI THE MON FIVE MCGUIRE
I MELINDA'S NO MEN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO TROUBLE NO PAN I
PERSON TINA HI RALPH HI RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER. FIVE STERN ON
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI. HI WINNER
I WILL NOW. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA. GORGEOUS NO EGGMAN
LASER NO MAN. STERN. MARCH
TWENTY FIVE NOTES ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE I DON'T
WANT SIX TO SENATOR LEARNERS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HAND AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT THRILLER TO FLOOR
CHURCH THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
BY SENATOR JACKON. WHICH
EXPANDED THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHTS ACT TO APPLY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH FIVE TO
NINETEEN EMPLOYEES. UNDER THE
PROGRAM THE EMPLOYER EMPLOYEES
WOULD NEED TO REQUEST MEDIATION
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF RECEIVING
THE RIGHT TO SUE NOTICE-
HOWEVER CURRENTLY EMPLOYERS DO
NOT RECEIVE A COPY OF THEIR
RIGHT TO SUE NOTICE UNTIL AFTER
THE LAWSUIT HAS BEEN FILED
UNDERMINING THE ENTIRE PURPOSE
OF THE MEDIATION PROGRAM. THIS
BILL CORRECTS THIS BY REQUIRING
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING TO
NOTIFY THE EMPLOYER THIS ALLOWS
ENOUGH TIME TO PROCEED WITH
MEDIATION OTHER SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES I ASKED FOR MY PHONE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF SENATOR LEVEL. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MAY I ASK A
QUESTION OVER THE FLOOR MANAGER.
YOUR LAWYER WILL YOU CHECK THE
QUESTION. IS WHO WAS THE CHAIR
THANK YOU SIR SO THIS BILL
SIGNED INTO LAW HOW WOULD IT
WORK TO MEDIATE JUST ONE CLAIM
IF THE WORKER HAD MULTIPLE
CLAIMS FOR EXAMPLE WHAT IF THE
WORKER ALSO HAS A GENDER
DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS OR EVEN A
DISABILITY CLAIM- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION. AND I HAVE TO
SAY FIRST. BOB ARNOT
SHAKESPEARE AND SHAKESPEARE DID
NOT WRITE CHITTY CHITTY BANG
BANG. BUT NOW THAT I HAVE SAID
THAT. LET ME RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION. WHICH IS THE MEDIATOR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND EMPLOYMENT IS TRAINED. AND
WILL- MEDIATE THE FAMILY LEAVE
CLIMB AND THEN DISMISSED THE
PARTY'S UNLESS THE PARTIES
VOLUNTARILY DECIDE THEY WISH TO
CONTINUE MEDIATION AT NO POINT
WOULD MEDIATION BE FORCED ON
THE PARTIES. IN THE EVENT THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE CLAIMS THE
OTHER CLAIMS ARE NOT IMPACTED
BY THE MEDIATION ANY ACTION
THAT AN EMPLOYER OR EMPLOYEE
WISHES TO TAKE ON THE OTHER
CLAIMS CAN CONTINUE OKAY I
THINK THAT ANSWERS IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM HEARING SEEN ON
CENTER ALERT WHICH ELECTRICALS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
TO FILE ITEM ONE SIX TWO.
ENCINO OBJECTION ALL EYES
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE I DON'T WANT SIX
THREE. CENTER TO A BLOG ARE YOU
PREPARED SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY
MARY. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL
AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
HEALTH CENTER TO A BOOK. MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY NINE AT HOT
DOG ON THE WRONG TALKING
POINTS. ONE MOMENT SORRY ABOUT
THAT. I DO. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB THREE ZERO NINE THIS
TIME ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. AB THREE OH
NINE WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A MODEL
REFERRAL PROTOCOL TO ADDRESS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS.
THE LEGISLATURE IS NO DOUBT
AWARE OF THIS TO DO MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA ONE THAT HAS BEEN
EXASPERATED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
EIGHTY THREE ZERO NINE
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO CONSULT WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AND EDUCATION
EXPERTS. TO DESIGN A MENTAL
HEALTH REFERRAL PROTOCOL FOR
VOLUNTARY USE BY SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE THAT SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
WILL HAVE THE RESOURCES. AND
TRAINING TO BETTER ADDRESS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
THIS BILL RCEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE AND ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SILENCING HEARING C. NINE
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS OR- CALL ANSWER ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLY OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO. FOLLOW
AT ONE SIX THREE. HEARING SEE
NO OBJECTION ALL EYES THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIX FOUR WE HAVE
SENATOR NEWMAN HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY REALLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- HI PLEASE RESENT A
B. THREE FIVE SIX ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PHILLIP CHEN. WE
EARLIER HAD A SPIRITED
DISCUSSION ON THE FUTURE THAT
VERITABLE AMERICAN CLASSIC THE
LAWN MOWER I'LL SAY IT AGAIN
THE LAWN MOWER. HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE THIS BILL- IS
ABOUT FEROCITY. AND THIS BILL
WOULD GRANT PHYSICIANS SURGEONS
DOCTORS OF PODIATRIC MEDICINE
OF USE FLASK IN ANOTHER STATE A
ONE TIME NON RENEWABLE AND
TEMPORARY PERMIT. TO USE FOR US
THREE X. RAY EQUIPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA THE CURRENT
CERTIFICATION PROCESS IS
OUTDATED AND TAKE SIX TO NINE
MONTHS TO OBTAIN THROUGH
PHYSICAL APPLICATIONS. WELL THE
SURGEON WAIT FOR THEIR PERMIT
CERTIFICATION THIS BILL WOULD
ENABLE THEM TO USE FOR US BEEF
FOR UP TO TWELVE MONTHS A. B.
THREE FIVE SIX RECEIVE
CLARIFYING AMENDS. IN CENTER
PROCREATION THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR HIVE OF THE CV.
PRODUCT ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS I
DON'T. HEARING C. NINE MEMBERS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING TO YEAH UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL TO FOLLOW AT A ONE SIX
FOUR. HERE IN C. NINE ALL EYES.
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
MOVING TO FOLLOW ADAM ONE SIX
FIVE. WE HAVE CENTER LAVE US
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY REALLY. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY OF
SIX MEDIALLY. CENTER LEVEL
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
AB SIX NINETY ONE WOULD ENSURE
THAT ALL TOP TEMPERATURES ARE
AUTHORIZED TO ADMINISTER CLIA
WAIVED COVERT TESTS INCLUDE
NINETEEN VACCINES AND EFFORT TO
HELP IDENTIFY AND STOP THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. CLEARLY
THE COOK NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AS OF
SEPTEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THERE WERE FOUR MILLION
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY CONFIRMED
CASES OF COVERT NINETEEN IN
CALIFORNIA. RESULTING IN SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND THIRTY DS MEMBERS
ONE OF THE WAYS WE CAN HELP
LESSEN THE LONG TERM IMPACTS OF
COVER NINETEEN A CALIFORNIA.
HAVING ACCESS TO VACCINES
CURRENT LAW AUTHORIZES
IMMUNIZATION CERTIFIED
OPTOMETRISTS TO ADMINISTER
THREE VACCINEFOR THOSE EIGHTY
THREE VACCINES FOR THOSE
EIGHTEEN OR OLDER WHICH INCLUDE
INFLUENZA. HERPES ZOSTER VIRUS
A NEW A CAUCUS THE CLINICAL
LABORATORY IMPROVEMENT
AMENDMENTS OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WAIVED POINT OF CARE
TESTS FOR CODE NINETEEN. FOLLOW
UP CONFERENCE ARE AUTHORIZED TO
ADMINISTER CLEAR WAVE TEST
THEIR RESTRICTED RESTRICTED BY
CONDITIONS. EIGHTY SIX NINETY
ONE WITH A DRESS THIS ISSUE IN
A NUMBER OF WAYS FIRST IT
AUTHORIZES OPTOMETRISTS TO
APPLY TO THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
FUHRMAN IMMUNIZATION
CERTIFICATE. TO MR COVERT
NINETEEN VACCINE. CATION FORM
FOR IMMUNIZATION CERTIFICATION
AND EXPAND THE CERTIFICATE TO
COVER THE ADMINISTRATION.
ADMINISTRATION OF IMMUNIZATION
FOR COVERT NINETEEN FINALLY IT
AUTHORIZES OPTOMETRISTS TO
PERFORM A CLEAR WAVE CLINICAL
LABORATORY TEST. NECESSARY TO
DETECT THE PRESENCE OF COVERT
NINETEEN MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING CENA AND MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLY OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THE
FOLLOWING A ONE SIX FAR. ENCINO
OBJECTION ALL EYES THIRTY EIGHT
MILLS ZERO. THE URGE ON THE
URGENCY. ALL EYES THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBER WERE UPON OUR
FINAL. I DON'T OF TONIGHT.
WE'RE DEALING WITH FILE ITEM
ONE SIX SIX SENATOR RALPH HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS CENTER
OFF THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS
BILL EXPANDS ACCESS TO QUALITY
EYE CARE BY AUTHORIZING UPTIME
INTERESTS TO TREAT ADDITIONAL
CONDITIONS OF THE EYES THAT
FALL WITHIN THEIR TRAINING. IN
ADDITION THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE TO PERFORM
ADDITIONAL PROCEDURES UNDER
SUPERVISION NO OPPOSITION NOVO
NO VOTES NOTA VOTES. MODI THANK
YOU. OKAY ARE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEN NONE- IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
OUR YOU KNOW AND THROW CALL ON
THE SIDE OF. HEARING SEEING
NONE OF THE I. SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO. HI ARE. THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS BUSINESS SENATOR
ACHEN STUFF HOUSE IS CLEAN AND
IT'S JUST AS CLEAR. MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR A VERY
VERY BUSY AND PRODUCTIVE DAY.
THANK YOU FOR SOME VERY
COLORFUL AND INTERESTING
STATEMENTS TONIGHT- I HOPE YOU
GO HOME GET SOME REST COME BACK
TOMORROW AND I HOPE THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM PASADENA WORKS A
LITTLE HARDER. ON SOME OF THOSE
INTERESTING- STATEMENTS HE
WOULD LIKE US TO INCORPORATE
INTO OUR LEGISLATION SO HAVING
ISSUED THAT CHALLENGE MR
PRESIDENT FOR. MORE CREATIVITY
TOMORROW I SAY HAVE A GOOD
NIGHT AND WE WILL BE BACK
TOMORROW THURSDAY SEPTEMBER
EIGHTH NINTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT TEN AM YES WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO MORE CREATIVITY. THE SENATE
WILL BE IT WILL BE ADJOURNED
WILL RECONVENE TOMORROW
THURSDAY AT TEN AM.